foreign
stack development video this full course
video will cover various Technologies
used in application development
the video will go in depth for each tool
and framework in the roadmap to become a
successful full stack developer
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our Channel already make
sure to hit the Subscribe button and the
bell icon to never miss an update so
here's what we'll be covering in this
session first we look at a simple
introduction to what exactly full stack
development is then we'll learn the most
popularly used version control system
that is git which helps you manage your
project files
next we look at a tutorial on the
commonly used front-end framework that
is angular
moving on we'll understand back-end
development and learn about node.js
talking about database Management
Systems we look at tutorials on mongodb
and MySQL now after this we look at an
angular tutorial on how to build an
admin dashboard moving further ahead
we'll have a section covering Maven and
Jenkins
finally coming to testing tools we learn
the working of selenium and lastly we'll
conclude the session by understanding
the popularly used continuous
integration and continuous development
tool Docker I hope you're excited for
this video so let's Jump Right In so now
what exactly is front end every time you
open a website it has several UI
components and once you click on a
particular icon say sign in in this case
you get navigated to the sign in or the
login page right so what happens is that
all of these items facilitate navigation
and utility
these are collectively called as the
front end
so the front end is the visible part of
the website or the web application which
is responsible for user experience the
user directly interacts with the
front-end portion of the website or the
web application
so now let's have a look at some of the
front-end languages so I'm sure you've
heard of HTML CSS in JavaScript so these
are collectively called the front-end
languages when it comes to HTML it
defines the structure of websites and
formats the web pages it also defines
text documentation so let's look at a
simple example so here I've made use of
the H1 tag which is the heading tag in
HTML and have displayed the message
hello welcome
so correspondingly my website displays
the same message
so HTML is responsible or defines what
is being shown on the website next up is
CSS now CSS is a style sheet that allows
you to alter and style different web
components be it size font spacing Etc
it makes the content on the website look
more decorative correct so now if you
have a look at the code here I've added
some styling I've changed the font style
to italic I've made the text bold and
I've changed the color to red and again
correspondingly all the changes are seen
on the website
moving on we have JavaScript now
JavaScript is a very powerful
client-side scripting language and it is
mainly used for enhancing the
interaction of a user with the web page
so again if you have a look at the code
here I've created a form wherein the
user can enter their name and I've also
displayed the message please enter your
name as a result an input box is made
available whether user can type in their
name now this is facilitated by
JavaScript so as I mentioned earlier it
is used to make web pages interactive
and bring the web applications to life
so next let's have a look at some
front-end Frameworks and libraries now
most of these are JavaScript Frameworks
and libraries first we have react then
there's angular there's view there's
jQuery and then there's bootstrap now
all of these help develop the front end
of the application however when it comes
to react angular in view it's not
necessary that you must know everything
to create a website one of them will be
sufficient however the usage of react is
on the rise and most of the developers
prefer using react jQuery and bootstrap
are also powerful Frameworks that can be
used used to create interactive web
pages now that you know what front-end
development is you must be wondering how
the data is being fetched and how this
data is being presented in front of you
on your screen correct now this is all
facilitated by the back end of the
application so let's understand what
back-end development is
now back end basically refers to the
server-side development of the
application
it is responsible for managing all the
database with the help of queries and
apis so every time the user makes a
request it queries the database and
retrieves the data from the database and
presents it to the user
and lastly it ensures data consistency
so now let's have a look at some
back-end languages and Frameworks
firstly we have node node and express.js
are packages provided by JavaScript
then there's python which is a very
popularly used language python
Frameworks like Django and flask are
popularly used to create the backend of
applications
then there's Java and Java provides
spring and Java server faces which are
also used for backend development then
there's c-sharp which provides
Frameworks like asp.net core and asp.net
MVC and other popularly used back-end
languages are PHP this Pearl and Ruby
database is the collection of
interrelated data which helps an
efficient retrieval insertion and
deletion of data from database and
organizes the data in the form of tables
views schemas reports now some of the
commonly used database Management
systems are MySQL there's postgresql
there's Microsoft SQL Server this Oracle
database and then there's mongodb today
I am going to cover a few essential git
commands and walk you through a
demonstration for most of it I begin by
installing a git bash or the git client
and configuring it for its first time
usage once I'm done with configuring the
git client I'm going to spin up few
repositories locally and work on these
repositories using git commands once I'm
happy with my local changes I'm going to
commit few of them and then push these
changes to a git server of my choice for
today's demonstration I plan to use
github.com which is a cloud hosted free
service and it provides free account
registrations for anyone eventually I
will cover few topics regarding git
branching and merging because these two
in my opinion are the killer features of
the get distributed Version Control tool
kit is one of the most popular
distributed Version Control tools of
recent times and like any other
distributed Version Control tool it
allows us to perform various Version
Control tasks without really needing a
network connection before I jump into my
demonstration let me spend some time
explaining to you the git client server
working model what does it take for a
couple of users to collaborate and start
working with Git the bare minimal thing
that any user would need in order to
start working with kit is something
called as git bash or the git client
this comes as an installer for all
popular operating systems like Windows
all flavors of Windows Linux Mac OS and
other operating systems so once you
install git bash you get a command line
utility using which you can fire up your
git commands and ensure that you can
bring up repositories you can work with
these repositories by adding files to it
committing changes to it and all those
git commands would work perfectly well
so you can bring up a small repository
and you can work with your repository
using this git bash but what does it
take for you to share this repository
with another user who has also got
gitpash installed on this system this is
where you would need something called as
a git server so for user one or one user
to share his repository with another
user he would need to collaborate using
something called as a git server so in
the present Market there are a bunch of
git servers which are popularly
available some of them are free some of
them come with a cost because they are
licensed a bunch of these servers that I
can think of are GitHub which is one of
the most popular git servers that is
around in the market for a long time now
it comes with two variants one is the
cloud hosted one which is the github.com
and then the other one is an Enterprise
server which comes as a black box that
can be installed into your data centers
so typically organizations who don't
want their source code to be put up on
the cloud but go for this GitHub
Enterprise servers wherein the buy this
servers and these servers are hosted on
their data centers other popular variant
of the git server is bitbucket this is
from the famous atlasian products and it
integrates very well with all other
atlasian products like jiram in recent
times there's one other variant of the
git server called gitlab which is
getting very very popular these days
because gitlab not just provides a git
server it also provides something called
as a runner this is a part of the
continuous integration strategy where as
soon as you have a source code check-in
that is going in you have this Runner
that kicks up and builds your particular
project so all these are bundled
together in a gitlab and gitlab also
provides you with a Community Edition
which is almost free of cost having said
that there are a bunch of these tools
available for my demonstration what I'm
going to do is I've already registered
myself on the github.com by providing my
username and my password and I'm going
to use a free account so whatever
repositories that I'm going to put up on
this server is all public by default so
I will register Myself by using my
username or my email ID and my password
so this set of authentication is also
referred to as https authentication so
in order for me to share my repository
with say user 2. the first thing that I
got to do is have an access to a git
server where both user 1 and user 2 are
set up so once I have that I can push my
repository onto to this server and
provide right kind of access so that
user 2 or the other developer whoever
wishes to collaborate with me on this
repository can use his credentials as
long as is registered properly on the
git server he can use his credentials
and pull down this repository and work
with this repository so this is the
https way of authenticating and sharing
repositories another popular way of
sharing repositories or working with
each other is called as SSH
authentication as many of you would know
SSH means nothing but creation of a
private and a public key a bunch of keys
public and private are created on the
client machine while I create a keys I
will be asked for a passphrase I need to
type in a passphrase and remember my
passphrase and then I take this public
key and kind of post it on to my account
within my git server so that whenever
I'm going to connect next time using my
command prompt or any of the tools it's
going to challenge me for my passphrase
as long long as I remember my passphrase
correctly I can authenticate myself and
get into the server so both https and
SSH are popular ways of communicating
with the git server having said this let
me just get started by installing the
git bash on my local system and then
fire up some of these git commands and
build up some repositories make some
changes in my repository commit these
changes and later use my GitHub
credential to connect to my GitHub
server and push my repositories out
there
let me now go ahead and find my git bash
for my windows so that I can go ahead
and install it so I just type in get
client for windows open up a browser and
type in for this the first one that I
find is a GUI tool I don't need this GUI
client I need this one so this is the
git client or the git batch that I was
referring to it's about 40 Megs and let
me just download this pause this video
for some time so that the download
happens and come back to you once I have
the download the download seems to be
complete when I'm recording this video
the version that I have the latest
version that is there is 2.19.0 and this
is a 64-bit version for Windows so I've
got that downloaded let me go ahead and
find it and install this EXE
all right I go ahead choosing all the
default options I want it to be
installed in SQL and program files under
the git folder everything looks good for
me I'm not going to make any changes
here
get Bash from Windows yes I may want to
use git from Windows command prompt that
sounds good for me open SSH that's fine
next card looks good no I don't want any
of these new features
so what I'm doing is installing the git
bash or the git client so that I can
start using my git commands
and the motion that I'm using is
2.19.0 which as I record this video this
happens to be the latest version
all right so looks good I don't want to
see the release notes I'll say again
launch git Bash
so what I get is this window so this is
the git command prompt so let me check
if everything is looking good it's a Git
Version it sounds good say get help all
right a lot of git help commands
everything looks good so I ended up
installing the git bash I can go ahead
with all other commands
now that I have git bash installed on my
system let me open up a git bash prompt
and start using it but before I do
anything I just need to configure It For
the First Time stating what would be the
username and the email ID with which I
want the git bash to be configured with
the command to do that is get config
hyphen iPhone Global which means that
this setting that I'm going to set would
be a global setting user dot name and
this the name of the user would need to
be specified within a double code in my
case I am using a simply learn account
which is the official account and this
is the particular username of this
account the other setting is nothing but
git config hyphen iPhone Global this is
also a global setting
and this would be the email ID
the email ID need not contain a double
quote
so in my case this is the email ID that
I would be setting up git to work with
all right let me check if the
configurations were set correctly or not
all right if you see this the username
and the email ID has been picked up the
way I wanted it to be picked up looks
good so far alright so what do we do
next by default whenever you open up the
git prompt you are placed into your home
directory let me create a folder here
which would be a repository folder from
where I'm going to create all my
multiple git repositories so I will
create a folder called let's say git
underscore demo
all right
there's already a folder called git demo
so let me just delete that in the first
place and let me create this git demo
again
all right let me navigate to this
particular folder
so this is the folder let me open up
that folder using a command prompt
this is my git demo so this would be a
folder so I would use this folder as a
base folder for creating all other
repositories as a part of this demo so
let me create my first repository a
repository is nothing but a folder so
let me create my first folder called
first repo
and let me
get into this repo all right as of now
this is just an empty folder
if at all I navigate to this you could
see that this folder is empty there's
nothing much in this folder at all at
this moment
okay so let me create a repository out
of this how do I create a repository of
this is pretty simple I just run a git
init command
when I say kit in it it means it's going
to initialize a repository as of now
the folder contained nothing in it was
an empty repository so it initially is
an empty repository in this particular
folder for all I look at my content you
would see that there's a hidden folder
this would be a hidden folder since I've
configured my Explorer to view all
hidden folders I see it otherwise you
wouldn't see it so a folder by name dot
get is created within this first repo
and this was created because we ran the
command kit init
if I get into this folder I see a bunch
of directories and other configurations
if you see there's something called as a
hooks directory a couple of
configuration files that are here in
this directory all these relate to one
or the other type of a client hook that
can be enabled and this info this
objects
this references a bunch of stuff that is
there
so what is this folder this is a magical
git folder and this is created whenever
a repository is initialized so by
default if at all you get into any git
folder or any git repository you would
see this dot get folder a word of
caution do not get into this folder and
try to modify anything because if you
fiddle around with this and correct this
particular folder your whole repository
will go for a toss so let me come out of
this
and let me show you another thing now if
you notice here when I was in the folder
the repository did not have anything
after this now when I say git in it
there is something called as a master
that shows up so typically what happens
is whenever a git repository is created
for the first time it creates a default
Branch the name of the branch is called
master and that is why you would see
Master within braces this doesn't mean
anything else other than we have a
repository out in this particular folder
and by default there is a branch called
master and we are currently on that
Branch if at all I create multiple
branches in this folder whenever I
navigate to different branches the
branch name within this brackets would
change all right so far so good so we
created a folder we made it a git
repository by initializing that with the
git in it and then I'm not put anything
yet in the repository so let me try to
do that let me create a few files within
this particular repository so I use a
touch command touch is a Linux command
it kind of creates this particular
folder if all you're not comfortable
with the file creation by this way you
can always use a file explorer and
create some files in this so I create a
file called touch master.txt I'll open
up in the notepad
okay so this is my first file that's
what I'm gonna write inside this
I save this and it come out of this all
right now let me do a git status command
so what does this tell you there's no
commit set you're in the master Branch
there is an untracked file and this
shows up in thread it also gives you all
the commands that is supposed to be run
so if at all you want to add this file
you would say git add and the name of
the file and then you're going to commit
it
so what happened is that when the
repository was initialized it was an
empty repository now that a git notices
that there is a new file in this
repository called master.txt if at all
you want you want us to let git know
that you want to track this file we need
to add this to the repository so the
command to add that is called git add I
can specify either the name of the file
or I can give a wild character saying
git add dot now if I run the git status
command again
it says there's no commits yet added a
file and the file which was earlier in
red now shows up in green and it says
it's a new file master.txt all right it
also gives you something called git
remove command if at all you want to
unstage or undo your changes so what has
happened is the file which was earlier
untracked has been added into the git
index or it is ready for staging or it's
in a staged State now I can go ahead and
comment this file if at all that's what
I want to do so let me do that
I'll do a kit commit minus M and I give
a message that I want I would say this
is my first get commit
all right I run the get status command
again and see it says on the branch
Master nothing to commit it's all nice
and clean so typically what happened was
I created a empty directory made it into
a git folder by doing a git in it I put
a file into it I made some changes to
the file I added that file into the
repository and I committed to the
repository if it were I run the git log
command
it says this was the commit ID or the
commit number or the commit hashtag and
this is the author if you notice this is
the email ID and the username that we
set earlier and this was done on this
date and this is the
commit message that is there all of it
looks so good let me do one more commit
into this repository so I will touch
Master One Dot text I'll put in another
file
I'll open up this particular file
write something into this
all right I save this change
let me also open up the older
file make some more change into this
all right so what I did I modified the
older file that existed I also added a
new file to my repository now if I run
the get status command
it says modified this file which is
showing in red and it says you have one
more file which is an untracked file
all right now let me add both these
files because these are the changes that
I want to
incorporate I would say git add dot I
run the git status command again
and it says now this is a modified file
this is a new file looks good to me let
me go ahead and Commit This so git
commit with the message let's say is
this is my second commit
all right
if I do git log now it shows both the
commits the first commit is the one that
that shows up at the bottom and the
topmost one is the latest commit that is
there so far so good if at all you
notice I'm doing all these git commands
without really connecting it to any git
server I don't need any network
connection for doing any of these things
I can keep on doing more and more git
commands and run git commands the way I
want to
without really having any connections to
the kit server now that I have my
changes the way I wanted and I've
checked in all the code changes into my
local repository I may want to share my
repository with somebody else and work
in a collaborative way so the way to do
that is as I mentioned earlier to host
this repository or to push this
repository onto a git server I already
have a GitHub account wherein I've
registered myself using my username and
password so I log into my GitHub account
using my username and credentials and
let me go ahead and create a new
Repository
my repository is already there on the
local system so what I essentially need
is just a placeholder for my repository
so that I can link them together and
push the content from my local
repository to the server
if you notice the name of my repository
is his first repo
so let me copy this I would create a
folder structure or a repository
structure on the server with the same
name so that when I pushed my repository
from my local box it will go ahead and
get created in the server so the
repository name should be the same as
what I created on my local box
description I would say this is my first
get Hub Repository
on the server
this is just an optional description
that will show up and if you notice
I can't have any private repositories so
whatever repositories that I'm going to
create here would be a public repository
so I choose public and I don't want to
initialize this with a readme file or
anything of that because I already have
a repository with some content with some
code checked in all that I need is a
placeholder for my repository on the
server so with this option with just a
name and with an optional description
and the repository being public I go
ahead and click on the create repository
button
so if you notice it gives me a bunch of
commands that I would need to run in
order to create a repository and push it
onto the server and also important point
it shows me two URLs one is the HTTP s
URL and the other one is the SSH URL as
of now we do not have any SSH keys that
is set up so let me use this https URL
to connect my local repository with the
repository on this server
so I've done all these things I already
have the repository set up all that I
need is a placeholder for me to connect
my local repository with the server URL
so this would be the command that I need
to copy
but essentially links or ads and origin
with the URL of the git server I just
copy this command
and run it here
get remote add the name of the remote is
called origin and it points to an https
URL which is nothing but the placeholder
that I've created on the server
all right so let me check if it's added
correctly
okay the URL looks good I'm all set I've
got two comments in my repository I'm
done with all the changes so let me try
to push my repository onto the server
the command for doing it for the first
time is git push hyphen U this is for
linking the Upstream
origin master
so git push hyphen U Upstream linking
origin master link the master
branch of my local repository with the
master branch on the server repository
and where is it going to push it is
going to push by default to An Origin
and the origin points to this URL all
right let me try doing this
so it essentially opens up an URL asking
me the credentials with which I need to
log into my GitHub server so let me just
copy and paste
the username and the password with which
I have registered
I would say login
okay success so I am able to create a
repository on the server and the content
seems to be pushed and it created a new
branch called Master it is linked the
master Branch from the local repository
with the master branch on the server so
let me go back to my server and refresh
this page
and see if all my commits have come in
master master one dot text fit all I see
the commits they seem to be two commits
this is my first comment this is my
second comment and if at all you notice
each of this commit comes with a hash
key or a hash ID which contains the
details of my commits in this commit the
files were added this was the line that
was added if you look at the second
commit
I added these lines
I made this you know one line chain that
was there I also added this new file
which was not existing these are the two
commits that existed
and if you see
the timestamp of the Commit This is the
commit which was committed for 15
minutes ago so what does this mean is
that the commit is the timestamp when we
actually commented the code in the
client the pushing is just after we've
committed the change we have pushed it
so there's no time stamp of the push
that happened
this completes the first part of the
tutorial wherein I create a repository
on the client and then I pushed it to
the server after creating a repository
Skeleton on the server
now let me demonstrate to you the SSH
configuration that is required for
creating a pair of SSH keys and ensuring
that I connect to the GitHub server
using the SSH mechanism so for doing
that I need to First create a pair of
private and public key the command to do
that is SSH Keygen
hyphen T I will use the RSA mechanism
for creating my keys Capital C and I
need to specify the email ID using which
I'm going to connect to all right I need
to create the keys for
all right so generating a private and
public key pair it says let me know what
folder should I create the keys in so by
default the keys are created in the user
home directory under a DOT SSH folder so
this is pretty good for me so let me go
ahead and say that that's fine enter a
passphrase so let me enter some
passphrase
keep in mind that I would need to
remember my passphrase because when I'm
going to authenticate myself using SSH
mechanism it will challenge me for this
particular passphrase I need to enter
the right passphrase so that I get
authenticated
so the key is generated and by default
it is created in this particular folder
so let me go over to that particular
folder
and this is the folder where the keys is
generated you would see a public key and
a private key that is created let me
open up the public key with a notepad
and then copy the contents of the whole
file
and now I would need to stick it in
on the server so that I can get myself
authenticated using SSH keys so I've
logged in to GitHub using my credentials
and go to my settings
and you would see an SSH and gpg keys
let me click on that as of now there are
no SSH key or gpg keys so I would click
on new SSH key and let me paste my
public key that I've copied and I would
say add SSH key
it prompts me for my password just to
make sure that
I've got the right kind of
authentication to be adding a new key so
this one looks good that means the keys
were added successfully let me check if
my SSH keys are working well
so I do SSH hyphen capital T I would say
get
at github.com
this is just to double check if my SSH
keys
are authenticated correctly are you sure
you want the connection yes you want to
continue yes
all right now a check for my passphrase
let me enter my passphrase I hope I
remember it correctly
all right
triggered I've been successfully
authenticated so that means now my SSH
keys are good and just by using my
passphrase I can connect to my GitHub
server using SSH all right so for the
Second Use case what I would do is
create a repository on the server with
some content in it and then clone that
repository cloning is nothing but making
a copy of that repository linking the
origin so that I create an exact replica
of the repository which is there on the
server on my local drive so let me first
create a repository on the server I'll
create a new Repository
let me give a name for my repository and
let me kind of initialize that with the
readme file I would call this my second
repo
give some description
this is my second repo
that is created straight
on the git server on the GitHub server
to be precise
it's a public repository this time I am
going to choose this option the reason
being that I don't want to create just a
skeleton as of now I want to create a
repository with some readme file in it a
random readme file with no content in it
but then I want a repository to be
created on the server all right I say
create a repository
So Random readme file with some content
in it gets created and I can see there
are two URLs to this repository https
and SSH so this time let me copy the SSH
URL so that I will use this URL to clone
this repository on the server
rather from the server to my local box
right so let me navigate to my root
folder the folder that I created for
making all my repositories git
repositories if you see my first deposit
is already here so let me clone my
repository the second repo that I
created on the server the command to do
that is git clone the URL of the
repository that I want to clone
oops looks like I didn't copy the URL
correctly let me copy that again
copy this URL
all right so if you notice there is no
https to it I'm just cloning the URL
that is SSH URL of the Repository
it asks for my passphrase again
okay
so I just had first repository earlier
now I have something called a second
repo this is an exact replica of
whatever was the repository content that
was created on the server so if I get
into
the repository there is just a simple
readme file that is there let me try to
add a new file out here I would say
Notepad
second dot text
some text file I'm going to put in here
yes definitely you will not find that
file there
this is my second
file that
I will push onto the server
I'm going to put in some content out
there
and save this
and if I do get status
it says this this is a new contract file
you want to add this file onto the
repository do you want to track this
file yes I definitely want to track this
file let me also commit my change to the
file
with a message
this is my first
commit for the second repo
I given some particular message
and this time around since I cloned my
repository from a server the origin is
already set for me I don't really need
to add the origin and all that stuff
because what happened in the first case
was that I was creating a repository
from my local box and then pushing
another server which is why I had to set
up the Upstream branches and stuff like
that in this case I have cloned an
existing repository from the server so
when I clone I get the replica along
with all references to my repository so
I don't need to do anything more I'll
then push the content I'll just say get
push to be in the safer side I would say
origin and master
ask me for the passphrase
okay you post the content onto the
server let me see if the contents have
come in here okay wonderful I had only
one commit now I see my second comment
so what was added as a part of the
second comment it says a new file was
added all this line that never existed
got added this is the second file the
content exactly what I pushed onto the
server
now this completes the tutorial when I
create a repository on the server cloned
it made some changes to the repository
and pushed it to the server using SSH
quick recap of all the git commands that
we ran till now get init is used to
initialize the repository so if at all
you are creating a local repository you
can get into any of the folder which is
not a git repository and run this
command whenever you run this command a
magical folder by name dot kits gets
created in the folder and from that time
onwards git will start tracking any
changes that happen to that particular
folder it also creates a new repository
and a branch by default the branch that
is created is called the master Branch
git add dot is a wildcard character for
adding any number of new files into your
git repository if you have a bunch of
files one file two file 10 files a
folder containing multiple files in it
all of them could be added into the
repository using this command so once
you add any number of files into the
repository you can keep on adding more
and more files into the repository once
you're done with that you want to commit
the change changes that has happened in
the repository you use the git commit
command git commit hyphen M with a
meaningful message this will commit all
the work items that you have done in
terms of the files that got changed the
files that got added all this with one
particular message get status will give
you the status of all the files and
folders any file that got added any file
that got created any file that was
deleted all the status of the files will
be obtained using the git status command
git log will show you all the commit
history with the latest history or the
latest commit showing up on top git add
remote origin this command is used
whenever you want to link any local
repository to a server and this is when
you want to really push a repository
from the local to the server for the
first time git push hyphen U origin and
master this is the command that you
would use whenever you want to push
contents from the local repository to
the server git clone and the URL of the
server this is the command that you
would run whenever you have an existing
repository on the server and you want to
make a fresh clone or a fresh copy of
that particular repository onto your
local box
more than often many developers or git
users find themselves in situations
where they would want to go back in
history and modify or change some of the
files that they recently committed or
checked into the repository now from a
perspective of get this is a very very
simple activity however my perspective
Version Control tool you will have to be
really cautious about the chain that
you're gonna do in case the changes are
pretty local none of the developers or
none of the other users who are
collaborating with you would be affected
by this change you are good to go ahead
and make this change however if your
repository has been pushed to the server
and you're trying to modify something
from history this would have a very bad
or adverse effect on all the other users
who will be using it you need to be
really cautious while running these
commands in case your repository
contents are local if you've not pushed
your changes to your repository and if
at all you made some changes to the
repository maybe to fix a defect or to
include a new feature and you missed few
things you can go ahead and modify this
with some of these commands let's say I
have this simple repository called undo
undo repo and if at all I look at the
logs of these I have the commit
histories which are like this
I have about five commits that is there
in my repository and in C1 I've added a
file in C2 I added the file in C3 I've
also added some file in C4 I made some
changes to M1 and M3 and in C5 I have
added another file called M4 now this is
my comment history now let's say I made
these two commits but possibly I want to
Club them together along with some other
changes because whatever changes I did
did not really fix things the way I
expected it to fix so there is a git
command called git reset this would
allow me to go back in history to go
back to any of the snapshot get rid of
all this commit history on the commit
messages but retain the changes that
were made as a part of these comments so
if at all I need to go back in history
and go back to this particular comment
and however I just want to get rid of
these commits that are there in terms of
the commit messages but I want the
changes that were there as a part of
these commits to still exist I would do
command called get reset hyphen iPhone
soft
now this would go back or unwind my
changes back to this particular snapshot
getting rid of all the commit messages
that were there as a part of these two
comments but a soft would ensure that
the file changes that were done as a
part of these two commits would still
exist a full remain so the command for
that is git reset hyphen iPhone soft
which is the snapshot that I want to get
back to if this is the comment that I
want to get back to I just copy this
and paste this
all right it doesn't give me any message
but if at all I do a git log pretty one
line
what it says is 7 C2 now the head which
is nothing but the current pointer which
is earlier pointing to C5 it's gone back
to C3 now what happened to the changes
that were there as a part of C4 and C5
if at all you do a git status if you see
the changes that were part of C4 was
some changes to M1 and M2 and C5 a new
file got M4 got added if I do a git
status
you'll see those changes still exist
however from the git history or the git
commit history C3 is the topmost comment
that exists as of now c4 and C5 have
been currently read off but the changes
that were there still exist
all right now I can make some more
changes that I want if as a part of my
commit and possibly go ahead and commit
this whole thing as a new commit
altogether maybe I'll open up a notepad
and possibly create a new file called
m6.txt
and say one new file that was missed out
I make this change I go to a get status
all these files are still there I would
send it add dot I also get
commit hyphen m
C4
rewriting history
and I do a git
vlog
pretty
there you go so C1 C2 C3 still existed
and whatever was a part of C4 and C5 the
older ones I have gotten rid of this
along with those old changes I also
added a new file I made some changes and
I was able to comment it now if you look
at my git history it's all nice and
clean however do this activity only when
you don't push your git repository to
the server one other most powerful and
useful command while undoing or
resetting the history is something
called as revert this is a safe way of
undoing some things remember what I
talked about when exactly you can do a
reset it's only when your changes are
local and is not being pushed to the
repository take this scenario wherein
let's say I have a git server
and I have the changes which are C1
C2
C3
and possibly C4
all right so this is a bunch of comments
that has happened this was the oldest
comment and this is the newest comment
and if at all developer 1 is the one
who's responsible for pushing these
contents
in the first place so he has got C1 to
C4 on his history
I'm going to jump all these C2 and C3
and get into C4 and he's pushed all
these contents out here and there are a
bunch of people from the server who has
pulled this repository and all of them
are the same level
now imagine a use case where developer
won then figures out that by mistake he
put in the C3 which is a wrong thing to
do and possibly you know he could have
done a better job of fixing this in a
different way so he wants to get rid of
the C3 or C4 or any one of these
comments
if he's going to do that and push it to
the server first of all the git server
would not allow him to go back in
history but assuming that he forcibly
pushed something
what would happen to all these people
who are looking to work ahead from C4
all of them would be affected in an
adverse way so in short never go back in
history if at all you need to undo
something go ahead and put in a new
comment to undo something
let's take this example maybe if at all
a developer one wants to get rid of C3
better way to do that is by adding a new
commit which is ahead say let's say C5
and what does this commit to this commit
possibly gets rid of C3 instead of going
back in history it actually is taking
your git history ahead but as a part of
this commit you are undoing some part of
the work that was done as a part of C3
in short you're removing a commit but to
remove a commit you are adding a new
commit and this is why you're doing it
because there are a bunch of other
people who are you are using this
repository collaboratively and what plan
to get ahead in terms of History they
cannot afford to go back in history and
modify something in history all right
the command to do this is called the get
revert command
so let me take up this repository which
has got a bunch of commits in it and if
at all I do a git log
pretty one line
I have these bunch of comments
and C1 I've added a file in C to our
other file in C3 I've added one more
file and in C4 I made some changes and
this is the latest commit and this is
the oldest commit so if at all I see the
contents of the git folder it contains
M1 m2m3 and M4 and let's say looking at
the previous use case that I mentioned I
may want to get rid of this particular
comment
I want to get rid of the C3 which is
nothing but I've added a file called
m3.text but I added it by mistake I need
a better way of fixing it possibly I
look at it later on but for now I don't
want this particular commit and the
changes that were made as a part of that
commit to exist so the better way to do
that is using the git revert command so
git revert and the commit ID whatever I
want to revert so if I want to revert
this
I copy this particular commit ID and
bear in mind that considering a reset
revert works on one commit at a time so
I can do one commit revert at a time I
can Club a bunch of them together and do
one commit but otherwise the revert
always works on one commit at a time so
git revert
business
essentially what I'm trying to do I'm
trying to undo this particular commit
while I'm undoing this commit what does
git do it safely adds a new commit and a
part of this new commit it unders
whatever changes that were done as a
part of this command so if I say git
revert this
all right I forgot to mention a message
which is why this window is showing up
but that message is good for me I say
write and quit
all right and if I do a git log
all right if you see this C1 still is
there in history and our history is
going ahead from C5 I see another commit
but what was there as a part of this
comment actually is getting rid of this
commit C3 so if at all I see my files
here there's only M1 M2 and M4
M3 was added as a part of C3 now I've
gotten rid of M3 by getting rid of the
revert command for C3 so this is a
better way of undoing things
now that we have acquainted ourselves
with few of those basic gig commands let
me get into a very very interesting
topic regarding it which is about
branching the topic is interesting
because git deals with branches in a
completely different way compared to any
other version control tool in most of
the Version Control tools whenever you
create a new Branch a complete copy or a
subset of the whole repository is
created which in my opinion is very very
cost inefficient because it's a very
very expensive operation both in times
of time and the disk space however in
Git You just create a very very
lightweight movable pointer whenever you
create a branch there is no folder or no
copy of the repository that is created
in short the branches are very very
inexpensive and great so go ahead and
create any number of branches that you
need however once you create your
branches do all the work relating to
that branch in that specific branch and
once you've completed your task go ahead
and merge your branches back into your
base branch and then delete the branch
let me go ahead and create a repository
with some branches in this and give you
a demonstration of that
so let me go back to my base directory
which is git demo and then I'm going to
create a new folder here
I'll create a folder called Arc details
all right this is my folder here
all right by navigating to this folder
and let me create a repository here I
initial as a repository a DOT git folder
is created without any files in it so
let me create a few files in it
say notepad name dot text
organization name
I create a name.txt within this maybe
I'll create one more file in this
Notepad
employees.txt
foreign
some content in this save this content
all right
so if I try to get status I just see two
files in it so let me go ahead and add
these two files and let me commit my
changes it's okay
commit hyphen am or iPhone m
First Command
so if I do a git log
I see only one commit and there are two
files here you can see those two files
that is here
all right so at this stage let me go
ahead and create a new branch
and the command for creating new branch
is get Branch name of the branch so let
me name my branches Bangalore Branch blr
branch
and this created a branch but I don't
see any changes in the folder structure
or in the file that exists here I've
just created this Branch so if it all I
do a git branch
I see these two branches and whatever
star means I am currently in this master
Branch so let me go ahead and get into
the blr branch at this moment the number
of files that exist in this repository
is same there's absolutely no change in
any of the branches both master and
Baylor Branch point to the same snapshot
so let me get into
the other branch and the command to do
that is git checkout
plr Branch now actually switched into
Bangalore Branch if you see the content
of the files this exactly two files the
way it was earlier because I've created
a branch from my base branch which is
the master branch and when I created a
branch there were two files existing
here if you see the content of these
files they would all be the same
all right so let me create a file that
is specific to Bangalore branch so I
will just say Notepad
maybe I want to put down the address of
this organization specific to Bangalore
in this address dot text so I see
notepad address dot text
we'll say simply learn
Bangor office
say located in
some arteries
I would say Bangalore
foreign
of this file
and I'm creating all this new file in
this blr Branch so I would sync it add
Dot and I would say git commit hyphen m
angalore
branch
comment
all right if you see this now I have an
address.txt which is there only in the
Bangalore branch that I am presently on
now let me switch back to my master
Branch the command to do that is git
checkout
Master Branch if you remember when I
forged out or when I created a new
Branch from the master Branch I didn't
have this address dot text in it so let
me go back to git git checkout Master
branch and keep noticing this particular
what happened to the address dot text
it kind of disappeared how did that
happen it's all because of this magical
git folder so what happened is now git
knows that when you are in the master
Branch the file that was there in the
Bangalore branch which was called the
address dot text didn't exist
so git is playing around with the file
system snapshot so if I come back let's
say I come back to git checkout
Bangalore branch
if you see this the address.txt file
appears
so this particular file is only present
in the branch and git is playing around
with the file system snapshot by moving
the pointers across and ensuring that
whenever I am switching to Bangalore
Branch I see this address dot text when
I go back to my master Branch I don't
say this Bangalore branch
contents which is the address dot text
all right now that I created this Branch
maybe I may need to push this onto the
server so let me go ahead and create a
particular repository structure on the
server similar to whatever we did in our
previous exercise
so the name of the folder needs to be
exactly this one so let me copy this
and let me create a repository very
quickly
go here and say new Repository
all right this
is the name of the Repository get Branch
demo this is what I'm going to put in as
a description I would say public I don't
want any readme files in it because I
already have a repository I will just
say create a repository
all right let me use
the SSH URL yeah this is this is a URL
this is good for me so let me copy this
URL
let me add it here
I'm linking my local repository with the
server and I would let me come back to
my master branch
let me first push my master Branch so I
would say git push hyphen U origin
master
it asks for my passphrase
all right
push my master Branch it looks good it
says New Branch Master is created so if
I go back to my server and it will
refresh
if you see it says only one branch
and it says what is the name of the
branch master
if you see the contents there is
employees.txt and name dot text now
let's try to push the other brands that
is there the command to do that is a
little different compared to
the way we created it on the client
because on the client we created the
branch with a git Branch command now
this Branch doesn't exist on the server
and I need to push this new Branch onto
the server so the command would be
get push hyphen new origin and the name
of the brand that I want to specifically
push
all right now it created a branch out
here
let me do a refresh of this
all right it says two branches
if I get into this Bangalore Branch I
will see the address dot text if at all
I go back into Master Branch I would not
see this under stock text
wonderful
now let me do one thing let me try to
get the changes from the branch that I
created back into the master branch that
is what I would mean by merging I would
want the changes that is there as a part
of the bangle Branch to come back into
my master Branch so if I go to click
checkout
Bangalore Branch I see this address.net
this is there only as a part of
Bangalore Branch now assuming that I am
done with the changes from the Bangalore
Branch I want to get those changes back
into my master so let me come back
to my master branch
and the way to merge in the changes is
get merge so what is that you want to
merge I want to merge the Bangalore
Branch changes and where will it merge
it will merge it into the current brands
that I'm on presently I'm in the master
Branch so this command would merge the
changes from the Bangalore Branch into
your master Branch so with this if we'll
keep looking here the content that was
there that was added as a part of
Bangalore branch which is nothing but
the address dot text this file should
appear as soon as we do a merge
all right so it happened quickly and you
would see this address dot text that is
here so if you see let's check the
contents in terms of the git log
all right so there's only one branch
that we had earlier which had only one
commit right now we are at this
Bangalore Branch commit which was there
as a part of the Bangalore Branch commit
so with this change let me push this
change onto the server as well git push
origin master
okay those changes were pushed to the
server and now
if at all I do a refresh out here
okay I mean two branches
the francis's master even if I'm in
master plans I should see this address
dot text that is there even if I'm in
the banker Branch the content is all
same because we immerse these two
branches now that I've merged this
Branch I don't need this Branch anymore
so I would go ahead and delete this
locally as well as push it under the
server so that it gets deleted from the
server as well so delete Branch locally
the command is get
Branch hyphen D and the name of the
branch
only thing you need to ensure is that
you should not be currently on that
branch which you're trying to delete so
I would say git branch
and I'm presently in the master Branch
so I can go ahead and delete the other
Branch so get Branch hyphen D Bangalore
branch
all right this got rid of our Pandora
Branch locally
if at all I don't get Branch hyphen Wii
it shows there's only one branch as of
now however this Branch would still
exist on the server because Server
doesn't know anything about the changes
that we have done we need to
specifically push our changes onto the
server
okay there are two branches still here
so let me go ahead and push these
changes so that the branch gets deleted
from the server as well the command to
do that is get
push
origin
hyphen hyphen delete and the name of the
branch
all right
so this went ahead and deleted the
branch from the server let's check that
okay if you see now there's only one
branch
these are the basic steps that you would
need to know before you work with any of
the branches within git and as I said
before the branches are very very
inexpensive in great go ahead and create
any number of branches that you want but
just ensure that once you create your
branch finish off your task and once you
finish off your task go ahead and delete
the branch and before you delete the
brands please ensure that you merge in
the branches so that you get in or take
in the work that was done as a part of
that particular Branch to summarize the
git branching commands are as follows to
create a new Branch you issue a command
git Branch the name of the branch and
this would automatically spin off or
create a new Branch from the existing
Branch from where you issue this command
if you are on the master branch and if
you execute this command git Branch new
underscore Branch it creates a new
underscore Branch from the master Branch
once you create a new branch in order to
get into this Branch you would type in
git checkout the name of the brand inch
this would automatically switch the file
system snapshot between different
branches now the branches that are
created are by default created on the
local repository in case you want to
push any specific Branch onto the server
you would have to issue a command get
push hyphen U origin and the name of the
branch so this will ensure that the
contents of the new Branch are pushed
onto this server at any time if you want
to list out all existing branches on
your local repositories the command
would be git Branch hyphen AV assuming
that you did all your work in a new
branch and you're happy with the changes
you would want to bring back those
changes into the master Branch the
command to merge the contents of any new
Branch into a master Branch would be git
merge and the name of the branch this
would automatically merge the branch
contents that you specified into the
branch on which you currently reside if
at all you're on the master branch and
if you issue a command git merge new
underscore Branch this would merge the
contents of the new Branch onto the
master Branch so once you merge the
contents of any branch you would
possibly want to go ahead and delete
this Branch so the command to delete
those branch locally is git Branch
hyphen capital D and the name of the
branch this again would delete the
branch locally in order to make this
change on the server which is in order
to remove this Branch from the server
the command to do that is git push
origin hyphen iPhone delete and the name
of the branch this would also delete the
brands that you created on the server in
this session we we're gonna cover the
topic of what is angular
I'm sure all of you use mobile and web
applications be it from social media to
healthcare e-commerce and net banking
these apps are used by billions of
people across the globe now the main
reason we use these apps is that they
offer seamless user experience and
interface
how would it develop provide such
reliability one of the Frameworks that
is widely used to build such robust apps
is angular so let's dive into the
session now so here is a list of topics
that we're going to be covering first up
we'll see why angular was introduced
then what is angular
features of angular
angular architecture advantages and
limitations of angular
the learning curve of angular and
finally we look at some of the companies
that deploy angular so without further
delay let's begin
why angular now JavaScript is the most
commonly used client-side scripting
language it is written into HTML
documents enabling interactions with web
pages in many unique ways
so as a relatively easy to learn
language with almost pervasive support
it is exceptionally well suited to
develop modern applications but the
question arises
is Javascript ideal for developing
single page applications that require
modularity testability and other
features perhaps not however we have a
variety of Frameworks and libraries
designed to help us with such thing with
respect to front-end development angular
and JavaScript together bring in
structure and consistency to your web
applications and also provide
scalability and maintainability
and angular is specifically developed
for single page applications so now the
question arises what exactly is angular
angular is an open source JavaScript
framework written completely in
typescript
now it was primarily aimed to develop
single page applications and is
maintained by Google
angular as a framework provides a few
advantages while also providing a
standard structure for Developers
designed for web desktop and mobile
platforms if you have a doubt here as to
what exactly single page applications
are let me help you with that now these
single page applications are basically
applications that get loaded just once
so the main page gets loaded onto your
browser so any further interactions does
not lead to loading of subsequent Pages
anything that has to be done further is
just an addition to the already loaded
page so these single page applications
are primarily developed using angular
moving ahead let's look at the features
of angular
we have four features that we're going
to be discussing we have the document
object model typescript data binding and
testing now let's look at them one by
one now the document object model treats
an XML or an HTML document as a tree
structure
here every node in the tree structure
defines an object representing a part of
your document angular uses the regular
Dom now let's suppose you've made 10
updates on a single HTML page so every
time you make a change the corresponding
Dom or the tree structure needs to be
updated
angular
of the entire tree structure of HTML
tags moving on to our next feature
we have typescript
now typescript defines a set of types to
JavaScript which helps you write
JavaScript that is easier to understand
now all the typescript code compiles
down to basic JavaScript that can run
smoothly on any platform now typescript
is not mandatory for developing an
angular application but it is highly
recommended the main reason is highly
recommended is that it offers better
syntactic structure while making the
code base easier to understand and
maintain now typescript can be installed
as an npm package now to do that you
just have to run the command npm install
hyphen G type script on your command
prompt next up is data binding data
binding is a process
that allows you to
make web page elements using the web
browser now it mainly employs Dynamic
HTML and does not require complex
scripting or programming
it is used in web pages that include
interactive components like calculators
tutorials Games Etc now incremental
display of a web page makes data binding
extremely convenient when Pages contain
a large amount of data when it comes to
angular it uses two-way data binding so
any changes need in the UI element is
reflected in the corresponding model
state
and conversely any changes made in the
model state are reflected onto the UI
State this allows the framework
the last feature we're discussing is
testing
angular uses Jasmine to run its various
tests the Jasmine framework allows
various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases karma is a
task runner for the tests that use a
configuration file to set the startup
reporters and testing framework so with
that we've covered the features of
angular
so let's go ahead and understand
the architecture of angular
angular is a full-fledged MVC framework
it provides a strong opinion on how the
application should be structured and
offers bi-directional data flow and
updates the real Dom MEC short for model
view controller is an architectural
pattern that separates the application
layer into model view and controller a
model here relates to all the data
related logic view on the other hand is
used for UI logic of the application
and controller is the brain of the setup
now it is an interface between the model
and view
moving on let's look at the advantages
of angular
first up we have custom components
angular allow
pack functionality along with rendering
logic into reusable pieces
data binding as discussed angular allows
you to effortlessly move your data from
your JavaScript code to the view and
react to user events without having to
write any code yourself
dependency injection angular allows you
to write modular services and have them
injected wherever they are needed this
greatly improves the testability and
reusability of the same don't worry if
you can't wrap your head around these
topics we're going to discuss them
further in the coming videos
next Advantage is testing angular has
been built from the ground up with
testability in mind
you can literally test every part of
your application
comprehensive angular is a full-fledged
framework and provides out of the box
solutions for Server communication
routing and mocking
lastly we have excellent browser
compatibility angular is cross-platform
and browser compatible an angular
application can typically run on all
browsers with chrome Firefox Safari and
platforms like Windows Mac OS and Linux
now many versions of angular have been
released ever since its Inception all of
these versions have added to the
efficient working of the framework now
here are two different versions released
first up was angular 1. it was built on
JavaScript and completely based on
controllers next release was angular 2.
now this Incorporated the component
based approach wherein the entire UI was
divided into several components and
lastly integrated to give the final
logic next was angular 4 it included
draft adaptation of angular CLI or
command line interface 1.0 was
introduced however not deployed in this
release the angular CLI was optimized
and commands like NG update and NG add
were added the angular 7 release prompts
were introduced which provided tips in
CLI about the functions being used
in angular 8 IB renderer and bazel were
introduced
and finally the most recent release was
angular 9. now this came with the better
framework and angular material now this
completely switched to the IV renderer
as a default compiler now that we've
learned about the pros of using angular
let's look at some of the limitations of
angular
first up is a steep learning curve now
since angular is a complete full-fledged
framework it becomes difficult for
Learners to begin with you need to be
acquainted with simple topics and then
move on to more advanced topics to
become proficient in this language
next up is limited SEO auctions now
angular offers limited SEO options and
poor accessibility to search engine
Crawlers
it's verbose and complex now a common
issue faced by the angular Community is
the verbosity of the framework it also
poses to be complex compared to other
front-end tools
and lastly migration now one of the
drawbacks of angular is poor migration
now it becomes difficult to Port Legacy
code to angular style architecture
also with each new release it is painful
to upgrade and a lot of them are not
Backward Compatible
next up let's look at the angular
learning curve
now if you wish to learn angular you
need to be acquainted with basic topics
in angular some of them are directors
modules decorators components Services
dependency injection pipes and templates
now once you've mastered your Basics you
will want to go and understand more
advanced topics such as change detection
zones aot compilation and rx.js however
the learning curve of angular is
clear-cut in the beginning it could be a
little intimidating but once you start
using the tool it becomes way more
easier to comprehend and understand what
is going on
and lastly let's look at some of the
companies that use angular today
many top tier companies like Nike Forbes
Google HBO Sony upwork among others
readily deploy angular so moving on
let's look at the prerequisites for
angular first up we have node.js angular
uses node.js as its base for a large
part of its build environment
so as a result to get started with
angular you will need to have node.js
installed on your environment so head to
their official website and download the
latest release for your corresponding
operating system next up is the angular
CLI now this command line interface is a
tool that makes it easier to bootstrap
and develop your angular applications
now to install the latest version run
the command npm install hyphen G at
angular front slash CLI you gotta run
this command on your command prompt and
finally to confirm installation check
for its version
now the next thing that you will need is
an IDE or a text editor to type your
code now there are several Ides that you
can choose from but in this series we've
used vs code throughout so it is
available on all platforms so go ahead
and download it if you haven't already
now moving on to the final part is the
demo now that you have a basic
understanding of angular and its
prerequisites I think you're ready to
create your first angular application so
let's head to our vs code and begin here
I've created a folder called angular on
my desktop and opened it on my visual
studio code so to create your app you
need to open the terminal just go here
and
select new terminal
and now type in the command Ng
new
and provide the name for your app so I'm
just gonna say hello world
so now this is going to create
just say yes
so basically what happens is that when
you run the command it will
automatically generate a skeleton
application under the folder that is
Hello World in our case and it includes
a bunch of files and installs all the
necessary dependencies for the angular
application
so this could take a while
so once you've created your application
to run it first change the directory so
let's say CD
hello world
and now use the command NG sir
now once it's compiled you need to go to
your browser and type in localhost 4200
[Music]
and once you do that
you can see your UI
you can see that the application has
been loaded onto your browser and it
says hello world app is running
so this is how you create your
application
so let's go back to our vs code now as
you can see here
there are many files and folders that
are created right so let's look at a few
of them of course we can't explain
everything but I'll brush through a few
of them
so the first main component is basically
the root component now the root
component here is the index.html
so here if you open the file and see
it's a very small crisp code right but
the most important thing in the file is
this app Root element
so what this does is it's basically the
marker for loading your application code
so this is extremely important so the
next important file is the main.ts
now this is the part of the
bootstrapping piece all right so the
index.html file is responsible for
deciding which files are to be loaded
correct the main.ts file on the other
hand identifies which angular module is
to be loaded when the application starts
so this is just a brief explanation as
to what they're doing
next we have the app folder now here we
have the app dot module.ts file now this
application module file can be thought
of as a core configuration of your
application
so here's where the source code starts
from and moving on we have the
app.component.ts these are all
typescript files hence the extension TS
now this file basically is the root
component of your application and then
we have the HTML file for the same which
defines the appearance of what you can
see on your browser so let me just
change the message that is being
displayed
so I'll say hey
welcome to this
angular
tutorial so let's save this and when we
go back to our browser
we can see the message hey welcome to
this angular tutorial being displayed
so like this we can make a simple change
and then it gets rendered onto your
browser so this was just a brief
explanation of what happens in the
background of your application
first we'll get acquainted to what
exactly angular components are then I'll
help you create an angular component by
showing a quick demo and lastly we'll
learn about component decorator metadata
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel if you love
watching new and interesting technology
videos also hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update so what exactly are
angular components
now I'm sure everybody uses web
applications and one of the most widely
used applications is Gmail correct now
to help you understand what components
are consider them as Lego blocks now
they basically are combined together to
form the final application so in this
case here we have the logo component
then you have a sign in component an
image component and then a create
account component now all of these
components generally don't affect the
working of each other but however when
embedded they Define the UI of your
application
so I hope you understood what components
are so to go ahead let's discuss some of
its common features now firstly they are
the building blocks of an application
generally you have a root component
which is basically the app component and
then it branches out into other
components creating a hierarchy
and these components are a subset of
directives now don't worry about what
deductives are because we'll cover them
later on in the series but to give you
an idea there are three types of
directives you have the structural
directives the attribute directors and
the component directors
only one component can be instantiated
per element in a template now components
are typically custom HTML elements and
each of these elements can instantiate
only one component
now don't worry you'll understand this
better when I show you the demo
nextly a typescript class is used to
create a component now this class is
then decorated with the at component
decorator Now The Decorator accepts a
metadata object that gives information
about the component now a component must
belong to the NG module in order for it
to be usable by another component or
application
and finally components control their
runtime Behavior by implementing life
cycle hooks so this was just a brief
introduction to what annular components
are
now you will only be able to understand
the working of components when I show it
to you practically so let's head over to
our Visual Studio code now here back in
my vs code I've created a folder called
angular demo within which I've created
an angular application called demo
components once executed the browser
looks something like this so if you
haven't watched a previous video on
getting started with angular that is
angular hello world I highly suggest you
go through that video first it helps you
create your first angular application so
um now let's go ahead and create our
first component now the command used to
create our component is NG GC and your
component name once executed it creates
four different files now let's just see
how this works on RVs code now what you
can do is head to your terminal and type
in the command Ng
g c
and provide a name for your component
for example I'm gonna just call my
component text component all right
so what it does is that it creates four
different files you can see you have
four different files that have been
created and finally it updates the file
that is app.module.ts indicating that
this new component has been created so
here in your Source folder within which
is an app folder and again here you can
see that your four different files have
been created first is the HTML file
wherein you can Define all the code that
you want for your component next you
have the CSS file for your styling then
you have the dot TS file which includes
the component decorator and finally you
have spec.ts which is basically a unit
test file all right and then in your
app.module.ts you can observe that the
company that you've created that is text
component has been imported that is what
the message conveys here all right now
let's go back to our
app.component.html now this basically
has all the corefair applications so let
me just get rid of it
and I'm just gonna display a basic
heading saying
hello
welcome all right so let me save it and
if you go ahead and look at your browser
hello welcome messages displayed now
let's go back to our component dot HTML
file and here let me
provide a message
[Music]
let me say h
and let me display a message saying
welcome to this tutorial
on angular components all right now in
your text component dot TS file which is
your typescript file
the selector mentioned here is app
hyphen text component now go ahead and
copy this
and in your final
component.html go ahead and create your
custom HTML tag with the selector that
you just copied now this indicates that
the component that you just created that
is the text component is being
Incorporated in the final render
so what happens is that whatever is
defined in the component.html file is
also being rendered in your final output
so when I say this
let's go ahead and check
our browser you can see that the message
welcome to this tutorial on angular
components is displayed so this was a
simple creation of a component now for
this let's give it some styling so here
go to your dot CSS file and provide some
styling see for example here I just say
text line
and let me say Center and also in my
app.companying.cs I'm going to give the
same thing and see each one
text line is Center
all right so let me save this
and there we go
now we can also create multiple
components and Define the tags in the
app component now the components are
executed sequentially so now let's
create another component just to give
you a brief insight into it let's say NG
GC image component
now here I'm going to be adding the
simply learn logo so I'll show you how
that works
now you can see that a new component has
been created with four files again so in
my assets folder here I've added the
logo so what I can do is back in my HTML
file I can go ahead and create an image
tag so first let me just display another
message here
just to avoid any confusion and let me
say this is the image component
[Music]
and then let me say
image
Source equals so the source is basically
assets
[Music]
slash logo
dot PNG
and class
equals
Center
[Music]
all right so you can also head to your
CSS file and provide any sort of styling
that you need so let me just say
text
align
to be Center
and then let's create
a styling for the image
and here I mentioned the code for the
image
so let's save this and from the dot CS
file let's copy the selector
and create a custom HTML tag in our
final component.html file
so there we go let's save this and check
the output
and there we go
first the hello welcome message is
displayed next you have the message
displayed from the first component and
then you have the second component so
this is how you can create your own
components and don't forget to
incorporate these selectors into your
final HTML file
so moving on to our next topic component
decorator metadata now as mentioned
earlier the at component decorator
accepts a metadata object that provides
information about the component correct
here is a list of properties of the
metadata object first up is the selector
now basically the selector is a CSS
selector that identifies this particular
component in a template now this
corresponds to the HTML tag that is
included in the parent component you can
create your own HTML tag however the
same has to be included in the parent
component so to help you understand that
better let's head back to our vs code
and say for example in our text
component
here
the selector says text component correct
for the time being let's change it to
say n component
[Music]
all right now when you save it and look
at the browser the message is not
displayed
so what we can do is you can copy this
selector and then include this
here
and now you can see that the same
component has been rendered onto your
output
all right so the selector plays a
crucial role in that
next up we have the template now a
template is an inline defined template
for the view now the template can be
used to provide some particular markup
the markup could typically include some
headings or paragraphs that are
displayed on the UI
next up we have template URL now it is
the URL for the external file containing
the template for The View
so here you can see
this is basically the external file that
contains the template for the view next
up you have Styles now these are also
inline defined styles that can be
applied to the components view so any
code that you provide in the dot CSS
file can also be included here
next you have the style URLs now this is
a list of URLs to your style sheets that
are applied on your components View
next up you have providers now this is
again an array where certain Services
can be registered for your component
lastly we have animations as the name
suggests these are animations that can
be listed for your components
first we'll understand what exactly
dependency injection is
then we'll understand the demerit or the
drawback of not using dependency
injection
then we'll understand dependency
injection as a design pattern and
finally I'll help you understand the
entire concept with the help of a demo
so let's begin
what exactly is dependency injection so
let's consider this I'm sure you're
aware that angular uses the concept of
components the entire UI of the
application is divided into several
components now what have all of these
components perform similar tasks be it
accessing the database rendering images
Etc now instead of writing the same
piece of code for every component you
could write the code once and then
perhaps inject the same core into every
component now this is supported by
dependency injection now to give you a
better example consider two classes A
and B now let's assume that a uses the
objects of Class B and normally in
object oriented programming an instance
of Class B is created so that a can
access its objects with using dependency
injection we move the creation and
binding of dependent objects outside of
the class that depend on them so
dependency injection or di keeps the
code more flexible testable and mutable
also classes can inherit external logic
without having to create on its own and
lastly GI benefits directives pipes and
components
next up let's have a look at the
drawback of not using dependency
injection
now let's consider Class Postal details
that is dependent on the number and the
address class
in the postal details class the
Constructor creates copies of the number
and address
so when you instantiate a new postal
details class the Constructor
instantiates a unique number and address
now although this looks simple there's a
problem with this code let's assume that
the number and address class
Constructors now accept parameters when
we change the numbers class the postal
details class gets broken now to
overcome this what we need to do is we
need to pass parameter to the number
Constructor so this applies to address
as well the first drawback of using this
traditional method is that the code is
not very flexible anytime the
dependencies change the postal details
class needs to be changed as well
and the second drawback is that the code
is not suitable for testing
once you instantiate the new postal
details class you get the same number
and address even if you change the
number and address classes every time
what if these classes are in turn
dependent on other classes
then it's going to be a chain reaction
so to overcome this we make use of
dependency injection
now let's look at di as a pattern
dependency injection as you all know is
a coding pattern where a class receives
its dependencies from an external Source
rather than creating them on its own so
here in the above example we have moved
the definition of dependencies from
inside the Constructor to the
constructor's parameters so the postal
details class doesn't create the
dependencies anymore
it just consumes them so the postal
dependencies class doesn't create the
dependencies anymore
so with that we overcome the drawbacks
of not using Di
so now that you know what exactly
dependency injection is and how vital it
is let's look at a simple demonstration
to understand the concept better now
services classes modules components all
of these are benefactors of dependency
injection so in the demo I'm going to be
showing how dependency injection can be
used with the help of services and
injecting these Services into classes so
the main thought behind this is normally
components are used to ensure just a
good user experience these components do
not generally execute tasks so to
execute these tasks we make use of
services so a component can delegate
tasks like fetching data from the server
any network related issues
ETC to a particular service and these
Services can be made available to
components with the same thought what
I'm going to be doing is I'll be
creating a service that performs the
task of displaying an employee list
later we're going to inject the service
into the class using dependency
injection
so let's head to our Visual Studio code
for the demonstration
all right so as discussed I'll have to
first create a component that displays a
button for the employee and then I have
to create a service class and inject it
into my component now this service holds
the employee details such as name
employee ID email ID
Etc so first let's go ahead and create a
component
so here let me just type
n g g c
and the name of the component I'm
providing is M info
if getting your learning started it's
half the battle what if you could do
that for free visit scale up by simply
learn click on the link in the
description to know more
all right so as you can see here in my
component with four different files all
right so the next thing we have to do is
we have to create a service so to create
that we make use of the command n g g s
you can either give s or service and the
service name I'm providing is records so
let me just say records here
all right here you can see two files are
created there is a spect.ts file and the
dot TS file all right so now the service
contains all the employee data that
needs to be displayed right so let's go
ahead and write the data so first we're
going to make use of three arrays I'm
going to be displaying employee records
for three employees so I'll have to
create three arrays and provide certain
information so let's go ahead and do
that
all right so the area I'm creating is
called info one for the first employee
and I'm going to be passing
information like name employee ID and
the email ID so the arrays of type
string
and within which let me just mention the
details I'm giving random information
I'm just saying Adam Taylor
and some random
employee ID
and let's say 80 at abc.net
all right so I'm going to be creating
three records so I'll just copy the same
thing and paste for the rest too
let's just change here
provide a different name here
and same for the last one
and let me change the name of the array
as well
all right so with the agenda to retrieve
this data in our component we make use
of the method for the same right so this
method Returns the employee data
so let's go ahead and create this method
I'm going to call it get info
and then just say string
and then this will just return
this dot info one
all right I'm going to be calling it get
info one for better understanding
same for the rest two as well
I'm just gonna return different arrays
here
now that and lastly info three all right
now in order to retrieve this
information in our component we need
three more arrays right three more
arrays that will receive this data let's
go back to our component dot TS file
here and then type in the following code
so I've created three arrays again or
info received one two and three
now what we need to do is we have to
accept the information that is being
sent from the service correct now as I
mentioned services are implemented with
the help of dependency injection so what
we need to do is we'll have to first
import the service into the component.ts
file the key reason behind doing this is
that when angular creates this component
and instance of the service class is
also made to perform the necessary tasks
correct so let's go ahead and just
import it here
so I'll say import
[Music]
records
services
I'm sorry service
from
and let's say records.service
all right and what we have to do next is
that we must also declare this instance
that is being created in the provider's
area of the component
all right so
let's just say providers
and then say records
service
all right now we've created the instance
of this class right however to access
this instance an object is also created
so this object will in turn access the
methods and variables of the service
class
so for that we have to create another
object so let's do that here in our
Constructor method let's say Constructor
private
foreign
is called our service you can give a
name of your choice and then I'm going
to just say records service
all right now this object will help me
retrieve data from the service so let's
go ahead and use this in order to get
the employee details our ads have
created three different methods here get
info from service class 2 1 and 3 and
these methods will retrieve the data and
add it to our array here that is info
received all right and lastly we'll have
to create an unordered list in our HTML
file here we haven't added anything so
let me get rid of this
so now I have to create three different
buttons for three different employees
and when the user clicks on the button
the data is retrieved from the service
and then displayed on the UI right
so as you can see I've created buttons
for three different employees
and then I've made use of a bootstrap
class called list group info and then
I've
interpolated info which displays the
contents
of the info variable all right now in
order to call the methods in the dot TS
file we have to bind them with the
button so since it is bound with the
click event every time you click on the
button the information is displayed
so now the last thing we have to do is
we'll have to create a custom HTML tag
for the component and then add it to the
main component
so let's just do that
let me copy this here
and then in my app component.html let me
get rid of this
and then let me just create this I've
just created the custom HTML tag for my
component
and now just to beautify the code I'll
write a heading
and let's say employee
foreign
logo
say image source
[Music]
I've I've added the image here so let me
just say logo dot PNG
I've also added some styling to it all
right so now let me just save this and
have a look at the browser
so here we go we have the logo here and
then employee details heading and then
we have three different buttons created
that is employee one two and three and
when I click on it
the information of the employee is
displayed the name the ID and their
email address
so yeah so this is how you can make use
of dependency injection and inject a
service class into a component
dependency injection plays a crucial
role in angular
will understand what angular forms are
then we look at the different types of
form buildings supported by angular next
up we'll get acquainted with features
like form control and group control
and we learn all of this with the help
of a simple demo
so without further Ado let's begin
so what exactly are angular forms
now I'm sure every application that you
use comes with certain amount of form
filling correct be it your login
credentials or your sign up forms or any
sort of registration forms Etc so forms
are an integral part of a web
application you need forms to update
your profile or to enter sensitive
information or also to perform any sort
of data related tasks so now let's look
at the different types of form building
supported by angular
first up angular supports two types of
form building
first you have the template driven
approach and second you have the
reactive approach
now let's look at them one by one so
talking about template driven approach
in this method the conventional form tag
is used to create forms so angular
automatically interprets and creates a
form object with the help of the
directors
now consoles can be added to the form
using the NG model tag now multiple
controls can be grouped using the NG
control group module so it basically
uses several module classes to provide
controls now if you don't get this don't
worry you'll understand better when I'm
showing you the demo
next up is Json values so form value can
be generated using the form.value object
form data is exported as Json values
when the sublip method is called
lastly basic HTML validations can be
used to validate the form fields in the
case of custom validations directives
can be used so arguably this method is
the simplest way to create an angular
form
so moving on to the active approach now
this approach is the programming
Paradigm revolving around data flows and
propagation of change
now with reactive forms the component
directly manages the data flows between
the form controls and the data models
now reactive forms are code driven
unlike template driven approach
reactive forms eliminate the
anti-pattern of updating the data model
by a two-way data binding so it does not
use two-way data binding
and typically a reactive form control
creation is synchronous and can be unit
tested with synchronous programming
techniques
so now let's go ahead and look at form
control and form group
so consider a typical form consisting of
fields like name age and location
now a form control is basically a class
that enables validation of these fields
for each input field an instance of this
class is created now these instances
help check the values of the field and
see if they're either touched untouched
dirty pristine valid invalid and so on
so this allows you to check every field
for the value it makes it easier to
understand which Fields value is invalid
or which field has not been entered
Etc
now moving on to form group
so a form group class represents a group
of controls a form can have multiple
group controls the form group returns
true if all the controls are valid and
provides validation errors if there are
any so I hope this was clear
so moving ahead let's look at the demo
to explain all of these features I'm
sure it will become extremely clear once
you look at the demo so for that let's
head to our vs code
so back in my vs code
I've created a component called form
component and I've also included the
simply learn logo just to purify the
appearance so once you execute the code
this is what you're gonna see on your
browser so you just have the logo at the
moment
the first thing we need to do is we'll
have to import the forms module all
right so oh uh but before we begin let
me tell you what the use case is so
we're going to be creating a user
registration form which is going to
include four fields that is the first
name and last name email ID and the
password all right so now let me show
you how to import the forms module so in
your main
app.module.ts file you'll have to import
forms module from angular forms
all right and then in your Imports
you'll have to just call it here
all right so this is just a simple step
and now once you're done with that let's
go ahead and start our form creation
so here in my component.html let's
enclose the entire form within a div tag
so here let me say div
class
as a container
foreign
within which let me just have one
heading
which says user registration
all right and now let's go ahead and
create our form
so first let me just say form
now I'm going to create a div class for
every field so say div
class
equals form group
I'll explain it to you a little later
[Music]
now first let's create a label
so label tag
for
basically it's the first name
so let me just say first name
and the tag will basically have
first name again
all right and let me just break the line
next we have the field so let's say
input
type is text
name is
first name
and we have a class which is
the form control class
all right
so this will have to do for all the
other fields so let me just copy this
paste it like four times
I'll also add the tag three for spacing
let's do that here
and finally we'll have the button
so let's just add that here
with a type submit
um let's just say submit on the button
so now let's go ahead and change these
values here
so here let me just change it to last
name
here as well
and here as well
and in this case it is going to be email
so let me just change it here
[Music]
and finally we have passwords so
let's add that here
all right so let's save this and just
have a look at our browser
so there we go we have our uh user
registration form ready but I would like
to uh align it to the center so let me
just do that
so here in my CSS file I'm just going to
uh align all the div tags in the center
and the label tag to the left so let me
save this and look at the browser now
and there we go we have our registration
form was a logo so this is how you
create a simple form
now we'll have to add a directive called
NG model now this directive when added
into the input tag will provide form
controls to every input field all right
so here let's just go ahead and say NG
model
that is it
so let me just copy this and paste it
for every other field
all right let me save this and back in
my browser let me inspect
and here you can see different types of
classes like NG untouched NG pristine NG
ballot are added right so this indicates
that angular has recognized the form Tab
and it has added these classes to the
form as well as all the fields
so this is achieved when you add the NG
model directive in your input tag now
back in my vs code now every form has an
output property attached to it called NG
submit all right so this property can be
bound within a method that method called
the submit method
so once submitted this method is called
right so once we click on the submit
button this method has to be called so
to include that
we'll have to just save
form
and G submit
equals
submit
[Music]
all right so now we have to define the
submit method
in our component.ts file so here let me
just go to our component.ts file and let
me
just get rid of unnecessary code here
and let's define a function
or submit
and then here let me just
console law
form submitted
all right so let me just get rid of this
as well it's unnecessary here
let's save this so what it means is that
every time you click on the submit
button
this method is called all right so let's
just have a look at the browser so first
let's go to our console
and when I click on submit it says form
submitted
all right so the next crucial step is to
generate JavaScript representation now
we'll have to make use of another
directive called NG form that is
assigned to a template variable
okay so this JavaScript representation
helps with validating all the fields so
I'll help you understand that better
so back in our HTML file
let's just create a variable first
let's call it login
all right and say Ng
form
okay now the mg form object includes the
JavaScript representation so now while
you're calling the submit method you're
going to pass login as a parameter
so let's just say login here
and in my ts file again let's just say
login
and along with it
I want login to be displayed so
I say login again
so now let's save this
and if you have a look at the browser
let's click on submit
and now here you can see the JavaScript
representation So within form
I can
check for email
or say first name and here for this
field first name you can see different
properties attached you can see invalid
is it invalid or is it untouched
which is true or are there any errors so
this basically gives you all information
about the particular field
so we can make use of this feature to
validate the information so we're going
to learn about that in our next segment
moving on to form validation one way to
ensure that incorrect fields are not
submitted is by disabling the submit
button
correct now apart from this you can also
specify certain properties in your input
tag for the corresponding input field
now um let's say that the fields that
now let's say that the fields can't be
empty and the form only accepts names
with the minimum length of 2 and the
maximum length of seven all right so
here in my input tag I just mentioned a
required meaning this field cannot be
empty
and Min length
2 2
and
max length
to say seven
all right
so to check this
let's go to our browser
and here
let me submit the form without filling
the first name
and evidently there has to be an error
so when I submit it
and I look here
what's in forms and here controls
and my first name you can see that an
error is shown here it says require
equals true that means that there is one
error now you can make use of these form
control objects you can leverage form
control objects to ensure field
validation and display a message
whenever an error occurs
right so to do that you need to access
these objects like errors or invalid or
touched all of these properties or
objects need to be
accessed for that we'll have to create a
template variable
and then this variable is assigned to
this object
so back in our vs code
let's create
a variable let me call it
name
and let's say NG model
all right here the variable name
receives the control object
so here back in my browser when I submit
again without the first name
you can see that the invalid property is
set to True correct so this helps us use
this property to alert the user with the
help of a simple if logic
so back in my
vs code let me create
another div tag
within which I mentioned NG if
foreign
[Music]
name which is our template variable name
dot touched
and name dot invalid
is true
right then I'm going to alert
so I'm gonna
make use of an alert here let's say
alert
Danger
all right
so in my CSS file I'll have to mention
the simple styling for alert
so here let me just say
so we're gonna have the background color
red
for danger right and here I'm going to
display the message
invalid in bold
foreign
so now let's go back to our browser and
check it
so let me proceed without entering the
last name it says invalid here so this
was a simple demonstration to show you
form validation
of course you can modify the code
depending on your requirement see
suppose the length of the first name is
too short then you can alert the user
with a different message or uh suppose
they have missed out on filling a form
field then you can again alert the user
so you can basically make use of the
nested if condition right now just to
help you understand that better let me
just show it to you
now back in my HTML file
instead of invalid let me have another
tag a paragraph tag
within which I make use of NG if again
now ngf
name dot errors
[Music]
dot required
is true
then I display the message first
name required
all right and if
the length of the first name is
[Music]
not 2.
now if the length of the first name is
less than 2 then I'm going to display
another message so let me just say
name dot errors
dot Min length
if this is true then I'm going to say
sorry
short first name
all right so let's save this and have a
look at the browser
when I proceed without providing the
name it says first name required but
when I type in one character it says
sorry short first name but if I type in
another character it accepts so I hope
this made you understand how form
validation works
so this was just a simple demonstration
again now I highly recommend you explore
these properties and play around with
these objects uh trust me it's really
fun so I hope this tutorial helped you
out I'm sure you all know that an
angular app is divided into several
components for example you have the logo
component you have the sign in component
and image component and say a create
account component
now these components are Standalone and
each of them represents a part of the
user interface
now imagine if all of these components
performed common tasks for example
accessing the database or rendering
images on The View
tasks like those now instead of having
to write the code for every component
you can just make use of angular
services
now the service can be written once and
then injected into all of these
components
now a service could be a function it
could be a variable or a feature that an
application needs
so the main use of a service is to write
code once and avoid rewriting of it now
the same code can be injected into
several components that make use of this
particular service
but what are angular services
so normally components are used to
ensure a good user experience now that
is the extent of it components make sure
that whatever is being rendered onto the
screen is right and pristine
but in order to execute tasks we make
use of services and this approach is
ideal
so a component can basically delegate
tasks like fetching data from the server
validating user input or logging
directly to the console to a particular
service
and these tasks can be made available to
any component in the app
so let's talk about a few features of
angular services
now typically an angular service is
simply a typescript class with an at
injectable decorator
this decorator tells Angela that the
class is a service and can be injected
into components that need that service
now they can be used to share the same
piece of code they can also inject other
services as dependencies
now these Services hold valuable
business logic
and can also be used to interact with
the back end now for example if you want
to make Ajax calls you can have methods
to those calls in a service and then use
it as a dependency in files
and as mentioned earlier it can be used
to share data among several components
in angular services are Singleton
meaning that only a single instance of a
service gets created and the same
instance is used by each and every
building block in the application and
finally a service can be registered as a
part of a module or it can be registered
as a part of the component now to
register it as a part of the component
you'll have to specify it in the
provider's array of the module
I'm sure you'll understand the concept
of services better if we look at a
simple demo so in the next section we're
going to look at a demo but before that
let me tell you the use case
so basically in the demo what we'll do
is we'll create an employee details list
say for example you will have employee
information like name employee ID and
their email ID we'll create a database
of say three employees
and on the browser when you click on the
employee button it displays the
information about that particular
employee
and at the end we can also add
information to the employees details so
without delay let's head to our vs code
and start learning angular Services
Hands-On so here first I've created a
folder called demo underscore angular
which in which I've created a file
called hello world so uh this was
previously used for a tutorial so the
name is just hello world so don't get
confused
however when you look at the browser
I've written an initial code here which
is angular services and I have the
simply learn logo so back in my browser
this is what the UI looks like
so uh to
understand the concept of angular
Services first let's go ahead and create
a component
so here I'm going to say NG g c
e info
I'm creating a component for employee
information
so as you can see
inside my app file we have the e-info
component which has these four files so
if you're wondering what exactly
components are and how this is working
then I highly suggest you watch our
components video first
so now let's go ahead and create a
service
so I'm just typing in the command NG G
here G stands for Generate and we're
generating a service and the name of the
service that I'm providing is data
so now it creates a service
which is going to be a DOT TS file
so you can observe that dot service is
appended this indicates that it is a
service all right
as mentioned earlier we have to display
the employee details correct so for that
in my component.ts file I'm going to
create an array that displays the
employee information in our case I'm
creating uh three different employee
records so for that I'll have three
different arrays so let me just call the
arrays info
received
one indicating this is the information
of first employee and this is going to
be of type string
and I'll just initialize it to null
for now
all right and I'm going to create
two other
arrays
and let me just
change
the name of that is all right
so now uh to retrieve the information
I'll have to create a method again I'm
creating three methods for the three
different employee records
so I'm gonna call the array get info
[Music]
from service one indicating it's again
for employee one
and
I'm just gonna leave it as it is for now
I'll tell you how the information is
being received
and I'm gonna do the same for the other
two uh employee records so let me just
copy paste and here I'm just going to
change
the name of the methods
all right so uh this is the initial code
for retrieving information however we'll
have to create the employee record in
our service
so back here in my data.ts file
what I'm going to do is
I'll create three different uh Records
for the employees so let me say info one
which is going to be of type string
[Music]
all right
and let me just give a random names say
for example I say John
Matthew
[Music]
all right
and employee ID say
if 354
and let me just give a random
email ID and say JM abc.net
all right so I'm gonna do the same for
the other two uh Records
so let me just create another one and
call it info 2.
and the name I'm providing is say Rob
listen
with a different employee ID says 673
and I'm just gonna make it RW at abc.net
and another record for employee number
three
and I'm just gonna say Rose Adams
[Music]
with
some employee ID
and an email ID all right so now we've
created the employee records so what I
have to do is I have to create a method
that returns these employee records
correct so for that I'm just gonna
create another method called get info
one
which is of type string
and it just returns
this dot info one
all right similarly for the rest of the
two records I'm just gonna retrieve them
let's say info 2 and get info two
and again
I'm just gonna make it get in full three
[Music]
and this is gonna return
in full three
all right so I'm sure you've got an idea
as to what I'm doing here so basically
this information is going to be
retrieved in our employee component
correct so for that I'll have to make
use of dependency injection
so here I'll have to import the service
that I've created so let's go ahead and
say import
[Music]
the service was data service
all right
from
[Music]
slash data dot service all right
now the main reason we're doing this is
to tell angular that when the component
is created
the service instance is also created and
this instance is being used to perform
particular tasks and for that we'll also
have to include this in our provider's
array so here let me just say providers
[Music]
and let's say data service
now to access this instance of service
that is created we make use of a
property
so uh this property basically allows us
to access all the methods that are
defined in the service class
all right so here in my Constructor
method I'm just gonna say
private
and you can give any name for your
property and here I'm just giving the
name d service
all right and which is of type data
service
[Music]
all right
so now with the help of this property I
can retrieve information from the
service class so here I'm just going to
say
this Dot
info receipt
equals this dot d service
dot get info one
all right so what it basically does is
that it calls the get info one method in
our service which Returns the
information of the first employee
and this information is being stored in
the array that is info received one
so similarly for the next two methods
I'm just gonna use the same piece of
code
let me just change it here
all right
and
same for the third one
[Music]
all right
so now that we have the logic behind
what is being displayed
let's go ahead and create the UI for it
here in my HTML file
I'm going to create
an unordered list
[Music]
and now I'm gonna make use of
the NG
for director
to basically Loop over the record and
display everything so for that I have to
make use of a particular variable so
I'll just say
let info
of info receipt
so
um you can check here in our TS file the
array is info received correct so I'm
going to make use of the same array here
and since it's displaying the first
employee record I'm just going to
say
info received one
all right and let me just create a Class
A bootstrap class of list
group
item of list group info
and we're just gonna have to interpolate
info
all right that is basically going to
display what the information holds what
the info variable holds
all right and here as well let me create
a bootstrap class
called list
group
all right I hope this was clear to you
so basically here the information is
being retrieved with the help of this
method right let us get info from
service one so in order to call this
method we'll have to bind it with a
button all right so that's what we're
going to do let's just
copy this and here I'm going to create a
button
foreign
[Music]
and the type
this button
[Music]
with a name
button again
all right so I'm going to bind it with
the click event so what happens is that
when I click on it this particular
method gets called
all right I'm just pasting the method
here
and finally let's just
provide the name employee one
for the button all right
so uh similarly we'll have to do the
same for the other two records as well
let me just
this letter all right so uh what I'm
going to do is I'm just gonna paste the
same
twice
and here I'm gonna just change the names
I'll say 2 here and this is again for
employee two
and I'm going to change this as well
it's going to be employed I'm sorry it's
going to be in four received two this is
going to be in 4 received 3.
and finally employee 3.
all right uh and lastly we'll have to
include
the selector that is app hyphen e info
in our main
component.html so here
let me just
create a custom tag alright and save
this so now let's go back to our browser
and see what it looks like
so here you can see that uh three
different buttons have been created for
employee one two and three and when you
click on it it retrieves information
that is the name the employee ID and
their email IDs so we've successfully
created an angular service and injected
it into our component to retrieve
information all right so now the last
part of the use case that we discussed
was uh to add another detail that is the
employee detail in the record all right
so for that we'll have to take uh input
from the user and in our case we're
taking the location now we're also
adding the same location for all three
employees
so this is what services do you know
they can be used to update modify alter
anything that happens in the back end so
you can tweak the code a little bit and
you can change the entire uh view of
your application you can add information
you can delete you can retrieve you can
alter
Etc all right so for that what we're
going to do is back in the HTML file
we'll create a form that basically takes
the input
so I'm just going to say um
[Music]
form
all right within which I'm going to be
defining a div glass
[Music]
within which I'm going to be defining a
div tag
inside which I'll have the input tag
of type
text
and uh the name I'm going to be
providing it will be location
all right
and we'll have a value and I'll just
[Music]
leave it blank and finally I'll have NG
model so if you're confused as to what
I'm doing here then I suggest you watch
the angular forms uh video it basically
teaches you uh how to work around with
angular forms
all right and now after this we're gonna
have a button
so let me say button
[Music]
all right
and I'm gonna just say add info
okay
all right so now when I'm creating the
form I'll also have to create a template
variable to access all the values within
my form so if I have to access the
location then I need a variable to
access it so here let me just go ahead
and create a template variable let me
call it frm
and I'm gonna make use of the NG form
directive
so this tells angular
that uh this variable can be used to
access all the values within the form
and since I'm using form here I'll have
to import it in my module file
so here I just go ahead
and see
import forms module from angular forms
and here in my imports
I'll just say fonts module
okay so I've imported the forms module
so now uh back in my HTML file
what I'm going to do is that I'll have
to make use of this template variable
to update my information correct so I'll
have to create another method that will
update information into the records
so here in my uh component.ts file I'll
have to create another method and I'm
going to call this method update info
method
all right and uh this basically takes in
the template variable that is form
and let me just specify any
okay and what this is going to do is
that it updates
the record correct so I'm gonna say this
Dot
D service
add info now you must be wondering what
ad info is
I'll just let you know in a minute and
and the value that I'm going to be
passing will be the value that you've
provided as an input which is nothing
but form dot value dot location
all right so now what happens is that
I'll have to again specify what add info
is and this method is going to be
defined in the service file correct
so here I'm going to create another uh
method that's add info
and I'm going to pass info as a
parameter
and what this method does is that it
just pushes the information or the data
into the arrays
so since I'm going to be pushing the
same information into all of these
arrays that is info 1 info 2 and info 3.
I'm just gonna say this dot info1 dot
push
of info
all right and the same for
[Music]
the other two arrays as well
let me just
change these all right
so what exactly I'm doing is that I have
I have a method called add info which
gets information from the component
all right and it basically pushes this
information into the array and also I
have to return it so I'll save return
this dot info
one
all right and I'll save it
and here we have another method called
update info which basically calls the ad
info method in our service
and passes the value to it
and then my HTML file also note that the
button type here is submit and not
button so what happens is that now the
value that we've received as an input
has to be passed on to the method that
is update info so here I'll say NG
submit
foreign
[Music]
update info
and I'm gonna pass
frm as the argument and now let's save
this
and execute
so all right here you can see that we
have an input field and a button saying
add info
so now I can just go ahead and say type
USA
and when I say add info and when I check
on my employee one details USA has been
added to the list
and same goes with employee 2 and
employee 3.
so I hope this simple demo on angular
Services helped you understand the
concept better I highly recommend you
play around and explore other
possibilities
let's understand what exactly is
bootstrap
bootstrap is a powerful toolkit
basically a collection of HTML CSS and
JavaScript tools for creating and
building responsive web applications and
Pages it is a free and open source
project based on GitHub and originally
created by Twitter
now to put it more easily bootstrap is a
giant collection of Handy reusable bits
of code written in HTML CSS and
JavaScript it's also a front-end
development framework that enables
developers and beginners to design quick
and responsive websites
now there are several advantages to
using bootstrap
to name a few bootstrap comes with a
responsive grid you don't have to spend
time working on your layouts
bootstrap comes with its own code for
automatically resizing images based on
the current screen size
it also comes with different components
that you can use for your web page these
components could be navigation bars drop
downs progress bars thumbnails
Etc
it also offers excellent documentation
and is customizable
so bootstrap comes in extremely handy to
create responsive user interface
so now before using bootstrap it needs
to be embedded into your application so
let's see how to embed bootstrap into
angular
now there are two ways to do it first up
is by using the bootstrap CDN or the
content delivery Network
now this enables users to load CSS
JavaScript and images remotely from its
servers
the other method is to use bootstrap npm
bootstrap jQuery and other packages and
Frameworks can be installed via the
command prompt
in the tutorial that I am going to be
showing you I have embedded bootstrap
using npm alright so I'm sure you only
understand the concept better when you
look at a demo
so let's go ahead and create an
application with the help of angular
bootstrap so in this tutorial what I'm
going to be showing is the creation of a
blog post
so uh let me show you what we're going
to be doing
so here I've created a simple blog
for simply learn and I've added the
simply learn logo I've also written a
few lines about simply learn and what
they offer I've also mentioned their
tagline and when you scroll down you can
see that I've mentioned the different
courses they're offering
and when you click on the more info
button
it navigates to the official page that
gives you the overview for that
particular course so this is for lean
sex Sigma the same for full stack web
development
as well
and the same for the last one that is
cyber security
and finally I've added a simple video
here to just make it more uh beautiful
so I've added a simple video
and lastly I've also linked our YouTube
channel so when you click on the YouTube
icon it will navigate to the YouTube
channel
to our YouTube channel here
all right so this is what we're going to
be creating uh using angular bootstrap
so I'm hoping you're all ready for it so
without further delay let's jump in so
first let's find the template that we
want to use for our blog
so for that I'm going to just go ahead
and say
bootstrap
blog template
and I'm just going to click on the first
link that I get
and here you can choose the template
that you like so I'm just going to look
for more templates here
and the one that we are going to choose
is
oh yeah this one so which is small
businesses so you can go ahead and click
on that you can then click on live
preview
and once you do that
you can just
save view frame source
so here you can see that the HTML code
is available
it has the head section and then the
body section
so the head section consists of a lot of
meta tags and then you have the title
and then you also have the CSS file
references
and then if you look at the body tag you
have different code for different parts
of the UI there's code for navigation
bar and then you have page content code
heading row
call to action and all of that and
lastly you have the footer
so what we're going to be doing is that
we'll take all of the code and then
we'll have to create components for each
of it and then we'll include all the
components in our main
HTML file
so that is the best practice that
angular uses so we're going to make use
of components
and you can also see that when you
scroll down you can see that it has
certain dependencies so here it has the
bootstrap dependency and then you have
jQuery so we'll have to download them
so we'll have to install them and as
mentioned earlier we're going to be
installing them with the help of npm so
for that we'll have to head back to our
vs code here
back in my vs code I've created a
folder called angular demo and then I've
also created a file called demo
components
and here
I'm just going to say CD
demo components
within which I'll say npm install
G query
[Music]
so this could take a while
and once you've installed jQuery go
ahead and type npm install bootstrap
[Music]
all right so we've successfully
installed jQuery and bootstrap so now we
need to add the references to these
JavaScript files to do that go to your
angular.json file
and here we'll have to add them in our
build section so here you can see we
have styles and scripts so in our
scripts array we Define the relative
path to these JavaScript files so these
files are generally uh stored in your
node modules so go ahead and
here you can look for bootstrap
here you go and then in your dist file
and then click on Js
and then you can see you have
bootstrap.min.js
oh well I'm sorry we need
bootstrap.bundle.min.js so here
you can just right click and say copy
relative path
and back in my Json file in my scripts
I'm gonna just paste it here
and make sure to uh
make it a path by providing by providing
forward slash
[Music]
all right and then the next thing we
need is the
jquery.min.js files so for that
again in our node modules you will have
to look for jQuery so here there's
jQuery and then click on dist
and then we have jquery.min.js
so again let me just
copy the path
and paste it here
[Music]
follow the same procedure for this as
well
[Music]
all right so we've embedded both our
files in our
angular.json file
so now in our code here in the beginning
they've also included the CSS file so
we'll have to embed that as well so
here back in bootstrap
let me just add the CSS file as well
that's
bootstrap.min.css I'm just going to copy
the relative path and just provide it
here
[Music]
let me just change these to forward
slash
[Music]
okay so we have our custom style sheet
so what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to copy this
and just paste it in our
and then you can just paste it here
all right
so I think we've added all the
dependencies and the custom style sheet
and everything so now let me just close
all of these files
what we can do now is that we can go
ahead and take the code from The Source
here so I'm just going to copy the body
tag
all right
so
I'm gonna copy this till the footer
and then I'm just going to paste it in
my
component.html file
[Music]
so as mentioned earlier I will create
components and then place the code for
specific parts of the UI in these
components
so let me just see if I've got
everything here
okay
so I'll be creating four components the
first one will be for the navigation bar
the second will be for the introduction
and then the third one will be uh to
display the courses that we're providing
and then lastly we'll have the footer
component
right so first let's create these
components I've also created a
components folder here in my app folder
so I just have to
type in the command NG g c first we'll
create the component for the top
navigation bar so I'm just saying NG GC
so I'm just gonna say components
slash nav bar
[Music]
all right so uh the component has been
created so what I'm going to do is I'll
just
copy this
[Music]
here
all right and the next component I'm
going to be creating is for the
introduction right so I'll say NG g c
components slash intro
all right so
so I will have to take
this code here I'm also going to be
including the call to action part
so I'll just
copy paste this one in my
intro.html file
so let me do that and then I'm gonna
have the main course content
component so for that I'll say NG GC
components slash courses
[Music]
foreign
the next part of the code
[Music]
all right until uh till the footer
let me just add it here
and finally we're gonna create the
component for the footer so I'll say NG
g c
components slash
photo
foreign
[Music]
all right
so now we'll have to create the custom
HTML tags for these components and then
place it in our HTML file right so first
one that we created was the navigation
bar so here
head over to the TS file
just copy the selector
[Music]
and then your
and then in our
app.component let me just
create the tags
similarly for intro
[Music]
just gonna copy the selector
and then for courses so
and add a hyphen courses
that as well
[Music]
and then lastly we have the footer
components so let me just copy that
[Music]
paste it here
all right so we've included all the
components so let's just run this
application and see if everything is
displayed in that so here let me just
say NG serve so when you execute the
command you can see that the template is
being displayed so you have the
navigation bar you have the
intro component and then we have the
courses component and finally we have
the footer component right okay so now
that we have the template ready we can
go ahead and customize it according to
our needs so now I'm going to be making
a few changes to the code we're going to
add the simply learn logo we're going to
change the tagline here we're going to
display something else over here all
right so let's go back to our vs code to
customize
and display the final output
so here
the first thing that I'm going to be
doing is
changing the message here I'm going to
display simply learn for that
in our nav bar component
let's go to the HTML code
and here instead of start bootstrap let
me just type in simply learn
[Music]
all right so when you save it and when
you look at the browser
you can see that
simply learn is displayed
and the next thing that I want to do is
I want to add the image right a simply
on logo
so what I've done here is I've already
added the logo uh dot PNG file in my
assets folder
so I'll just go ahead and provide the
path to this so that's going to be in
our intro files so here
image source is going to be
[Music]
assets
slash
[Music]
logo dot PNG
so let me save this
so there we go the logo is displayed
so the next thing is we'll have to
change this part of the UI so the
information that I want to display is
this
uh I'm gonna be displaying
world's number one online boot camp and
other information so what I'm gonna do
is back in my vs code I'm just gonna
delete
this
and instead of that I'm just gonna
copy this that's world's number one
online boot camp
and then within the paragraph tag I'll
display something else so let me get rid
of this
[Music]
let me just copy the information that I
want to display
paste it here
[Music]
and let me just give a line break
let me save this and see if it's
displayed
so yeah we can see that the information
is being displayed
next up here instead of displaying call
to action message I'm going to display a
explore programs message so let's go
back to our vs code
let me just say explore
programs here
and then lastly
instead of this message here
I want to display the message or get
certified get ahead without programs so
back in our vs code
I'm just gonna get rid of this
[Music]
and paste this instead
foreign
have a look at the browser
Let me refresh this
you can see it displays the message gets
certified get ahead and all of that
uh well now what I'm going to do is I'm
really not happy with the font size and
everything so I'm just go ahead and add
certain styling you can customize this
and provide your own font size and all
of that
so here I'm just gonna mention Style
and then say font size
and I'm going to make it XX large
all right so let's see
[Music]
yeah all right so it's the font size has
increased so I think I'm happy with this
all right so the next thing we have to
do is add information here for our
courses
so back in RVs code
we'll have to go to the courses
component so here I'm gonna just type in
the code for the different courses so I
already have it here so the first thing
is this message that I want to display
let me just copy that
and for our first tag I'm just gonna say
postgraduate program and lean Six Sigma
and the next information I'm going to be
providing is the duration
so here let me just get rid of this
face that here
let me just break the line
to beautify the code and then and here
for our reference link I already have
the link here
so I'm just going to paste that so once
you click on the more info button it
will automatically navigate to this page
all right
so let me see this
next up I'm going to do the same for the
other two courses as well
foreign
[Music]
program in full stack development
and then we're going to mention the
duration and the cohort so
let me paste that
and also provide a line break
and then link I have it here so
I'm just gonna paste that
[Music]
and finally for the third card I have
the third link here
[Music]
let me get rid of this extra core and
paste this instead
[Music]
and then let's also provide the link for
the same
all right so uh let me save this
and have a look at the browser
so you can see that the information has
been added you can see it displays
postgraduate program in lean sex Sigma
full stack development and cyber
security so once I click on more info it
leads you to that page
that shows the overview all right
so now the next thing on the agenda was
to display a short video and then the
link to our YouTube channel so let's go
ahead and add that in our
cautious component
so what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to get the code to add a video
from Google and then I'm going to
provide the source which is going to be
the video that I would want to display
so I've received the code I'm just going
to paste it here
so you can get the code uh on Google so
go ahead and just paste that also for
the source I have a video in my assets
folder which I have provided here
so when I save it and look at the
browser here we go you can see the video
here
all right
and once clicked it starts playing
[Applause]
[Music]
all right and lastly we'll have to
provide the logo for YouTube and then
the link to navigate to the YouTube page
so let's go ahead and do that
[Music]
so here again I've pasted the code
for the YouTube logo so here you can see
that I've added the image that is
YouTube dot PNG in my assets folder and
I've provided the source
and accordingly I've also added
The Styling I've provided a white
background and I've also aligned the
text to the center of the page
all right and I've also displayed the
message saying check out our YouTube
channel for technical videos and
tutorials
and then I provided the link to our
Channel on YouTube so let me just save
this and head back to the browser
and here you can see that
we have the YouTube logo
and we have the message displayed so
once you click on the
logo it navigates to the simply learned
Channel on YouTube
all right so uh if you want you can also
change the message here for the footer
so here in footer.html I can just
remove this and
paste this I say simply on Solutions and
All Rights Reserved and I save it and
look at the browser
it must get updated
so yeah there we go
so with the help of bootstrap we have
successfully created a website which is
basically a Blog
and we've also added the reference links
and images and logos to customize it
according to our requirements
so yeah this is it this is how you make
use of bootstrap and embed it into your
angular for more responsive and better
user interface let's have a look at the
basics of routing
now I'm sure that you've observed that
the URL changes every time you click on
a particular link or on an icon on the
user interface correct now this
basically indicates that you are
navigating throughout the application
now to achieve this navigation we use a
mechanism called routing routing is
essentially used to navigate through a
website or a web application
but how is it achieved in angular
especially in angular routing plays a
major role it is used to create a single
page applications now these applications
are loaded just once and new content is
added dynamically applications like
Google Facebook Twitter and Gmail are a
few examples of single page applications
the best part of using single page
applications is that it provides an
excellent user experience and you don't
even have to wait for new pages to load
which by extension makes single page
applications extremely fast but how is
this new content loaded
enter routing now routing is the
mechanism that as discussed earlier that
is used to navigate through the
application and load new content
routing helps angular configure the
route and the component that needs to be
displayed
now I'm sure you're going to understand
the concept of routing better when you
work on it Hands-On
so in the demo we're going to be
navigating to the login and the home
pages of a web application with the help
of routing
so let's head to our Visual Studio code
so basically the objective of our
application is to navigate to home and
the login pages so when I click on the
login icon here it loads the login page
and here you can see the extension
slash login and similarly with home once
you click on it some new information
gets added and the URL changes
with the slash home appended all right
so this is the main objective of our
application so to create it let's head
back to our vs code all right so here
I've created a folder called demo and
underscore angular and I've created a
file called demo routing
now the first thing you want to do is
open the index.html file and make sure
that the base tag is added now although
this is generally
added when your app is created if it is
not then add a base tag with href
attribute which is set to a forward
slash
all right now this is generally done to
tell angular to construct the URL while
navigating with a forward slash all
right and the next thing you want to do
is open your app dot module.ts file and
check if the app routing module has been
imported
if not go ahead and import it and then
also mention it in your Imports array
or with that or the initial setup is
done
Now to create the nav bar the code that
I'm going to be using is already
explained in the previous video that is
angular bootstrap I highly suggest you
go through that video before watching
this
so uh the code is already available I'm
just going to create a component and
write the code for it
and paste the code in it so let's do
that
let me say NG g c
foreign
[Music]
is now created
now here in my HTML file
I'll just get rid of this and paste the
code for the nav bar
so here we go I've pasted the code for
the navigation bar
and back in my
app.component.html file I'll just remove
all The Unwanted code here and just
specify the
custom HTML tag for my nav bar
so
let me just create one here
all right let me save this let me just
run the application and see if it's
displaying correctly
all right so when I open the browser uh
the navigation bar has been created
along with these different options
that's home about services and login
all right and we also have the simply
learn icon here all right now the next
step is to generate the components to
display the login page content and the
home page content now again I have used
bootstrap to define the user interface
for these files you can easily find the
code online just search for a bootstrap
login templates and depending on your
requirements you can choose the
appropriate one
so first let's create the components for
by two files that is for the home
component
and the login component
so
let's go ahead and do that
[Music]
NG GC
I'm just gonna call it login for my
login component
all right and then I'm gonna say nggc
home for the home component
all right
so I'm just going to copy the code for
the login component
so back in my login.html
file
foreign
okay
also note that I've added the simply
learn logo in my assets folder
and then just provided the source for it
here in my login component
all right
so next up is the home component
and if you've seen the previous video
that is angular bootstrap you might have
seen that we created three different
components that is intro courses and
footer which included the content for
the intro message for the courses and
the photo message correct so here we're
going to just paste the code for all of
these three
and then just display it when the home
button is clicked
all right so what I'm going to do is
I'll just paste it here
[Music]
so this basically has all the content
one thing I want to tell you is that in
the previous video we made sure that the
code was written in three different
components however for this I've just
added all the code in the same component
now I agree that this is not the best
practice so if you want you can go ahead
and create three different components
and separate the code into these three
components and just add the custom HTML
tags in your home component
I'm just hoping you're uh following me
right now and also here in my assets
folder I have added a video and the
YouTube logo that needs to be displayed
uh when the home icon is clicked all
right so now that we've created the home
and the login components the next step
is to configure the routes for the
application right so here you can see
that we have a file called app routing
module.ts file
so here we have the routes and the
router module that is imported and we
also have a constant called routes which
is strongly typed two routes from the
router package
all right now this array is used to
define all the possible routes in the
application now each route is basically
an object with a path
so here in my routes array I'm just
going to go ahead and create the paths
that is we have two different uh routes
right one is for login and one is for
home so I'm just going to create a path
object so let's say path
sorry within curly braces I say path
foreign
this is basically what will appear uh on
the URL all right and the component that
needs to be
navigated to is nothing but the login
component
so let me just say login
component as you can see the login
component has been automatically
imported
now same with
uh the Home Path so let me just say
but
home
and the component that needs to be
rendered is the home component
[Music]
all right
now the next step is to link these
routes to a button
in the navbar that is the home and the
login button right so we're going to
make use of the nav tag and an anchor
tag for this
you can see that we have a nav tag
and an anchor tag
which encloses the login and the home
components
all right now we're going to make use of
two directives from the router package
called router link and router link
active now these are specified within
the anchor tag the router link basically
holds the path to the page
and the latter that is the router link
active specifies one or more CSS classes
that will be applied when the router
link is active
all right so to do that let me just add
router
link
all right in our case it is home here
and we're gonna have another director
called router link active
[Music]
and we're just gonna say active here
all right
same for the login icon here
let me just copy this
[Music]
and instead of home
the path we created for this was login
[Music]
all right
so this is how you can bind the route to
your specific button on your UI
now despite of all this how are we
specifying where these components are to
be displayed
right the answer to this is using the
router Outlet director now again this
directive is available in the router
package so we have to add that in our
app component.html file
so here just go ahead and type
router Outlet
[Music]
all right so with that we've created a
simple navigation bar which has
different options that is home about
services and Link and once the user
clicks on the home icon it displays the
content that is in the home
component.html file and once the user
clicks on the login component it
displays the content in the login.html
file all right it's as simple as that so
now let's go to the browser and see if
it executes correctly
so all right we have the navigation bar
and once I click on the home icon here
all right yes we see that all the
content has been loaded
you can see we have uh the intro section
we have the courses section and the
footer section as discussed
and the most important part is that here
in our URL you can see that slash home
has been appended this shows that a
route has been created that navigates to
the home component so we've successfully
created a route here
and for login component when I click on
this icon you can see that the path
changes here and the login component
gets displayed
all right so this is how routing is
achieved in angular hello this is
Matthew with simply learned so let's
cover we're going to go through today so
we're going to go through what node J is
and what the architecture for node.j is
how you can use node package manager
which is one of the tools that comes
with node.js it's actually a very
important tool what are the different
types of node.js modules there are the
HTTP module and that is defaulted and
with node.js the file system the events
the Express framework and working with
databases and Industry Trends so quite a
lot to cover but we'll get through it
quite quickly I think
so what is node.js so node.js is an open
source cross-platform JavaScript runtime
and it allows you to build web
applications inside and outside of a
client's browser it is absolutely
fantastic for creating web applications
it's a really great way to speed up your
delivery it's also great for developing
solutions that are asynchronous and
event driven and what you'll find is
that with node.js one of the other
things that you'll find is that it's
just absolutely loaded with tools that
really allow you to accelerate the way
that you deliver your Solutions a little
bit of History node.js was originally
developed by Ryan dial back in 2009 the
latest version as of this discussion
right now is version
13.3.0 one of the most popular open
source Solutions out there are just a
ton of people contributing to it so this
kind of Deep dive into the architecture
so node.js uses a architecture was known
as a single threaded event Loop and this
allows it to handle multiple concurrent
clients very easily now so we visualize
that and what happens is that you have
your requests coming in and you have
your event queue and then a threaded
pull which does your computation
database and file system analysis and
then we have our event Loop that just
spirals through very quickly and
actually helps you manage the
transactions it's a very efficient way
of running the communications throughout
the system no package manager is a key
tool that comes with node.js it has
really two functions one is it allows
you to access online repositories such
as Express or mongodb or it allows you
um to and you can go out you can
actually search those for packages
online go to
search.nodejs.org there's something like
50 000 different different packages that
you can use it also comes with a command
line utility that you can actually come
in and and actually manage your packages
and you'll find that with all of the
solutions I think there's about a dozen
um node.js videos that we've created and
all of them you'll see that we use npm
in every single one of those demos so
it's really key that you have npm it
does install by default when you install
node.js so you'll have it a good way to
be able to validate which version of
node.js you have is to open up your
terminal window and then type in npm
dash dash version and that lets you
bring back the version number of your
npm module then once you have npm you
can actually then go in and install a
module name right from npm so in
installing a module is really easy you
just type in npm installer and the
module name the example here is
expressing that in Source Express JS
really fast way of being able to install
codes and what's great about it is that
as you're writing out your scripts you
actually can put in the script how to um
to have the defaulted install modules so
that whoever takes that package will
have exactly the same environment that
you're working so let's Deep dive into
modules because there are key component
of working with node.js and so modules
are really just like they're kind of
like JavaScript libraries so extensions
to node.js
um it's just that to be able to have a
module inside of your application you
have to use the require function and
then you can then specify uh like for
instance if it's a default module such
as HTTP then you can just put in HTTP
but if you need to be able to require a
module that's outside of the defaults
then you could actually have the insta
store from npm which we did in the
previous slide actually installed what
the module is such as Express so there
are a bunch of core modules uh HTTP for
a default web server is installed you
also have URL for URL passing query
string which allows you to work with
methods but you know you have here a
list of the different types of modules
that you can use so let's dive into one
of the modules which is the HTTP module
and the reason why we want to Deep dive
into it is because you're going to use
HTTP quite a bit just to get up and
running with different solutions so as I
said HTTP is a core module it's really
designed from being able to transfer
data over the internet as you would with
any other HTTP service it does use the
require method so that when you run it
it'll actually have you can actually
require the HTTP module to be
instantiated when you're building out
your Solutions and the web server then
will come up and running so for instance
in this instance we could say we could
do a very simple script and we go
through first line here is VAR HTTP
equals require and that's requiring the
HTTP server to be instantiated and then
after that in line two we actually then
create a function and that function is
going to have two key elements uh the
res right is put posts a hello world
comment to the screen then we have a end
to the response and then the final line
actually will then post out to which
port to look for on the Local Host so
here we have an example of the response
so the localhost is going to port 8080
and there we have the text for hello
world again really easy we created a
default script and force the script to a
post out onto a default port and we did
that all in half a dozen or so lines of
code so let's jump into node.js file
system so with node.js file system it
allows you to actually allow you to work
with the file system on a computer again
it uses the require method to be able to
be used in a solution so if you want to
have the files that have been used
inside of your code you do have to use
the require command for that so let's
jump into node.js events and so every
action on a computer is an event such as
opening up a file connecting to the
internet really anything that you do
with the click of a mouse is in advance
and node.js has a built-in module that
helps you manage and listen for those
kind of actions to happen and so here we
have an example of a basic event model
inside of node.js you know we have in
the Top Line we explicitly call out the
events so that we know that we're
looking for something to actually happen
inside of our script we can create the
object for the event emitter allows us
to to listen for that and then we create
a function that listens for the handle
that gets created we're looking for what
type of events to actually be created so
it's on click event and that's the
trigger so whenever you go ahead and you
know click on the terminal window you
just click popping out in your terminal
so let's look at node.js Express
framework the node.js comes with a HTTP
server but if you want to really take it
to the next level and you want to build
out a more sophisticated application you
want to use the web framework that comes
with node.js for building up both web
and mobile applications and so here
we're going to require Express which
actually installs Express JS express.js
is a very popular open source project by
itself but it's bundled into it can be
bundled into your node project by using
npm and so we step through the first
line actually goes out and calls out
it's supposed to be installed and then
we put together function that does our
requests and responses that get managed
from node.js and that allows us to have
our objects go back and forth and be
passed within a web server environment
in this instance we're actually
listening to Port 8081 on our default
host and we're actually using
server.address to listen for our host
and our port on our server and we're
able to then dynamically create a
console message so if we look at the
example here now we've actually got a
console message that's popped up onto
the screen that is a defa which is
dynamic to our own individual
environment so if we were actually to
move and be posting and pushing out our
solution to a different name server than
that name server would appear on our
console and here we have our message as
it appears printed from the web server
onto our browser page now you may wonder
why would you use express.js and seems
to be very similar to the default HTTP
server that's bundled in node.js the
reason why is that you can build just
more sophisticated applications with
node.js than you can with just your
traditional the default HTTP service
so let's jump into node.js with
databases node.js as you can imagine can
be used with a lot of different
databases a default is MySQL but you can
also use mongodb and there are
connectors for both that make it very
easy so for instance with mySQL you can
actually just use the MySQL connector
and it will install MySQL and you can be
up and running and connected to my SQL
in you know really minutes you don't
have to wait for a long time to set up a
server environment and get it running
for what you need and the same is true
for mongodb mongodb the difference
between that and my SQL is mongodb is a
nosql environment we actually have a
TV video where it shows node.js
and mongodb working together with each
other and I'd highly recommend you for
you to check that out if you want to see
how that works and as you can imagine
I'm putting in mongodb is also very very
easy you just put in the variable to
require mongodb and in the terminal
window you would just do npm install
mongodb you actually install the full
mongodb environments on your local
machine so you can actually do your
development testing and you then have to
use the mongodb compass tool to be able
to access and view your solution as
you're building it locally so let's go
through a demo of putting together a
very simple weather application using an
API that allows you to see how you can
actually control node.js with your own
Scripts
let's go and create a node.js weather
app called Weatherly so what you can see
is we've just put in a address and it
came back with the degree Celsius in
Bangalore and you can put in you know
New York and select weather and we're
actually playing against an API here
that allows us to get the actual
temperature and so here we have it's 22
degrees in New York City right now so
let's go ahead and show how you're going
to build this out so the first thing you
want to do is we're going to use node.js
since we're building all our Solutions
or
node.js which is nodejs.org is the
website and you have options for
downloads we're going to go with the
latest download now you also have a
download options where you can download
for other operating systems by default
when you actually go to the website
you'll detect which OS you're running
and give you the appropriate download
but you can go and choose out other
versions if you wanted to and you'll
also notice that the latest version of
node also includes node package manager
or npm and we'll need that for some of
our solutions that we're building later
on to validate whether or not you have
node included so you can actually just
go in type node dash dash version and
terminal window now she'll come back
with the version number if it's
installed that's the carrier if you
don't have it installed then you won't
come back with anything and you'll know
that you have the wrong version same
thing for npm your npm version and if
it's installed boom you can get a
version that's that you can validate is
yours and we're up and running with the
latest versions of node here
um you'd also want to have a text editor
now my personal preference is vs code or
Visual Studio code
um you go to code.visualstudio.com
um and it's um an open source software
from Microsoft
um it's really good it's uh and it will
run on all the leading um os's and it
allows you just to run and install a
really nice text editing tool and and
it's it's really like notepad on
steroids but it's just really really
good and then you also we're going to be
using uh the open weather map for an API
and so if you do open web map in Google
search it'll actually show a link for
the weather API and you'll be able to
connect that here we're actually just
going to go and show what the open
weather map website looks like but
across the top you can see that we have
different options and API is one of
those options we're going to be using
that quite a bit in our application so
there's certain apis you can get such as
the current weather the forecast and
daily forecast for 16 days and if you
click on any one of these such as the
current weather forecast it'll actually
show you what the API will look like now
one of the things that you'll need for
your API is you need the city name plus
your API key and I'll show you how to
get that in a moment but these are the
different types of calls that you can
make
all right let's go back to uh terminal
window so we're going to open up vs code
and we want to go ahead and open up a
folder we're going to create a new
folder we're going to be building our
project with me on the desktop and we're
going to create a new folder here and
we're going to call this for the weather
Dash app we're going to select that
folder and open it and this will be now
the folder that we'll be building our
solution in and then we can get rid of
the welcome screen we don't need that
anymore so let's go ahead and open up
terminal window and this is one things
you can do is you can actually run
terminal window inside of vs code really
nice so let's go ahead and format this
folder so that it's actually a a node
package manager fold a formatted folder
so npm in it and by default we're
running on our folder and so it's now
going to go ahead and create the package
Json file now we're going to name the
the we can give it a name we can call it
Weatherly but then we can just go with
the defaults for or the rest of the
applications to just kind of keep
hitting return and then what you'll see
on the in the folder is we now have a
package.json file and yeah we put in the
name there but then we have the rest of
the metadata index.js is going to be the
key file that we build our application
from so let's go ahead and create a file
called index.js and we're going to open
that up yep and that make sure that
matches up you've got to make sure
everything matches up for these files
just otherwise if you get it wrong then
your file is going to load anything so
let's put in our core constructions um
and so we're going to make sure that
Express is required Express is a HTTP
server it's really nice to use as part
of the Moon framework of mongodb Express
react and node.js we're also going to
put in a element called body parser
which gets used with Express
and then we're going to request
put in a request we can kind of require
request to be installed
and then we make sure that we have these
installed in our Channel window so we're
going to do npm install
save Express and body dash parser
and request this will install everything
into a folder
and it's going to go ahead and download
the latest versions
and this is one of the benefits of using
npm is that
as you are packaging together your
application it will pull out and ensure
that the developers all have the latest
and greatest
all right so now we see that our
dependencies have installed we have
everything uh supporting
um our requirements and so let's go
ahead and I will start defining our app
and so our app is going to be an Express
app
and we're going to have an API key that
we want to reference and this is going
to be from the weather app that we'll be
using
and
this is just a very some constants for
our application
and app.use express
static
and we can make it public all right so
let's create a new folder and we're
going to call that folder public
and inside the public
and create a subfolder I'm going to call
this one CSS
this is going to be our styling
and we're going to create another folder
called images
thank you
this allows us to
use body parser to pull in
URL encoded elements
so app set
View
[Music]
engine
and we're going to use EGS and EGS is a
extended template design for JS that we
can use
our embedded JavaScript
and we're going to listen on Port 3000
and so we're going to run our server
this will be localhost server and it's
going to run on Port 3000.
in our console log we're going to put
instructions to tell us that the
Weatherly app is listening on Port 3000.
all right so we're going to go and I'm
going to initialize node.j we're going
to type in node index.js and this will
initialize the app
there we go you can see that the app is
now running on Port 3000 so if we come
over to our local host and oh in error
can I get oh that's probably because we
have
two apps running on the same port
it's gonna have to cancel the other one
and so let's go app dot get
and
put in the function
render
[Music]
index.js is right right
I'll make sure we're rendering the
correct part of our solution
okay so let's create a new folder under
views and we'll call this one index.egs
and that stands for embedded JavaScript
which is
is a template model that we can use for
rendering our code
right so we're just going into our EGS
file and
put in our defaults
I'm going to link
to our style guide
and CSS
and here's our link CSS
Style
.css
and we have this in the downloads
go ahead and downloads we can have a
default CSS file that you can use all
right so under CSS would type in CSS so
we actually have something reference
and
[Music]
so let's put in link
now I'm going to go ahead and link to
some fonts
um if you haven't used any other Google
fonts before they're great online
repository where you can install
uh really I think they have hundreds of
fonts now
and we're going to use open sounds
[Music]
okay
all right
so let's start putting together our
content on our page so when our
container
and form elements
so we want to be able to have a post
element so we can actually
submit
what country or what city we're looking
to get
the weather for and then we'll have a
response
so it's just going to be a text field
followed by a button
so but
city as the name of the text field
and then the placehold will be enter
City
so that'll be actually in the text field
so we refresh
I'm still getting in there let's go back
to look at our code
and if we need to rerun this rerun so
node index.h.js
still getting error
so we couldn't find the module hem ejs
so we need to make sure that we're
pulling this into our code correctly
so this MP oh that's right we need to
install ejs so let's install that
there we go
installed
let's rerun index.js
there we go
very simple page you can see that we
have enter a city
and then we can go back
all right so let's go in
and
I'm gonna put input type
ID
[Music]
submit
and this could be a
and we're going to be looking to get the
weather and that's going to be the the
text on the button
and we already have some class files
already defined in our CSS document
you'll see it in a moment
it's going to be ghost stop button
and the class here is going to be ghost
Dash input
okay let's rerun that index.js
now you see that we have a button there
we don't have any styling yet we need to
bring that over
so let's go over to our CSS file
and it's blank
but we already have
everything already written
in a package and so again you'll find
the complete program
um here can be downloaded in the details
for this video
and you can see that we have all the CSS
styling correctly saved so make sure we
save that file
let's add in the comment styles are
let's create that comments
and so you can go to
https
codepen
dot IO
and it's slash official underscore
Naveen
slash pen
slash
rjkna and that will give you all of
these files
all right let's rerun everything so note
index.js
all right so we're starting to get some
styling and we have
a text field
another button
let's go back to
vs code
thank you
we're going to add some more
CSS file formatting
you'll see we actually have to pull in a
weather jpeg or put that into the images
folder here
so we'll just drop that in boom there we
go
there's our nice fluffy cloud
save that file
you'll see that everything is pulling in
correctly
for our
index.egs file let's go back down to
terminal window rerun the index.js node
and now
we get a much more pleasant design so
you can actually see the text isn't wait
for the get weather button
and we have that now base container
which is
the first thing that you see on the
screen
okay
all right so let's go back to index.egs
all right so what we want to be able to
do is put the the weather on our screen
here
so we're going to update the
field set now
so let's go to styles
and we're going to place in a default
style for fieldset
and of course we have to go in and rerun
the index.js file
you're just seeing a little bit more
padding around
the actual application
and here we go
and we've got an error that's all right
means we can
fix this
and come in to our solution
and our index.js file
and we're going to add in a new feature
here that allows us to
post
I'm going to post and refresh the page
when we post
and
we will put in
City and we'll pull that from our input
text which is labeled City
the URL
so I'll just be
playing this is the structure we need to
capture
that's our API call so here's our
URL
time in the full path
and we have to make some changes here
obviously so we want to dynamically put
this in the city name so let's change
that here
we put in
dollar sign which is the
Escape key to allow us to play around
um commands and so we can put in city
and this will be allow us to pull it's
from the input text field for City
and now we need to put in our API key so
let's just
reduce that and we'll open the dollar
sign and we put an API key which is
again pulling from the API key at the
top here
so obviously we'll have to put our API
in there but it does allow us does
prevent us from having to rewrite that
over and over again which is good
and then console.log
body City
okay so let's sign in and
oh we're already signed in so that's
good so that's my account
but you can sign in with your own you
need to get an API key so I select apis
and locate a key name
so in this one we're going to call it
weather Weatherly that's the name of our
app
and here we go
here's our API key that's been created
so we just want to copy that
put in to notepad
[Music]
you will have to generate your own API
key though if you reuse the one I'm
using here it simply won't work for you
because it's tied to the app that I've
created so just go ahead and just render
your own API key
all right so let's go and grab your API
foreign
go back over to our app we'll just paste
in the API here
and when your cash returns we'll get rid
of them
okay so now we should have be able to
dynamically pull
from our API so we rerun the code
and let's go over to our Weatherly app
all right so it's intro City
foreign
and here we are in
our log it's pulling in Bangalore so we
know that that's been captured correctly
which is good
now we're going to
write in the commands to
complete our application
okay so we're going to respond
okay with it render into the
index file
and it has an error
please try again
not let's pass the
Json packet
into the body of the script
so you see there's it's fairly basic
application allows us to
pull and push API content pretty easily
if there's any error messages
I'll make sure that the
tell us tell the user to try again
save our code
and
we'll put the weather
response
and this will be City
oh we're there
the weather
text
[Music]
weather City so these are all values
we're playing from the Json file
from the
API that we're pulling back
okay good
good looking good
make sure everything matches up
correctly
and send a message to our console log
looking good
let's rerun the app
node index
.js
okay everything's running correctly
let's rerun the app
good more time in Bangalore
hit get weather
and now we have all the information
yeah in
our terminal window so by pulling back
body actually pulls back the full Json
packet that we get from the API request
and you can see that we have just
different matchups here so like for
instance you see clouds
is a description
we have temperature and we can then
start manipulating
all of that content
and so we want to make sure that the
value comes back in Matrix so we just
added in a new value there so we ran the
script let's go in and rewrite the
application type in Bangalore
now because previously the if you don't
then everything comes back in Kelvin
so now we have the temperature has come
back in metric so 28 degrees not 305
degrees Kelvin which is great
because now we can actually start using
this content
as you can see there's a lot of content
here so we can actually
really use it to
modify our presentation
so let's type in New York to see some
additional information
and go back to vs code
and now you'll see that New York we have
New York just the weather for that
right let's go back to our EGS file
and now we can actually start doing some
pulling in some of the data that we
received back from the API call
all righty so let's put in for our
weather response
let me just put in a paragraph here
okay
so if
error
is now
okay
um let's say this is the
EGS template during the work
so here's our template
playing back the weather information
and it's going to reference the
formatting that we have developed
already
okay let's rerun
okay here we run the application
so in Bangalore
and there we are we have
and we can do
oh that was just a error message so
you see that we got our error message
correct
so then we're able to pull in the
correct messaging
for our weather
so we wanted to change
the structure we can set into that
so if we type in New York
it's going to default to New York City
it's 23 degrees with clear in New York
and that's our demo
so finally let's look at some of the
industry Trends and why you'd want to
learn node.js so there are some number
of really key things one of them is that
JavaScript simply is just an extremely
popular and highly in demand scripting
language having node.js is in the top 10
most in-demand jobs worldwide so there's
lots of opportunities we've seen things
such as you know node.js
um the number of downloads is increased
by 40 over the last year is just
tremendously the number of people
looking to install node.js not so much
because they're just trying to download
and solids because they're actually
using it which is fantastic
um more importantly some of the biggest
companies out there are using node.js so
you can actually get work with them and
we're seeing that just the important
value of JavaScript continues to
increase so on the right hand side of
the screen you see the JavaScript is now
the number one programming scripting and
markup language out there outside of
HTML and CSS and so just you know just
tremendous popularity and what we're
finding is that node.js developers
continue to get more and more salary
options
um you know you can see here that uh in
India the average salary option is
around 613 000 rubies which is just
phenomenal and then in the United States
you know a a mature node.js developer
can be easy looking for a salary of 104
or more thousand a year in this session
we will learn about the database and the
need for a database then we will
transition to SQL and see some basic SQL
queries after knowing what a SQL query
is we will see the features and
applications of SQL query and then we
will have a hand on some of the basic
SQL queries so hey everyone I'm abisa
from Simply learn and welcome to this
video when SQL basic of ignorance but
before we begin if you love watching
Tech videos subscribe to our Channel and
hit the Bell icon to now miss an update
let's start with database a database is
a vast collection of data that is stored
and retrieved electronically from a
system in today's world data has become
the new oil which has mandate companies
and businesses to rely on an excellent
database to store the vast amounts of
data
every millisecond the tech Giants are
accumulating vast amounts of data that
need to be stored the database comes
with features to update and effortlessly
manipulate data and not only that these
database provider companies ensure the
data to be safe and secure they also
provide tools to extract useful
information to help the companies make
meaningful decisions
after knowing about the database let's
see how SQL communicates with the
database to get desired results
SQL stands for structured query language
the structured query language is the
standard language used by database
operators and developers to carry out
different operations from manipulating
updating and retrieving data from
relational databases
now let us see how we write a basic
query there's a customer table with
columns customer ID customer name age
gender date of purchase address item and
price
and we need to extract the customer ID
and customer name from this table
so we will write a query select customer
ID comma customer name from customers
semicolon when we will execute the query
in MySQL workbench we will get the
desired result that is the output table
with customer ID and customer name
this is how we write a query to extract
the information from the database we'll
see some more queries as the session
proceeds
now we'll see what the features of SQL
are SQL lets you access any information
stored in a relational database with SQL
queries data is extracted from the
database in a very efficient way the
structured query language is compatible
with all database systems from Oracle
IBM to Microsoft and it doesn't require
much coding to manage databases
now we will see applications of SQL SQL
is used to create a database Define its
structure implement it and let you
perform many functions SQL is also used
for maintaining an already existing
database SQL is a powerful language for
entering data modifying data and
extracting data in a database SQL is
extensively used as a client server
language to connect the front end with
the back end the supporting the client
server architecture SQL when deployed as
data control language DCL helps protect
your database from unauthorized access
after knowing SQL with its features and
applications let's go through some basic
queries in SQL
that is ddl data definition language DML
data manipulation language DCL data
control language TCL transaction control
language ddl or data definition language
consists of the SQL commands that can be
used to define the database schema let's
see ddl commands create command is used
to create the database or its objects
like table index function views store
procedure and triggers drop is used to
delete objects from the database
truncate is used to remove all records
from a table alter is used to alter the
structure of the database
DML or data manipulation language
consists of the SQL commands that deals
with the manipulation of data present in
the database insert into command is used
to insert data into a table update is
used to update existing data within a
table delete is used to delete records
from a database table select this
command helps you to select the
attribute based on the condition
described by the workloads
tclo transaction control language these
commands deals with the transaction
within the database commit commands
commit a transaction
rollback command roll backs a
transaction in case of any error occurs
save point it sets a save point within a
transaction set transaction it specify
characteristics for the transaction
dcn or data control language it consists
of the command such as Grant and revoke
which mainly deals with the rights
permissions and other controls of the
database system
Grant command gives user access
privileges to database
revoke it will draw users access
privileges given by using the grant
command now we will have hands on some
basic queries in my SQL work match now
we'll see some basic queries executing
in MySQL workbench so we'll start
and first query will run will be use
sys that is the database
this command is used to select the
database
in which we want to create or manipulate
any data now we'll see another command
that would create a table
now we will add attributes to the
customer table that would be the columns
first would be the customer ID and we
will
act it it as a primary key
The Next Step you could add would be
customer name customer underscore name
and its data type would be back there
next item that would be each
within data type
next attribute would be gender
with character data type
next we will add as date of purchase
foreign
attribute that would be addressed
with data type where care
next we will write the attribute item
that will be the item purchased with
data type where care
next would be the price
okay for price we will make it as float
and let's shift this to next line and
now we'll execute this command
yeah you can see that the table is
created
now we have to insert values into it
for that we'll write a command insert
into
customers
values
and I have all the records written in
the notepad
so I will copy these
foreign
these are 20 records like all the
attributes they are in the order so we
have written all the records in the
order only
like customer ID that will be 101
customer name that would be Joseph age
that would be 22 gender May date of
purchase this is the date of purchase
address Pune
item that is vegetable purchased price
that is 80. so now we will run this
command and all these
records they would be inserted into the
table
and these are 20 commands 20 reports
you can see insert into customer values
the command has been executed and they
have been inserted into the table
now we'll see
the table
for that you will write the command
select star
from
customers
here you can see the table
in the output grid
okay I'll make sure you will see the
whole table
with all the 20 codes
here
you can see
all the 20 reports they have been
inserted
now you see another command
and for that we would just
get the output as customer ID and
customer name in the output grid for
that we'll write the command select
customer ID
comma
thank you
okay
customer name
from
customers
semicolon
and we'll run this command
and we will get both the columns
customer ID and customer name
in our output grid
now we'll see another command that would
be drop
the drop command just removes the
component from the database
so we will write
drop
table
and table name that would be customers
and semicolon and we will execute this
command
now the table has been removed from the
database
to verify whether the table has been
removed from the database or not we will
run a command select star from
customers semicolon and execute this
command
foreign
start from customers error code table
says customers doesn't exist the table
has been removed from the database so
that drop command worked here
now we don't have any table that is the
customer table has been dropped from the
database so we have to create that table
again
so we'll go at the top
k
yeah
and we'll create the table again
and we'll insert all the records again
into the table
the commands have run
now we will
run this command to see whether the
table has been created and the reports
have been inserted into the table or not
both commands have worked
now we'll see another command
that would be truncate the truncate
command just manages all the records
from the table
truncate table
name
semicolon
and just run this command
the command has been executed
now we'll see
yeah you can see that all the records
from the table has been vanished so the
truncate command worked here now to
carry other operations we have to insert
all the records again into the table
we'll do that
will again go put
and run this command
insert into customers values and all the
records
and we'll execute this command and that
command has been executed and all the
records are again in the table so we'll
turn this command and check it
yeah you can see all the records then
set it into the table
now we'll see another command that would
be alter
alter command is used to update any
record into the table you will see alter
table
name that is customers
and now what we should do uh okay we'll
drop the column H from the table
so we'll write command drop
column
age
semicolon
I will run this command
the command has been executed
and now we'll check whether the each
column has been dropped or not
select star from customers
semicolon and we will execute this
command
yeah you can see the age column has been
dropped off the table
so the alter command has been executed
successfully
okay so now we'll see another thing uh
like if you want to comment something
during the execution you can do that
just write two minus signs and the text
this would be the command
and you can also use
slash
star and that
text
inside it and start and Slash
so this is also the comment section you
can write comment with this syntax or
with this syntax they both work
now we'll see another command that would
be update
this is also used to manipulate data in
the table to update any record into the
table
so we will write update table name that
would be customers
and what we should update okay we will
update a record
uh we'll change the customer name and
address
and we have the primary key as customer
ID so we will use that so update
customers
set
customer name
equal to
James
comma
and address
equal to poster
where
customer ID
equal to one zero one
okay you can see here in the table 1 0 1
customer ID the customer name is Joseph
and the address is Pune we have updated
command and we will execute it see okay
okay
we have an error here
uh yeah so it's correct we'll execute
this command
yeah the command has been executed
successfully and now we check the table
with the command select star
from customers
you can see the row has been updated
the customer name is James here and the
address is Boston so the command has
been executed successfully
now we'll see another command that would
be delete
so delete command is used to delete any
particular record for any particular row
so we will write the command delete
from
customers
where
customer ID
equal to 102.
semicolon
so the second row that is with customer
id102 that would be deleted when we will
execute this command
now check into the table
yeah you can see
the record has been deleted
now you'll see distinct command that is
used to return different values so we
will write command select
distinct
and the column name for which we want
different values to be in the output
grid
we'll select address
from
customers
and we will execute this command
yeah
these are the address so these are the
cities in the address
which are different and which are unique
and we have get that through the
distinct command
now we will see minimum command minimum
command is used to get the records or
get the data that is minimum of all the
data
so for that we will write the syntax
select
minimum
McMain in bracket we will write the
attribute name or the column name
for which we want the data to be minimum
as
less price
this would be the attribute name
from customers
so we will execute this command
and what we would see is that 60 would
be the last price
like the customer table they have the
column price and in that we all we have
all the prices and from that the minimum
price is 60 and we have kept it at less
price
similarly we have the maximum command to
get the maximum amount from the column
we will use the maximum command
select Max in bracket to write the
attribute name
as
Max price
from customers
and we will execute this command
and what we get is 3400 it's the maximum
price from the price column
now we'll see another command that would
be count
command it Returns the number of rows
according to the query so we will run
the query and see like how it works
we'll write select
count
and the attribute name
that would be a customer ID
customer ID
from customers
semicolon
and when we will run this command
we will get 19 as a result that is it
counted the number of customer IDs that
is 19 in the table
now we'll see another command
that would be average
so it just gets the average of the
numbers and how we do it write the query
select
AVG and the attribute name for which we
want the average
from table name
semicolon
and we'll execute this command and we'll
get the average of the price
from the customer's table
now if you want to add up all the prices
from the customer table you can use the
command sum so how we will execute that
command
select sum in bracket we would write the
attribute name that would be price
from
customers semicolon
and we'll run this command
and we'll get the sum of the prices from
the customer table
now we'll see where command
where command is used to filter records
let's see through syntax
so we will write select
star
from customers
where
address
uh yeah we will
where address equal to
Pune
semicolon
and then we will run this command
and yeah this is the taper we will get
tele codes with addresses spooning
so this is the functioning of where
command
now we'll see Group by command
that is used to just group the number of
rows that have the same values we will
see it through the syntax
like we will write
select
count
attribute name that will be customer ID
comma
address
from
table name
and group by
accordingly with address
now here the comma will not come yeah
this is the command select count
customer ID comma address from customers
Group by address
when we will execute this command yeah
we will get this table
that would be these are the different
addresses and these are the number of
times number of persons who live in this
address with the count with respect to
customer IDs
now we'll see having close with the help
of an example only
select
count attribute name that will be
customer ID
comma
address
from table name that would be customers
group y
address having
count
customer ID
greater than unit 3 review
semicolon and then we will execute this
command
and you can see
the output we have got through this
command that is Group by command
close this and when we have added having
closed having count customer ID greater
than 3
we just got the customer ID count with
four
thank you
now we'll see another command
that is order by
select star from table name that is
customers and we will order this output
by address
semicolon
we have got the output with respect to
the address
the address has been assigned
alphabetically here
in this particular project we'll be
having a basic angular setup ready so
you know it very well to develop an
angular application we have used a
similar technique called uh downloading
the angular CLI version and we have used
engine new and the name of the project
is project and this particular project
does nothing have only one single
component name called app as you can see
it right now here
uh
under the SRC you have got app folder
appcomponent dot HTML and here you see
app component.ts so that is one of the
very very basic component angular can
hold in so this HTML contains a very
simple message called welcome and
component.ts contains nothing special it
is just holding one title and uh
app.module.ts if you see it contains
nothing special whatever it comes as a
predefined pre-loaded it contains only
those particular type of modules and in
my app.module.ts sorry yeah if you talk
about call package.json inside my
package.json we have some additional
dependency added which I will tell you
like what dependencies a part of angular
which comes as a pre-loaded or by
default available
now you can see here
animation compiler core forms localize
these are all by default are there a
part of that we have also taken this
bootstrap as an additional dependency so
we talk about called NG bootstrap
okay which is the additional dependency
we have taken bootstrap jQuery opera.js
rxjs which anyways comes by default and
here
these dependencies will be playing
additional role during your development
time
okay rest everything gonna be remained
same as it is but yes these additional
dependencies like in jQuery poker and
your say TS lib and you talk about like
in bootstrap
okay jQuery these libraries are
additional to those the one which comes
as a by default okay so once you have
those additional dependencies added into
your project do not forget that in your
angular.json you need to have
uh additional declarations do we get
added okay as you can see now under the
scripts part okay under the Styles part
you see the under the Styles we have
kept our bootstrap.min.css
and under the scripts we have kept all
those necessary dependencies with
regards to our JS called demo chart pie
chart pie demo you talk about bootstrap
you talk about jQuery so these are the
additional dependencies we have kept
under the scripts part which is there in
the urangular.json
okay and under the Styles we have about
bootstrap through which we can directly
include these bootstrap related stuff
directly into my project
so that would be the first thing which
will start with okay so if I want to
start my application I will certainly
say npm space start let me say npm space
start
if it is launching my application
okay please use Google
foreign
my application will be starting up now
it is saying Port maybe this application
is ready somewhere
so let me check if it is available
okay so application is already running
so inside my photo double zero if I try
to run I can see this by default message
will come appears so that's the only
thing with regards to your project so
nothing fancy it is just a basic stuff
your application have some basic set of
dependencies added and along with this
you have some new dependencies and you
just you say npm space start and under
the localhost 4200 your project will get
ready okay so in my previous example you
remember like we have created and done
with our basic setup and now it's time
for us to go back and create some new
component into my project now what's the
first component I'm looking forward for
that is called navbar for creating a
navigation so inside this first of all I
want to open a new one
okay so I want to say NG space g space c
space number
so let the new component get ready okay
so we have got never component ready
with me so this is what my nav bar is
and inside the snap bar I want to add
some additional dependencies inside my
HTML
okay so here
I may have a lot of tags associated with
me but here I want to start with my body
tag okay so this is what I want to start
with my body tag
okay and here onwards we want to start
all my development So within my body tag
I'll be writing a lot of other tags too
but first of all let me try to have some
additional dependencies to be get added
here so I want to add the div and here
I would like to have some additional
dependencies to be get added as you can
see right now it is for jQuery it is for
your bootstrap it is a scripts okay this
is for charts this is for chart areas
data tables so these dependencies are
very much required in order to start
your basic development
okay and I want to continue
developing this example by adding some
New Logic one by one
okay now what logic I want to add it now
so I will be using bootstrap as a basic
code
okay so first of all I want to use the
body with some body
class equal to I want to give this name
called SB hyphen
nav hyphen fixed
that is actually the bootstrap class
which we're associating with you and
here after that we'll be starting with
my Dev tag so after body
here see this is the SB hyphen nav
hyphen fix which we have used now I'll
be using some nav tag now
and inside my nav tag I want to say
class
equal to
SB hyphen uh top now
the space
navbar space
Napa iPhone
Sprint
okay space now bar
hyphen we want to use the dark things
I'll be using never hyphen dark and
space BG hyphen
dark
so this is the first thing we are using
it now inside my nav
okay we want to use few more important
details like I'm saying like anchor
okay so with this anchor I want to say a
before hdf we want to say class
equal to Nepal
never hyphen brand
okay space nav bar
or else we can say hrefs we can use this
just add this single quotation and just
say href href equal to
index Dot
HTML to go back and after this we'll be
also using uh this IMG tag also we just
use this IMG sr3 equal to we'll be using
some logo okay which will be there under
the assets
okay under the assets I'll be having
logo Dot PNG
okay and we would like to also
say some controlling this
some width and height so we just use
width equal to what 80 percent
okay and we want to use
height equal to 120 percent
so worth 80 percent height 120 percent
alt is maybe something option you want
to give it I just want to leave it now
we do not want to give alt as an
alternative and if you also want to give
Style
so I say Style
equal to now I say padding
hyphen top
colon
here I say 10 pixels
okay that's it so that's where exactly
the main logic is let me try to bring
this back
okay and here the anchor tag is closed
after this I'll be using my button tag
now
with this button we want to add some
class
class equal to BTN
space BTN hyphen
link followed by BTN
hyphen SM because I want to have a small
size button and I want to say order
iPhone 1
space
order iPhone LG
hyphen 0. okay followed by ID equal to
sidebar toggle
what I'm saying sidebar toggle and after
that some more new properties like in
hrf I do not want to go anywhere else
I'm just saying href equal to what hash
in a single quotes
okay and that's it
So within this button I would like to
offer some eye class so here I say I
class
I
class equal to uh
[Music]
okay FAS fa hyphen bars
this is a special class available
and that's it
is there
now here's an iCloud is getting close
and here the button is getting close now
so this is the first part of my code now
okay now we talk about called navigation
or navbar search so here I'm starting
with my
never
search
okay so inside my Nava search we would
like to offer some more new number of
fields so called form
okay so I start with my form
now with this form
I may not say action for a time being so
I'm just removing this action from this
instead we are saying form class
equal to
d
hyphen none
space MD
hyphen
inline
okay hyphen block
hyphen block
okay so MD hyphen inline hyphen block
after that you have to suggest form
hyphen and here you see inline because I
want to go ahead with the inline form
and also ml iPhone Auto
the space Mr hyphen 0
Space Mr iPhone MD
hyphen 3 my iPhone
to the space my hyphen MD
hyphen 0.
so this is what all about our form but
within this form is not at closed it is
just a first portion of the form plus
along with this we'll be also offering
the div class so we just use div
here I say plus equal to
input hyphen group
input hyphen group and
now inside this input icing group I want
to use input class
input type equal to text and here I say
Plus
input
class equal to
foreign
hyphen
control
solve hyphen control we would like to
add few more classes here first it is
form control type equal to what type it
is a type text and now we say
placeholder equal to
search
for
okay this is the property for me where I
want to use it and a part of that
foreign
level equal to
search
it will make it
okay search here and followed by a few
more properties
the first property I'm trying to use it
a part of this area search we say area
hyphen
okay described by and here we give the
value called basic hyphen
hyphen
add on to
okay so this is how we are trying to add
it now after this what next after this
we would like to use another div tag now
div and here we say
class equal to inside this class we may
offer few more details uh
okay like I can say input group
input hyphen
hyphen group hyphen
append
okay that is the div class and inside
this step class
I would like to use also another button
here we say
class equal to BTN space vtn iPhone
primary okay type equal to what it is a
button so that's it and after that
within this button I would like to use I
class
equal to
FS space x-ray hyphen
search
okay that's it so this is how we are
making it first and now we'll be going
ahead with the next level okay so let's
get started with the next point now so
we have finished our div and div for
knowledge we'll try to organize it
properly
okay now the Deep div and this part is
getting close and now we would like to
talk about our nav white part okay so
here I'm starting with the nav point so
here accelerometry
foreign
just to tell you like this would be the
never related
stuff here I'll start with my UL tag now
so inside my UL I say you will space
class equal to
navbar
okay so we have a call navbar hyphen
nav
okay space ml
hyphen
Auto
space ml hyphen MD hyphen 0.
so that is for my UL So within this URL
I'll be having some Li class also so we
have got Li within this Li I'm saying
class equal to
now what are the details I want I say
nav hyphoon
item
okay nav hyphen I item space
drop down
okay so now hyphen item space what a
drop down low now within this
Li tag okay I want to use a lot of other
tags too so first tag I'm using this is
called anchor tag okay
so in this anchor tag we want to say a
and followed by
class equal to
well I'm saying now iPhone
link
followed by drop down
hyphen toggle
okay after this space ID equal to
user
drop down
Okay add equal to what user drop down
href
equal to you just make it as a just a
hash
because I'm not taking anywhere after
this hash we say role equal to
button so role will be a button type and
the job doesn't get over here we also
have some option called
data hyphen
toggle
data hyphen toggle equal to drop down
equal to drop down
space we also want to use some area
has pop-up
the property called ariad has pop-up so
I just said true
yes exactly it does have and we also
want to say area hyphen
expanded
you see now area hyphen expanded we're
also saying
false a part of that
we also want to use some image within
this so
image
so
in this image you want to say SRC SRC
will be under
okay
assets under the assets it will be under
ID Dot
PNG this is already sorry jpg
there's already one value available
inside this ID PNG alt we don't want it
as of now
if you want you can add it otherwise I'm
just leaving it blank I'm just using
this option called style equal to now
border hyphen
border hyphen radius
okay this hyphen border it is how much
you want to give I'm saying 50 percent
that is the CC system okay and followed
by width
how much weight you're giving it I'm
saying 50 pixels
50.
okay that's the whole idea for this
now the anchor tag is getting closed
okay so here the anchor tag is closed
after the acne tag is closed we would
like to give another dip class now for
the drop down so we say this div class
will have some of the set of properties
which is available I say div
class equal to
drop down
okay hyphen menu
and
followed by
hyphen menu
hyphen
right
okay and followed by we want to use area
hyphen
you can see this option called level by
equal to give the option name for the
user drop top I'm just giving the value
user
drop down value has been given now
within this div tag itself we'll be
adding some new more values what those
values will be I'm saying anchor tag
plus equal to
now that is an anchor tag class equal to
drop down
drop down hyphen item
okay space uh href
equal to hash
equal to what and
we are giving the value called what
settings
okay now I just copy this line
okay and let's have only two for a
timing so drop down hyphen item hdf
settings and we're gonna give one more
option that's called activity log
activity
log
that's the value
for activity log
okay anchor tag is getting close now
here after that we use another tip tag
here
it's called nestative tag
okay so in this div tag we want to use
class
equal to drop down iPhone item
drop down hyphen item and
I would say by the drop down iPhone
divider
drop down hyphen
divider as a value and in the same div
tag
this job tag is getting closed here and
we're using one more okay
and class
equal to drop down hyphen item
dot down item item hrf equal to give the
value the one which you want to give it
I'm saying hash
okay
it's difficult to what hash
we can close this up
yeah that's F equal to hash and uh
we just use router link
equal to as you know it very well in
typical navigation we always use the
router link rather than normal href and
here we are given the name called what
login
okay and here we can use
router link active equal to
active
okay and here we get the name call
logout
look
[Music]
okay so that's the value which we're
giving it now anchor tag is closed and
here the div tag is closed Li ul and nav
so let me organize it this one
this one
and lab tag
let me format this
okay so that's what my file is
okay so let's continue to this so we
have created the value till now and we
want to start with this div tag now now
with this Dev tag
we would like to have few more classes
added now
please say div ID equal to
you can just give the name called layout
side info
layout side nav
so this is the first value we are taking
it now with this layout site name a part
of this we would like to use another div
diagonal
and inside this div we would like to
offer the ID
equal to
layout
sitemap
whatever name we have used it underscore
name
that is a second div tag we have it now
now within this we want to use the nav
okay with this snap we want to say Plus
equal to
SB hyphen side have
side nav hyphen
menu
that value we are passing it to this
okay that is for
SB hyphen side nav view or back along
with this rather than menu I can have
another option with me to make it even
more better SB hyphen sidelab space
accordion
sorry
accordion okay so according we're going
to give you the kind of flipping type of
moment one after another as the hyphen
side nav
hyphen
doc and space ID equal to
Side neighborhood
side
now
according
so this value we are using it now with
this map So within this snap we would
like to bring another div class now by
saying live
and inside this div we will say class
equal to
uh I would say SP
yphen side nav
hyphen
menu
okay now within this div tag we want to
use another Dev diagram
so you might be thinking so many tips I
guess that is why we want to make it
more organized we say class equal to
name
okay now within this Dev tag we would
like to use another div
here we want to say SP hyphen
SB iPhone side nav
hyphen menu
hyphen heading
sitemap hyphen menu hyphen heading
okay and in this we just giving the what
we call
this is the value of this
okay so this is what for the first drip
tag
now within this div tag
with the step tag is closed we want to
use the anchor diagram okay
plus equal to
nav python
link
okay nav hyperlink followed by
href equal to give the name call index
dot HTML
so this is your href one second
it's difficult to index dot HTML now now
within this anchor tag we want to use
the dev diagram
okay and in this div we would like to
say class
equal to
SB hyphen
nav hyphen link
hyphen icon
so Deb plus equal to SB hyphen now
hyphen link hyphen icon so this is a
class of my devtim item
okay now this particular
class insert is we want to use
the I class I'm saying I
plus equal to FS
space Cafe hyphen
tachometer
tachometer hyphen LED
okay and we are closing this so I tag is
getting close the div tag is getting
close
okay and within this I'm giving the
value called what dashboard
foreign
okay so a class equal to
giving this call
nav link and hdf equal to index Dot
HTML and here we have the dev type which
is getting closed now and here the
anchor tag is closed
and after the anchor tag is closed we
can use few more div tags inside this
okay let's see about which of the div
tags are now left with here we'll start
another Dev tag
now inside this div we say class equal
to
SB hyphen
sidelab
okay let's be hyphen site now hyphen
menu
hyphen heading
hyphen heading and now we want to use
one tool name code interface
foreign
after this we would like to use another
anchor tag
okay and now with this anchor tag we
want to say class
equal to now uh as we know it very well
we have given this called menu heading
so we can enabling collapse so we say
now hyphen link
space
collapsed
okay so that is a
class which we're using it now with my
anchor tag
okay collapsed after the tracing href
equal to hash
of equal to what hash and
toggle equal to
collapse
so that's the value we are giving it to
my data toggle now after that we're
giving some more values here one where
we are giving is called Data Target
foreign
by saying collapse layout
collapse layouts
that is a data Target and we just want
to say area
hyphen expanded
area height and expanded equal to
false and one more property I want to
give it it is called area hyphen
controls
area hyphen
okay equal to collapse layout
collabs layouts
exactly let me try to add it here
and enter it here
collapse layouts okay so anchor tag is
there so within my anchor tag where it
is getting closed I just want to give
one more
Dev tag inside this
yeah so here we have got
So within this div tag we want to give
some additional property to this tip so
we know it variable what type of details
we are talking about so we set up class
equal to SB
hyphen nav link
SB hyphen nav link
okay hyphen icon
there is another class we are using it
now and uh sorry
SB hyphen nav hyphen link that's the
first property we have taken let me
close this
and
okay so SB hyphen nav hyphen link and uh
part of this you can just use hyphen
icon
hyphen
icon okay within this uh I can use I
class
so here I'm using I
class equal to
so which class you want to use it I'm
saying FS
space fa hyphen
angle
okay hyphen Dom
so this is your I class which we are
defining it right now
okay closing this so I tag is getting
closed along with the dev diagram
okay and anchor tag is anyways getting
closed
thank you
okay anchor tag is anyways is getting
close here so inside this we would like
to give because the div tag is getting
close we want to give home
any value which you want to do so we're
giving what over here
this is where it is getting close right
now
okay so after the div tag is getting
closed we are using this and uh
so later on we can go back and try to
implement more ideas okay so we have
finished one point of areas now we would
like to go back and start working with
the row level now so now here with my
application we want to use
do another div tag now So within this
div tag we want to use some classes we
set the
space
class equal to
row
okay after this I use one more div tag
and in this div tag we want to use one
more property here called
uh
class equal to call
hyphen Excel
hyphen 6. so six columns layout we are
trying to add it now here we are trying
to say div
and with this div we say class
equal to now see the properties now div
class equal to we're using card
space MB hyphen 4.
card space MB hyphen 4 we're using this
property now after that we would like to
use another Dev tag
with using div
plus equal to
header
class
and inside this we want to say I
I
class equal to some addition declaration
I'm saying FAS space
f a hyphen
chart
hyphen
area Space Mr hyphoon one
so
closing this so I tag is getting closed
here we're going to give the value name
called weekly analysis
weekly
weekly analysis okay so with this div
tag it is getting closed I want to bring
another div tag inside this
now with this div tag
we want to write another class here that
is known is called class equal to card
hyphen body
so we want to give class equal to cart
hyphen plus equal to
card hyphen
body
okay and
this class equal to cart Heights and
body we want to bring another thing
inside this that is called IMG
equal to now here
from the assets we want to use
area
chart
area chart Dot
PNG so that location we want to use it
now followed by
width equal to 100 percent
okay and
height
equal to 280.
okay and here the tip tag is getting
closed
okay so we're talking about this Dev tag
and there's another tip tag is getting
closed below this this is the third div
tag is also getting close now
okay so we totally have three dip Tigers
getting close and we would like to use
another Dev diagram
we want to set them
class equal to once again call hyphen
access
Excel
hyphen 6.
so six columns layout you're talking
about
and after that we say div class
div class equal to card
space MB iPhone 4.
okay the classical card space MB hyphen
4 and again we use another div tag
okay and in statistic we say class equal
to
div class equal to what
header so rather I would say card iPhone
header
card iPhone header now now within this
Dev tag we want to use another I class
people
yeah so within this card hyphen header
we want to use the
another
chart so as we've already seen we have
used this assets
hyphen chart area dot chart PNG in a
similar way we would like to use the
same technique now for the monthly
report also
okay so we have a call called sl6 card
MP4
okay we are using what card header so in
this the way we have used weekly
analysis
I just copy this the same
okay and I paste it here
okay and here what I try to offer not
weekly analysis I would other offer
monthly report
okay monthly report and after the div
tackle is close card body and now we
talk about called bar chart.png
but
chart dot PNG width equal to 100
div depth like is getting closed yeah so
this is how we're trying to use it now
so just like that we can keep on using
some other properties too now here
we want to use one module
okay in this div tag we feel class
now let's provide another property here
foreign
and other details too
we were on this position called card
hyphen MBA Raymond force and follow to
this we want to use uh on the div tag by
saying div class equal to cartridge
class equal to card hyphen
header so that is one of the div class
we are using it now so inside this div
class we want to use another I I
class
equal to here I am using once again FS
space f a
hyphen
table space
Mr
hyphen 1.
okay that's the position we are using it
right now
okay and after this I tag here we Define
this option equal employee data
employee data so here the div tag is
getting closed
okay so now our three properties we have
taken it now weekly monthly report
employee data now we would like to
create a table now
so whatever we are looking forward for
let's start we are saying there
class equal to
cart hyphen
body
okay now within this div class equal to
quad iPhone body we are using another
depth right here now
okay and inside this div tag we'll see
plus equal to
table hyphen
the responsive so we want to use stable
hyphen responsive
fine now after this we want to create a
table
okay within this table
okay we would like to
create multiple things but let me add
some classes here here I'm saying table
plus equal to we want to use table
this space
table hyphen border
[Music]
border and after that we use ID equal to
just give the name called data table
after this data table we serve with
equal to 100 percent
100 and also we want to use cell spacing
foreign
spacing
so some spacing we're giving equal to
zero
that is for my table and now inside this
table I can have table head
under the table that I will be using TR
so TR under which will be having
pH which is called table heading so we
give you the first property
foreign
like this I just copy this
and take few more property
name position
here we give call office
then age
then we can start it
and one more
and the responsible salary
so these are part of table heading TR is
closed the head is closed now we would
like to use t-body
would like to use keyboard you know
inside a tea body we want to use tier
which is your table row under this we
want to use what
TD that is called what a table data so
here we can give the name
so the first whatever they're giving is
called tiger
next one let me copy and paste it
so that is the first value second is
non-scope position so we are saying
system architect
okay system architect that is what my
table data
next we're looking forward for office
Edinburgh
next it is asking for
your age let's give each call 61. next
is asking for the start date so we just
give
slash zero four
slash 25 and yet we can give it last
which is asking for the salary you just
say dollar
any random value I've given it more
okay so this is the first stable Loop is
basically closed like that we can have
multiple records with me I copy this
and have another
and have another so as my number of
Records you want you can basically have
it done
okay let me quickly change the name
this value called accounting
next value which we have it that is
called Tokyo
range
X3
okay same and here we can give
okay
and here you can change the values later
on if you want but for the display
purpose it's okay
okay so here the multiple things are
getting closed your tea body is getting
closed your table is getting closed your
Dev tag is getting close your Dev tag is
getting closed and after this we have
got one more
that is the other okay after closing the
last depth tag we would like to also
close
the main okay after this main uh we
would like to start working with this
photo part now
in this footer
we would like to add some new classes
here I'm saying class equal to
py
Thon 4
space BG hyphen
light space empty hypher
Auto
okay followed by we can use the another
Dev tag and inside this div we can use
plus equal to
container hyphen fluid
container hyphen fluid now there is
another div tag
okay inside this div we want to use what
class equal to
hyphen Flex
okay space
align hyphen
items hyphen
Center space
justify
hyphen content
hyphen between
space small
okay now inside this div we would like
to use another div
ided
class
equal to text mounted
text
hyphen muted
okay and we would like to offer
here let's go copyright
copyright
okay and
copy
okay
space
give the name
Dot simpler or else
like this
so div tag is getting closed here now
after that you can use
hrf equal to you can just give hash
okay
and now you can give the value called
what privacy policy
privacy policy
okay and here in private sequence you
can just give ampersand
okay
okay and
okay and after this again href
so after this
we can use but first anchor tag is
getting closed here after this privacy
policy
Okay so
now another href here hash rather than
privacy policy I'm going to give terms
okay in terms
give space
okay conditions
okay terms and conditions
you don't need this now and that's it
for div
photo is also getting closed div tag is
also getting closed
same photographs also and
there's another tip tag is getting
closed and after that
another
okay and that's it body will be closed
Post that
okay so there are a lot of space let me
try to remove
that's it so now let me format it
let's avoid this other ways create a
confusion so guys our map our component
is ready and after that we go back and
try to add few more things into my code
now we're gonna create few more
components into my code so first
component a part of this what we have
seen I'm gonna create one more component
name called toggle so NG space g is
space c
the space
toggle
okay a part of that we want to create
few more components here the responsible
routes so NG space g space c space
routes
okay
so this component is ready along with
this
as we know it very well like there are
certain components which you have
created we also would like to create few
more components into my application
okay by saying
NG the space g space c space
[Music]
let's see
so under the routes we have got what
charts is another component which we
have seen now
okay now in a similar way I would like
to create one more component under the
routes and that is also a login
components ready along with this login
we would like to create a register
and along with this we would like to
also go back and create one more
component here that is also called
password
so charts login register password
so four components are ready now and
they're all inside what they're all
inside another Roots now
okay so these all components are now
ready with me and we'll be basically
making all those components Associated
inside my round spot
clear enough so which component used
what that we have to basically consider
it now so since they're all of the
components now
so under my
app.routing.module.ts we have to
basically provide a routings here now so
here we know con spot routes equal to
blank so let me try to say
part okay
if nothing has been given so the by
default component will be what
component will be
never
component
so this network components automatically
comes in here
after that
if path is somewhat
static
component
is what
toggle component
okay and here we are saying
path match
colon
full
okay along with this we're giving one
more path
colon login
so here
component
colon
login component
go to put comma
component C is small
okay now like this next we talk about
all path
colon
register
okay and here
concurrent colon
register
now let's talk about what path colon
what
change
password
so here we say
component
comma
component colon
which component we are trying to say
password component
next
we want to say path
colon
charts
then
[Music]
confident Boolean
charts company so these are the
components are now available to me so
these components are now all set and
later on we'll be combining all the
files together in my system one by one
okay everybody so our all components are
now all ready so you see like you ever
got navbar
which contains all the necessary tags
whichever is required for my application
here we have a basically the login and
this
login.component.html actually contains
all the relative part which is related
to your login like you can talk about
call
um
email you talk about called password you
have a call remember me and forgot
password these type of details are
available inside your login
component.html now so this is basically
the code okay which contains your login
related stuffs now
so it contains only few properties like
you talk about like email address it
contains what a password and only the
buttons through which user can login
through
followed by when I see my
password so this password
file that is called
password.component.html it contains the
details regarding to your password so
that the user can give the password
details or in case the user has
or want to change the password so we can
give the details like okay you can enter
your email ID
address where I can send the password to
you so here we have this email address
we haven't implemented your
I would say any kind of sending the
email to your uh registered email ID
that logic hasn't been implemented but
it's just for the demo like how exactly
you can bring this password
forgot condition inside your system now
so this is what the password and here we
have a link for the login and here we
have about registration
followed by if you think about call
register register contains that
register Dot component.html and here if
you see there are few details which are
expecting from the user like in first
name last name email password confirm
password so these are the quick fields
which I'm expecting from the user to
enter
and here it's a button for uh you know
confirming a password and this is what
exactly the links which are available
for the login
okay and for the login.html file so this
is a simple registration form which is
available to me and that is last which
is available for me for that for me that
is called toggling part
in toggle part we are just offering
the details with regards to your how in
case if you want to toggle you can
change the settings okay based on
between the settings and activity okay
so these are the links which are
available through which you can change
all different type of toggling part
whether you would like to enable or not
enable this is something which is
related to your page in case if you
click on that link so 401 page 404 page
500 page which will be available to us
now let's try to run the code and check
how the final application really looks
like in
okay so now I'm trying to run my
application
by
saying
npim space start once again
okay
okay and now I'm trying to say
in tablespace start
let the project start now
I will see how it really looks like it
if it is compiling all the files
okay and finally let's try to execute
localhost photo double zero
let me see what is an issue right now
thank you
okay let me check mean while try to run
it run it again
thank you
okay now I finally uh I'm into my
current project right now so it was the
wrong location where the project was
available so I just like to say npm
space start and let the project run
so project is picking up till the time I
say localhost 420
and beautiful guys this is how exactly
your projects really looks like it
isn't this an amazing right now see how
beautiful your project really looks like
it this is what exactly the dashboard
you have it and this is the nav bar
which is available to you getting it now
see how better and beautiful it looks
and organized so this is like in real
time dashboard which is available where
you can see the birthdays we have it we
talk about
you know Company announcement quick
links these all basically available
these are the charts which you can see
can give some dummy values and these are
the charts will be really available to
you so this is how the employee records
which we had it which we are displaying
it right now and this is how exactly the
chart looks like it
so weekly analysis and monthly analysis
this is a dashboard and here the links
are there but they're all dummy links we
haven't made it but you can certainly
make it further
okay you can search for
anything but it is not working right now
because it is just for the display
purpose nothing more than that it is a
home which you can see written like in
profile this is like the profile which
you have created by default the name is
called Kate Adams uh and this is
designation like an accountant and uh
like you can talk about like home under
the home you have a code profile we have
called settings
so nothing is the research in the
settings so it is just a static record
attendance
it'll be bringing you back to the same
page we have a call confirmation travel
expenses these are basically the dummy
links which are available we haven't
made it which you can see new
development okay part of that you see
like profile we have it settings account
activity if you see we have called login
and register these three page if you
remember we have created it under this
system
so you can see we have a got login we
have a call register we have a call
passwords so these are you are able to
see this now when you say change
password you see like
how they have given to you they are not
actually working but they're just like
an dummy option and you can see it is
really taking you directly to the sign
up option
okay
now here in your settings once again you
can look forward for the login
it works like in a typical model how it
comes a part of that we also have this
call register so these are the fields of
registration form
and
you see about activity activity we have
called these pages are available they're
all basically dummy Pages which we have
created downloads confirmation so really
it this project really gives you the
kind of sense of in a real time how your
application angular application can
really make your UI more attractive
which are more competitive in market so
I hope you guys love this project so we
have developed most of the codes by our
own except few which we have taken it
from uh online that is nothing but call
uh especially those images as well as uh
what to say some JavaScript related
libraries if you see which we are using
it right now here you think about think
about this uh
uh your
neighbor.component.html if you see like
these are the libraries we have taken it
from internet
because certainly we don't type it
because it is taking long time to type
certainly we have taken from internet
and some images also we have taken it
from the internet which are there under
the assets folder too
so if you see under the assets we have a
lot of images like an area chart bar
chart chart so this we have downloaded
from the internet in this we are going
to talk about the maven here now we will
be talking about that how exactly we can
make use of Maven here in performing
various kind of operations whether it's
available compilation various kind of
stuff there so let's talk about it why
exactly we use Maven here now Maven is
something which is a kind of a build
tool which is there for most of the
job-based projects here so this tool
also helps us in building up the source
code by downloading some couple of
dependencies these dependencies are
something which is being configured by
the developers which a developer feels
that uh the project is dependent on and
he requires those dependencies to be
downloaded so uh this tool is
specifically used to build and manage
any kind of a jar based project whatever
the complexity of the topic or the
project is there so this tool will be
able to handle that particular
requirement or the that project so it
simplifies the day-to-day work of a Java
developer and helps them in their
projects for performing daily to daily
activities
right now Maven also helps us in getting
the uh specific jar files for each and
every project so if you are going you
can pretty much make a jar file bar file
or your file any kind of a package
mechanism you can follow for your me one
day so to download the dependencies we
don't have to actually go to the
official website of each and every
software you can easily get it uh the
dependencies of each and every third
party binaries on the mvnrepository.com
this is a website which is present on
which if you visit you will be able to
download the dependencies which is
required by your project or by your
specific uh project over here so it
totally depends on how exactly you want
to download and you want to get together
a specific repository over here so
inventrepository.com is the one if you
visit you will be able to download and
go through all the jar files dependent
jar files as independencies which you
require for your current project
right so now what exactly is on Maven
all about so let's see on that part so
Maven is a popular open source Bell tool
which is uh developed by the Apache
group and the primary uh ownership of
this tool is to build publish and deploy
several projects at once Maven is
written in Java and it can be used to
build projects written in C sharp Scala
Ruby Etc so apart from java these are
the different programming languages or
the tools which is supported by the
maven here for performing the build
activity so the tool is used for build
and management of any kind of a jar
based project it simplifies the
day-to-day work of a Java developer and
helps them to automate most of the
compilation or build uh perspective
tasks on the projects
right now Maven is a kind of a bomb
based project so it also known as in
Project object model and it focuses on
of simplification and standardization of
the building process in the process it
take care of all the followings here
builds dependencies reports distribution
releases mailing list so all these uh
things are being taken care as in this
particular process here and ultimately
it's an availability inside the maven
that how the overall build process needs
to be automated and standardized here so
all these particular mechanisms is can
be followed as such over here so that we
can have a good standards and the
simplifications implemented as such here
now what exactly is an Maven repository
all about
so Maven repository is something which
is uh kind of a directory or it's kind
of a location where we have all the jar
files packaged all together in a single
location so depending on the software
which you want to download the dependent
Java files can be downloaded from there
so the metadata refers to the pump files
relevant to each project here this
metadata is what allows Maven to
download the dependencies now there are
three type of repositives from where we
can download the dependencies the first
one is the local repository second one
is the remote repository and the third
one is the central repository so these
are the primary three type of
repositories which is available there
for our per specific Maven over here
so whatever repository you want to
follow you want to access you can pretty
much access it and you can go with that
right now the local repository will be
primary present onto your PC that's the
way that how it's present there and the
particular remote repository is
something which you can store on any
remote machine or remote server and the
central repository is something which
you can have it on to the Internet so
usually the central repositories is
something in which we can actually host
our different kind of dependencies and
the jar files over there
so local repository on the machine of
the developer where the project material
is saved so all the particular
dependencies jar file will be available
on your local machine remote machine is
the location where you can actually
store all your particular dependencies
from where you can download these
dependencies whenever you require it so
this and repositories work similar to
the central repository whenever anything
is needed from remote repository it's
first downloaded into your local
repository and then it will be utilized
so if you feel that the dependency is
something which is not there in the
local it will be first downloaded from
the remote repository and then it will
be utilized or will be referenced onto
the local machine there
and Central repository is refers to the
maven drip Community repository there
where you will be able to see each and
and every dependency present on that
repository so Maven downloads the
repositories from here in the local
repository whenever they need it or
whenever required all these dependencies
are cached locally from where it will be
referenced in the next or you know
whenever we want to refer that we will
be able to do that particular reference
easily on that part
so this is the way that how the three uh
particular repositories or Maven
repositories really helps us for
performing various kind of automations
as such here
right now what are the basic concepts of
Maven here so some of the couple of
basic concepts which is present in Maven
is like for the first time we have the
project object model so project Palm
reference to the XML file which has all
the information regarding the project
how this particular project should be
built up how the different build process
should be automated there it also has a
description of the project details
regarding the versioning versioning
information is also stored as such in
this XML file in this particular Palm
reference file as such over here the XML
file is which is there in the project
home directory so Maven is something
which search for the pump file in the
current directory if it's able to find
that particular pump file so it will
execute or it will proceed with the
build step otherwise the it will hold
there itself so this Pawn file is very
important because it will act as a kind
of a build script and primarily the
maven tool will be able to process each
and everything which is configured as
such in this specific fake XML file
there and according to that only it will
function or it will proceed further
right now second thing is the
dependencies and repositories so
dependencies are usually refers to the
jar files so the Java libraries which we
need in our into our particular project
so while working on the project we may
be having the dependency on couple of
dependencies so these dependencies we
have to actually download or we have to
actually refer and once this is a
particular information or these details
are referred so what will happen that uh
we need to download these specific
dependencies from the particular Maven
repositories so if the dependencies are
not present in your local repository
then Maven will try to download it from
the central repository and cache it into
your local repository but first of all
it will look on into the local
repository and if it is not present in
local then only it will go to the remote
or the central Repository
then we have build life cycles and phase
and goes there so build life cycles
consists of the sequence of build phases
and each field phase consists of
sequence of goals here now each goal is
responsible for performing a specific
task when a phase is uh running all the
goals related to that phase and its
plugins are also used to performing the
compilation preparing the artifacts
downloading the dependencies all
different things being done by the
plugin cm then we have the build profile
so build profiles refers to a set of
configuration values now generally we
have the generic build process for all
the environments all the particular code
base there but sometimes we do have some
kind of a differences there so that is
where we can go for the profiles because
a specific profile can have its own
configuration and whatever it's required
for the build process we can have
different different configurations
stored inside the maven build script
here
then we have different uh build profiles
are added to the pump files and which
enables the different uh build as such
here so depending on these profiles we
can actually decide that how we need to
proceed with the build process and how
the different kind of build order
missions needs to be performed here then
a build profile helps in customizing the
build for the different environments so
that also we can perform as such while
work forming or while working on the
different components and the different
management here so a build profile is
something which you can configure you
can utilize and depending on that build
profile we will be deciding whether to
proceed further or how to design on that
particular Factor so these are something
which we need to take here or we need to
work according to see which we can
decide that how the specific
configurations and specific automation
needs to be performed here
now usually when we go for the uh Maven
there so we have to use some couple of
Maven plugins now the goal of using
these uh specific plugins is to automate
some of the basic stuff like compilation
creating the VAR file creating the jar
file so when we are using the plugins we
don't have to configure the steps or
write the steps that how these uh
specific plugins should be installed or
should be referenced it's ultimately the
internal configurations which we are
looking forward or which we are using
while working on these specific plugins
so you can download some couple of
plugins using which we will be able to
decide that how a specific goals needs
to be achieved here so Maven has its own
standard plugins that can be utilized so
if uh we know want to go for a custom
one so you can do that but pretty much
you can go for the default one and you
can pretty much have some specific goals
executed with the help of these build
plugins
now next thing is the maven architecture
so uh in Maven what happens that uh
let's talk about the basic architecture
of Maven here so the maven is Equitable
when it's deployed so it usually uh
reads the palm.xml file which is the
build script here now once the specific
bounded XML file is being read out so it
will process the components it will uh
you know download or it will process the
dependencies plugins life cycles phases
and goals and even the build profiles
and uh if any kind of interaction is
required so it will try to connect to
the central repository or remote
repository and according to that it will
provide the information and provide the
details as such so mu 1 repository is
something which is very important
because it's ultimately trying to
connect to the maven repository and try
to achieve the various kind of
automation here so it's really important
because ultimately it's trying to help
us to go for the complete end-to-end
build automation when we'll go for a
specific Palm based build automation
so Maven is going to read the palm.xml
file then download the dependencies
defined into the power XML file and that
dependencies are cached locally from the
remote or the central repository now
then create and generate a remote report
according to the requirement and execute
the life cycles phases goals plugins Etc
so it will process the power XML file
then and whatever the plugins and goals
or the life cycles which is configured
there step by step each of them will be
executed into a sequence here
now let's talk about the overall build
life cycle of the maven here so what
happens that uh the maven build life
cycle is something which is a kind of a
collection of different steps there and
this is something which is followed uh
to perform a build automation for a
specific project so that they are pretty
much three steps which is being done so
first one is the default so it handles
the project deployment there second
handles the project cleaning which is a
clean there and then we have site so it
handles the creation of the project
sites documentation there so these are
the three built-in particular life
cycles which is available there at the
bevel level which you can utilize to
perform a various kind of particular
steps execution for your project
right so the build cycle has the
different build phases or stages there
because when we are performing a build a
variety of things needs to be performed
over here so the first one is the
compile then test compile is there so
compilation is there for the source file
and test compile is there for the test
cases test will execute the test cases
package will package the bundle then we
have the integration test to run the
integration test cases then we have the
verify then install goal is there and
the last one is the deploy which is
there to deploy the artifacts to the
artifact tree so all these things are
the different phases and the stages
which is being followed as per a
specific build here so during these
builds these are the different phases
and these stages which we normally
follow for performing the build
automation
now what is the exactly advantage of a
specific Maven here so that is something
which we need to talk about that how the
particular automation needs to be done
or how we can actually go for the
configurations where we feel that yes we
want to perform or we want to take
certain benefits out of the
implementation of Maven here so for that
what happens that we have to see that
the various kind of benefits the first
one is that Apache Mi one helps manage
all the processes there such as building
documentation releasing and distribution
in project management here so the tool
simplifies the process of project
building it increases the performance of
the project and the building process all
together and the task of downloading jar
files and other dependencies is also
done automatically we don't have to
indulge in any kind of download part as
such manually over here
right and Maven provides easy access to
all the required information so Maven
makes it easy for a specific developer
to build a project in the different
environments so we don't have to worry
about the environment we don't have to
worry about the infrastructure nothing
is required everything is available
there inside this package and you know
depending on the particular you can
write the source code on one machine and
you can pretty much do the build on
another machine and this is the reason
how the build automation really happens
on the first place because the developer
is writing the source code in one
location and the same code is deployed
onto the particular or built onto this
Jenkins or any kind of build tool there
right in Maven you can easily add new
dependencies so you must write the
particular dependencies in the form file
so if you feel that you want to download
some particular dependencies so all you
have to do is that you have to put that
dependency into the specific palm.xml
file there and depending on that the
execution will be really performed and
executed as a chair right so let's talk
about the demo now so let's see that how
exactly we can go for this demo and we
can perform the various kind of
automations
so this is the virtual machine which we
have here on which the maven is already
installed so we can run like mvn
so Maven will be available as in 3.6.3
here now I'm going to run a particular
command called mvn archetype generate
here
let me create a directory here
our temp directory
and to perform this activity over there
so mvn
archetype
generate now once we run that so what
will happen that it will download some
of the binders there because uh
ultimately what we are trying to do is
that we are trying to generate a new
project like a maven project so couple
of a particular plugins will be
downloaded by the maven executable so
that it can achieve that particular
execution so we just have to wait for
downloading all these values now here
it's trying to give us a particular
attributes like it's asking the
different attributes over here so what
exactly we want to configure so if you
want to configure you can provide that
details otherwise you can perform or
whatever the setup you want to perform
now here it's asking for the version so
which kind of version we want to follow
so I'm going to follow like five here so
I'll press five
then a group ID which is there so it's
basically a kind of a group mechanism so
I can say like com dot simply learn so
that's a value which I'm providing here
artifact ID I can make it like a sample
project or something like that I can do
so that will be the artifact uh ID which
is there so version I am keeping the
same only so and uh yeah so package same
here
so I just want to create so I'll just
provide the value called yes and enter
so with this what will happen that your
sample project will be created here
right so whatever the artifact ID you
provided so according to that the
project is created in this directory so
you have to go into this directory and
see that what exactly the files are
created there so you have the pound.xml
file now this palm.xm file when I open
so you can see here that there are some
attributes like you can have the values
uh related to what version or group ID
you want to follow so this is a group ID
this is the artifact ID so this is jar
file by default you can change it
according to your requirement and this
is the version and if you feel that you
want to do the changes to the name that
also you can perform here so by default
the J unit dependencies added but if you
want to keep on adding your own custom
dependencies you will be able to do that
now in this case if you run like mvn
clean install so it will be considered
as in particular Maven project a
power.xml file is already there present
in the local directory so according to
that the execution of the steps will be
performed and according to that you will
be able to get some desired values here
so ultimately in the Target directory
you will be able to see that some couple
of java file or a specific jar file is
generated here so you can see that in
the Target directory this jar file or
this artifact is generated here so this
is the way that how we can actually go
for a generic one like a new particular
project and later on you can depending
on your uh understanding you can keep on
adding or you can keep on modifying the
dependencies and that's how you can get
the final result there
so that's it for this demo in which we
have find out that how exactly we can go
for a particular project uh preparation
with the help of mvn executable let's
get started with Jenkins Jenkins in my
opinion is one of the most popular
continuous integration servers of recent
times what began as a hobby project by a
developer working for Sun Microsystems
way back in early or mid-2000s has
gradually and eventually evolved into a
very very powerful and robust automation
servers it has a wide adoption since it
is released under MIT license and is
almost free to use Jenkins has a vast
developer community that supports it by
writing all kinds of plugins plugins is
the heart and soul of Jenkins because
using plugins one can connect Jenkins to
anything and everything under the sun
with that introduction let's get into
what all will be covered as a part of
this tutorial I will get into some of
the prerequisites required for
installing Jenkins post which I will go
ahead and install Jenkins on our Windows
box there are few first time
configuration that needs to be done and
I will be covering those as well so once
I have Jenkins installed and configured
properly I will get into the user
administrative part I create few users
and I will use some plugins for setting
up various kinds of access permissions
for these users I will also put in some
freestyle jobs freestyle job is nothing
but a very very simple job and I will
also show you the powerfulness of
Jenkins by scheduling this particular
job to run based upon time schedule I
will also connect Jenkins with GitHub
GitHub is our source code where source
code repository where I've got some
repositories put up there so using
Jenkins I will connect to GitHub pull up
a repository that is existing on GitHub
onto the Jenkins box and run few
commands to build this particular
repository that is pulled from GitHub
sending out emails is a very very
important configurations of Jenkins or
any other continuous integration server
for that matter Whenever there is any
notifications that has to be sent out as
a part of either build going bad or
build being good or building propagated
to some environment and all these
scenarios you would need the continuous
integration servers to be sending out
notifications so I will get into a
little bit details of how to configure
Jenkins for sending out emails I will
also get into a scenario where I would
have a web application a maven-based
Java web application which will be
pulled from a GitHub repository and I
will deploy it onto a tomcat server the
Tomcat server will be locally running on
my system eventually I will get into one
other very very important topic which is
the Master Slave configuration it's a
very very important and pretty
interesting topic where distributed
builds is achieved using a Master Slave
configuration so I will bring up a slave
I will connect the slave with the master
and I'll also put in a job and kind of
delegate that particular job to the
slave configuration finally I will let
you know how to use some plugins to
backup your Jenkins so Jenkins has got a
lot of useful information set up on it
in terms of the build environment in
terms of workspace all this can be very
very easily backed up using a plugin so
this is what I'm going to be covering as
a part of this tutorial Jenkins is a web
application that is written in Java and
there are various ways in which you can
use and install Jenkins I have listed
popular three mechanisms in which
Jenkins is usually installed on in any
system the topmost one is as a Windows
or a Linux Based Services so if at all
you have Windows like the way I have and
I'm going to use this mechanism for this
demo so I would download a MSI installer
that is specific to Jenkins and install
this service so whenever installed as a
service it goes ahead and nicely
installs all that is required for my
Jenkins and I have a service that can be
started as stopped based upon my need
any flavor of Linux as well one other
way of running Jenkins is downloading
this generic Word file and as long as
you have jdk installed you can launch
this war file by the command opening up
a command prompt or shell prompt
differently on Linux box specifying Java
hyphen jar and the name of this war file
it typically brings up your application
and you know you can continue with your
installation the only thing being if at
all you want to stop using Jenkins you
just go ahead and close this prompt you
either do a control C and then bring
down this prompt and your Jenkins server
would be down other older versions of
Jenkins were run popularly using this
way in which you already have a Java
based web server running up and running
so you kind of drop in this war file
into the root folder or the httpd root
folder of your web server so Jenkins
would explode and kind of bring up your
application all user credentials or user
Administration is all taken care of by
the Apache or the Tomcat server or the
web server on which Jenkins is running
this was a very older way of running but
still some people use it because if they
don't want to maintain two servers if
they already have a Java web server
which it's been nicely maintained and
backed up Jenkins can run attached to it
all right so either ways it doesn't
matter however you're going to bring up
your Jenkins instance the way we're
going to operate Jenkins is all going to
be very very same or similar one with
the subtle changes in terms of user
Administration if it until you're
launching it through any other web
server which will take care of the user
Administration otherwise all the
commands or all the configuration or the
way in which I'm going to run this demo
it is going to be same across any of
these installations all right so the
prerequisites for running Jenkins as I
mentioned earlier Jenkins is nothing but
a simple web application that is written
in Java so all that it needs is Java
preferably jdk 1.7 or 1.8 2GB Ram is the
recommended RAM for running Jenkins and
also like any other open source toolsets
when you install jdk ensure that you set
in the environment variable Java home to
point to the right directory this is
something very specific to jdk but for
any other open source tools that you've
installed there is always a preferred
environment variable that you got to set
in which is specific to that particular
tool that you are going to use this is a
generic thing that is there for you know
for any other open source projects
because the way open source projects
discover themselves is using this
environment variables so as a general
practice or good practice always set
these environment variables accordingly
so I already have jdk 1.8 installed on
my system but in case you do not what I
would recommend is just navigate on your
browser to the Oracle home page and just
type in or search for install jdk1.8
and navigate to The Oracle home page you
will have to accept the license
agreement and there are a bunch of
installers that is okay that you can
pick up based upon the operating system
on which you're running so I have this
windows 64 installer that is already
installed and running on my system so I
will not get into the details of
downloading this or installing it let me
show you once I install this what I've
done with regard to my path
so if you get into environment variables
all right so I have just set in a Java
home variable
if you see this C colon program files
Java jdk 1.8 this is where my my Java is
located C program files C program files
Java
okay so this is the home directory of my
jdk so that is what I've been I've set
it up here in my environment variable
so if you see here this is my Java home
all right one other thing to do is
ensure that in case you want to run Java
or Java C from a command prompt and show
that you also add that path into this
path variable so if you see this
somewhere I will see yes there you go
see colon program files Java jdk 1.8 pin
so with these two I'll ensure that my
Java installation is nice and you know
good enough so to check that to double
check that or to verify that let me just
open up a simple command prompt
and if I type in Java iPhone version
all right and Java C yphen version
so the compiler is on the path Java is
on the path and if at all I do this
even the environment variable specific
to my Java is installed correctly so I
am good to go ahead with my Jenkins
installation
now that I have my prerequisites
all set for installing Jenkins let me
just go ahead and download Jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
Jenkins
all right LTS is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions weeklies I would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that
um long term support is good enough and
as I mentioned there are so many flavors
of Jenkins that is available for
download
you also have a Docker container wherein
you know you can launch Jenkins as a
container but I'll not get into details
of that in this tutorial
all right so what I want is yes this is
the war file which is a generic War file
that I was talking to you earlier and
this is the windows MSI installer so go
ahead and download this MSI installer I
already have that downloaded so let me
just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
Jenkins instance or other installer this
is a pretty maybe a few months old but
this is good enough for me
before you start Jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that there is
a variable called Jenkins home this is
where Jenkins would store all this
configuration data jobs project
workspace and all that specific to
Jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an MSI
installer all your installation gets
into SQL and program files 86 and
Jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user ID with
which you're running your War file the
Jenkins folder there's a DOT Jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to backup your
Jenkins or you want Jenkins
installations to get into some specific
directories go ahead and set this
Jenkins home variable accordingly before
you even begin your installation for now
I don't need to do any of these things
so I've already downloaded the installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation all right so this is my
Jenkins MSI installer I would just I
don't want to make any changes into the
Jenkins configuration C colon program
files is good for me yeah this is where
all my destination folder and all the
configuration specific to it goes I'm
happy with this I don't want to change
this I would just say go ahead and click
installation
okay so what typically happens once the
Jenkins installation gets through is
it'll start installing itself and there
are some small checks that needs to be
done so and by default Jenkins Launches
on the port 8080 so let me just open up
localhost 8080
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein I need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets stored
out here so I will have to just copy
this path
if at all you're running as a war file
you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a Jenkins installation so as a part of
the installation it just asks you to do
this
so if that is not great it'll crib about
it but this looks good so it's going
ahead
all right one important part during the
installation so you would need to
install some recommended plugins what
happens is the plugins are all related
to each other so it's like the typical
RPM kind of a problem where you try to
install some plugin and it's got a
dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what Jenkins
recommends there's a bunch of plugins
that is already recommended so just go
ahead and blindly click that install
recommended plugin so if you see
there is a whole lot of plugins which
are bare essential plugin that is
required for Jenkins in order to run
properly so Jenkins as a part of the
installation would get all these plugins
and then install it for you this is a
good combination to kind of begin with
and mind you at this moment Jenkins
needs lots of bandwidth in terms of
network so in case your you know your
network is not so good few of these
plugins would kind of fail and these
plugins are all you know all available
on openly or or mirrored sites and
sometimes some of them may be down so do
not worry in case some of these plugins
kind of fail to install you'll get an
option to kind of retry installing them
but just ensure that you know at least
most or 1995 of all these plugins are
installed without any problems let me
pause the video here for a minute and
then get back once all these plugins are
installed my plugin installation is all
good there was no failures in any of my
plugins so after that I get to create
this first admin user again this is one
important point that you got to remember
Keen given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it alright so I'm going to create a very
very simple username and password
something that I can remember
I will
that's my name and an email ID is kind
of optional but it doesn't allow me to
go ahead in case I don't so I just given
an admin and I got a password I've got I
remember my password this is my full
name
all right I say seven finish
all right that kind of completed my
Jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that I have my Jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
UI is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys but if at all you're a
Java guy you know how painful it is to
write UI in Java you will kind of
appreciate you know all the effort that
has gone into the UI bottom line you
always little hard to you know wrap your
head around it but once you start using
it possibly you'll start liking it all
right so let me get into something
called as manage Jenkins
this can be viewed like a main menu for
all Jenkins configuration so I'll get
into some of those important ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete Jenkins instance few things to
kind of look out for this is a home
directory this is a Java home where all
the configurations all the workspace
anything and everything regarding
Jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and it's possibly show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration this just lets Jenkins
know at any point in time how many jobs
or how many threads can be run you can
you can kind of visualize it like a
thread that can be run on this
particular instance as a thumb rule if
at all you're on a single core system
number of executors two should be good
enough in case at any point in time if
there are multiple jobs that kind of get
triggered the same time in case the
number of executors are less compared to
the number of jobs that have that woken
up no need to panic because they will
all get queued up and eventually Jenkins
will get to running those jobs just bear
in mind that whenever a new job kind of
you know gets triggered the CPU usage
and the memory usage in terms of the
disk right is very high on the Jenkins
instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors two for my system is kind of
good label for my Jenkins I don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your Jenkins this is good
for me because I only have a primary uh
server that is running so I want to use
this node as much as possible quite
better each of these options I've got
some bare minimal help kind of a thing
that is that is out here by clicking on
these question marks you will get to
know as to what are these particular
configurations
all right so this all look good what I
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin SVN email
notifications I don't want that what I
want the yes I want this SMTP server
configuration remember I mentioned
earlier that I would Bond Jenkins to be
sending out some emails and what I've
done here is I've just configured the
SMTP details of my personal email ID
in case you are in a in an organization
you would have some sort of an email IDs
that is set up for a Jenkins server so
you can specify the SMTP server details
of your company so that you know you can
authorize Jenkins to kind of send out
emails but in case you want to try it
out like me I have configured my
personal email ID which is on my Gmail
for sending out notifications so the
SMTP server would be
smtp.gmail.com I'm using the SMTP
authentication I have provided my email
ID and my password I'm using the SMTP
Port which is 465 and I'm you know reply
to address is the same as mine I can
just send out an email and see if at all
this configuration works again Gmail
would not allow you to allow anybody to
send out notifications on your behalf so
you'll have to lower the security level
of your Gmail ID so that you can allow a
programmatically somebody to send out
email notifications on your behalf so
I've done already that I'm just trying
to see if I can send a test in email
with the configuration that I've set in
yes
all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your you
know your Gmail account in case you want
to do that if not put in your
organization SMTP server details which
are for the valid username and password
and should all be set
all right so no other configurations
that I'm going to change here all of
these look good
all right so I come back to manage
inkins okay one other thing that I want
to kind of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine the scenario or look at it this
way Jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know what
kind of a code base it's going to pull
in what kind of a tool set that is
required or what is the code that is
going to pull in and how is it going to
build so you would have to put in all
the tools that is required for building
the appropriate kind of code that you're
going to pull in from you know your
source code repositories so just to give
an example in case your source code is a
Java source code and assuming that you
know because in this a demo this is my
laptop and I've put in all the
configurations jdk everything on my
laptop because I'm a developer I am
working on the laptop but my continuous
integration server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it so in case I want
Jenkins to you know run a Java code I
would need to install jdk on it I need
to specify the jdk location of this out
here this way
okay since I already have the jdk
installed and I've already put in the
Java home directory or rather the
environment variable correctly I don't
need to do it git if at all I want the
Jenkins server to use git git is a you
know command Dash or the command prompt
for for running git and connecting to
any other git server so you would need
git to be you know installed on that
particular system and set the path
accordingly
griddle and Maven if at all you have
some mavens as well you want to do this
any other tool that you're going to
install on your system which is your
continuous integration server you will
have to come in here and configure
something
in case you don't configure it when
chenkins runs you will not be able to
find these tools for building your task
and it'll about it
that's good I don't want to save
anything
managing games let me see what else is
required yes configure Global Security
all right the security is enabled and if
you see by default it's the security
access control is set to Jenkins own
user database so what does this mean you
know Jenkins by default it uses file
system where it stores all the usernames
which hashes up these usernames and kind
of stores them so as of now it Jenkins
is configured to use its own database
assuming that you are running in an
organization you would probably want to
have a you know some sort of an ad or an
ldap server using which you would want
to control access to your Jenkins
repository rather Jenkins tool so you
would specify your ldap server details
the root DN password or the manager DN
and the manager password and all these
details in case you want to connect your
Jenkins instance with your ldap or ad or
any of the authentication servers that
you have in your organization but for
now since I don't have any of these
things I'm going to use this own
database that's good enough
all right so I will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once I put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that Jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
ldap server or you can have Jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so I'm going to save
all this stuff that's good for me so
enough of all these configurations let
me put in a very very simple job
all right so job new item you know
little difficult to kind of figure out
but then that's the new item so I will
just say you know first job this is good
for me I just gave a name for my job I
would say it's a freestyle project
that's good enough for me I don't want
to choose any of that so unless until
you choose any of this this particular
button would not become active so choose
the freestyle project and say okay
at a very high level you would see
General source code management build
triggers build environment build and
post build in case you install more and
more plugins you will see a lot more
options but for now this is what you
would see so what am I doing at the
moment I'm just putting up a very very
simple job and the job could be anything
and everything so I don't want to put in
a very complicated job for now for the
demo purpose let me just put in a very
very simple job I'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first Jenkins job all right I don't want
to choose any of these again there are
some helps available here
I don't want to choose any of this I
don't want to connect it into any source
code for now I don't want any triggers
for now I'll come back to this in in a
while build environment I don't want any
build environment as a part of this
build step you know I just want to you
know run few things so that I kind of
complete this particular job so since
I'm on Windows box I would say execute
Windows batch command
all right so what do you want to do I
will let me just Echo something Echo
uh hello this is my first Jenkins job
and possibly I would want the date and
the timestamp
pertaining to the job I mean the date
and time in which this job was run all
right very very simple command that says
you know this is my first job it just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right I don't want to do anything
else I want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me save this job
all right so once I save this job you
know the job names comes up here and
then I need to build this job and you
would see some build history out here
nothing is there as of now because I've
just put in a job I have not run it yet
all right so let me try to build it now
you see a build number you will see a
date and a timestamp so if I click on
this you will see a console output if I
go here
okay as simple as that and where is all
the job details that is getting into if
you see this
if I navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
I was mentioning earlier regarding
Jenkins home so all the job related
stuff that is specific to this
particular Jenkins installation is all
here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here all right so the workspace is
where all the jobs that I've created
whichever I'm running would you know
there will be an individual folders
specific to the jobs that has been put
up here all right so one job one quick
run
that's what it looks like pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
I would say second job
I would say freestyle project
all right this is my second job
I just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on Jenkins
which will be triggered automatically
remember what I said earlier about
Jenkins because at the core of Jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server all right so what I'm going to do
I will just keep everything else the
same I'm going to put in the build
script pretty much similar to
second job
that gets triggered
automatically
every minute all right let me do that
percentage date and I'll put in the time
all right so I just put in another job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what I was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time I'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger so the build can
be triggered using various triggers that
is there so we'll get into this GitHub
uh triggering our hook or a web hook
kind of a triggering later on but for
now what I want to do I want to ensure
that this job that I'm going to put in
would be automatically triggered on its
own let's say every minute I want this
job to be run on its own
so build periodically is my setting
if you see here there's a bunch of
help that is available for me so for
those of you you have written cron jobs
on Linux boxes you'll find it very very
simple but for others don't panic let me
just put up a very very simple regular
expression for scheduling this job every
minute
all right so that's one two three four
five
all right come up come up come up all
right so five stars is all that I'm
gonna put in and Jenkins got a little
worried and she's asking me do you
really mean every minute oh yeah I want
to do this every minute let me save this
and how do I check whether it gets
triggered every minute or not I just
don't do anything I'll just wait for a
minute and if at all everything goes
well Jenkins would automatically trigger
my second job in a minute's time from
now
this time around I'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see it's
automatically got triggered
if I go in here
yep second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42 1642 which is 442 my time that
looks good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this job would be
automatically triggered
now that I have my Jenkins up and
running a few jobs that has been put up
here on my Jenkins instance I would need
a way of controlling access to my
Jenkins server this is wherein I would
use a plugin called role based access
plugin and create few rules the rules
are something like a global Rule and a
project role Project Specific role I can
have different rules and I can have
users who have signed up or the users
who might create kind of assigned to
these roles so that each of these users
fall into some category this is my way
of kind of controlling access to my
Jenkins instance and ensuring that
people don't do something unwarranted
alright so first things first let me go
ahead and install a plugin for doing
that so I get into many Jenkins and
manage plugin
a little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there's updates available
installed and advanced as of now we
don't have the role based plugin so let
me go to available it'll take some time
for you to get refreshed all right now
these are the available plugins these
are the install plugins all right so let
me come back to available and I would
want to search for my role based access
plugin so I would say search for role
and hit enter
okay role-based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using a
role-based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or notes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that I want I would want to
install it without a restart
all right looks good so far yes
go back to the top of the page yes
remember Jenkins is running on a Java
using a Java instance so typically many
things would work the same way
understand until you want to restart
Jenkins once in a while but as a good
practice whenever you do some sort of a
big installations or big patches on your
Jenkins instance just ensure that you
kind of restarted otherwise there would
be a difference in terms of what is
installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you will need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go ahead and
restart your Jenkins instance but for
now I don't need that it looks good I've
installed the plugin so where do you see
my plugin I install the plugin that is
specific to the user control or the
access control so let me go into yes
Global Security
and I would see this role-based strategy
showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role based plugin so
this is what I would want to enable
because I already have my own database
set up and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what I'm going
to install I mean I've already installed
a role based strategy plugin and I'm
going to enable that strategy all right
I would say save okay now I have
installed the role based access plugin I
would need to just set it up and check
that you know I would go ahead and
create some roles and ensure that I
assign users as per these roles all
right so let me go to
manage Jenkins
configure all right let me see where is
this configured configure Global
Security is that where I create my rules
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now I've just enabled the plugin I
have enabled role based access control
and I would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular Jenkins
instance so I would say first manage
rules
so I would need to create some rules
here and the rules are at a very high
level these are Global rules and there
are some project rules and there are
some slave rules I'll not get into
details of all of this at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a row a role can be kind of
visualized like a group so I would
create a role called developer typically
the Jenkins instance or the ca instance
are kind of owned up or controlled by QA
guys so QA guys would need to provide
some sort of a you know limited access
to developers so that's why I'm creating
a role called developer and I'm adding
this role at a global roll level so I
would say add this here and you would
see this developer role that is there
and each of these options if we hover
over it you would see some sort of a
help on what what are these uh you know
permissions specific to so what I want
is like you know it sounds a little you
know different but I would want to give
very very little permissions for the
developer so from an Administration
perspective I would just want him to
have a read
um kind of a role credentials again I
would just want to view kind of a role I
don't want him to create any agents and
all that stuff that looks good for me
for a job I would want him to just
possibly read I don't want him to build
I don't want him to cancel any jobs I
don't want him to configure any job I
don't even want him to create any job I
would just want him to read few things I
would not give him possibly a role to
the workspace as well I mean I don't
want him to have access to the workspace
I would just want him to read a job I'll
check you know have read only access to
the job run
um no I don't want him to give him any
any particular access which will allow
him to run any jobs view configure yeah
possibly create yeah delete I don't want
to read yes definitely and this is the
specific role so what I'm doing I'm just
creating a global role called developer
and I'm giving him very very limited
roles in the sense that I don't want
this developer to be able to run an
agents nor create jobs or build jobs or
cancel jobs or configure jobs at the max
I would just want him to read a job that
is already put up there
okay so I would save
now I've created a rule I still don't
have any users that is there on the
system so let me go ahead and create
some user on the system
that's not here I will say configure
manage and cans manage users
okay let me create a new user
I would call this user as yeah developer
one sounds good
some password
some password that I can remember
okay his name is developer1 D at d.com
or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which I kind of configured or brought up
the system and developer one is a user
that I have configured so still have not
set any rules for this particular user
yet so I would go to manage and gains
I would say
manage and assign roles I would say
assign roles
okay so if you see what I'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular deal I will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that I have already
configured
the role shows up here I would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular role so if
you remember the user that I created was
developer one I would add this
particular user and now this particular
user what kind of a role I want him to
have because this is the global rule
that had created so developer I would
assign this developer 1 to this
particular Global rule and I would go
ahead and save my changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges so there you
go I have Jenkins but I don't see a new
item I can't trigger a new job I can't
do anything I see these jobs however I
don't think so I'll be able to start
this job I don't have the permission set
for that the maximum I can do is look at
the job see what was there as a part of
the console output and stuff like that
so this is a limited role that was
created and I added this developer to
that particular role which was a
developer role so that the developers
don't get to configure any of the jobs
because the Jenkins instance is owned by
a cure person he doesn't want to give
developer any administrative rights so
the rights that he set out by creating a
developer role and anybody who is tagged
any user who is tagged as a part of this
developer role would get the same kind
of permissions and these permissions can
be you know fine-grained it can be a
Project Specific permissions as well but
for now I just demonstrated the high
level permission that had set in let me
quickly log out of this user and get
back as the admin user because I need to
continue with my demo with the developer
role that was created I have very very
less privileges one of the reasons for
Jenkins being so popular as I mentioned
earlier is the bunch of plugins that is
provided by users or Community users who
don't charge any money for these plugins
but it's got plugins for connecting
anything and everything so if you can
navigate to or if you can find Jenkins
plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect Jenkins to an AWS instance or
you want to connect Jenkins to a Docker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plugin you can go and
search up if I want to connect Jenkins
to big bucket
bitbucket is one of the git servers so
many plugins that is available okay so
bottom line Jenkins without plugins is
nothing so plugins is the heart of
Jenkins for you to connect or for in
order to connect Jenkins with any of the
containers or any of the other tool sets
you would need the plugins if you want
to connect or you want to build a
repository which has got Java and Maven
you would need to install Maven and jdk
on your Jenkins instance if at all
you're looking for a net build or
Microsoft build you would need to have
MS build installed on your on your
Jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger Ms build if at all you want
to listen to some server side web hooks
from GitHub you would need GitHub
specific plugins if you want to connect
Jenkins to AWS you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a Docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the URL which is
publicly reachable you just have a
Docker plugin that is installed on your
Jenkins instance sonar cube is one of
the popular static code analyzers so you
can connect a Jenkins build you can
build a job on Jenkins and push it to
sonar Cube and get sonar Cube to run
analysis on that and get back the
results in Jenkins all of these works
very well because of the plugins now
with that let me connect our Jenkins
instance to GitHub I already have very
very simple Java repository up on my
GitHub instance so let me connect
Jenkins to this particular GitHub
instance and pull out a job that is put
up there all right so this is my very
very simple uh you know repository that
is there called hello Java and this is
what is there in the report there is a
hello hello.java application that is
here or a simple class file that is
there it's got just one line of
system.out so this is already present on
github.com at this place and this would
be the URL for this Repository
if I pick up the https URL this is my
https URL so what I would do is I would
connect my Jenkins instance to go to
GitHub provide my credentials and pull
out this repository which is on the
cloud hosted github.com and get it to my
Jenkins instance and then build this
particular Java file I'm keeping the
source code very very simple it's just a
Java file how do I build my Java file
how do I compile my Java file I just say
Java C and the name of my class file
which is hello.java and how do I run my
Java file I would say Java and hello
okay so remember I don't need to install
any plugins now because uh what it needs
is a git plugin so if you remember when
we were doing the installation there was
a bunch of recommended plugins so git is
already installed on my system so I
don't need to install it again so let me
put up a new job here this is a git job
let it be a freestyle project that's
good for me I would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some Echo kind of jobs
we did not need any integration with any
of the source code systems so now let me
connect this so I'm going to put up a
source code and git would sure because
the plugin is already there SVN perforce
any of those additional source code
management tools if at all you would
need just install those plugins and
Jenkins connects wonderfully well to all
these particular Source control tools
okay so I would copy the https URL from
here I would say this is the URL that
I'm supposed to
go and grab my source code from but all
right that sounds good but what is the
username and password so I'll have to
specify a username
and password all right so I would say
the username this is my username and
this is my https credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password I just save this I say add
and then I would say you know use these
credentials to go to GitHub and then on
my behalf pull out a repository all
right if at all at this stage if there's
any error in terms of not able to
Jenkins not able to find git or the
git.exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that you know something
is not right you can just go ahead and
kind of fix that for now this looks good
for me I'm going to grab this URL what
am I going to do this step would pull
the source code from the GitHub and then
what would be there as a part of my
build step
because this repository just has a Java
file correct hello.java so in order to
for me to build this I would just say
execute Windows batch command and I
would say Java C
Hello dot Java that is the way I would
build my Java core and if I have to run
it I would just say Java
hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after the repository contents are
fetched from GitHub
Java that sounds good I would say save
this and let me try to run this
okay if you see there's a lot of you
know it executes git on your behalf it
goes out here it provides my credentials
and says you know it pulls all my
repository and by default it will pull
up the master branch that is there on my
repository and it kind of builds this
whole thing Java C hello to Java and it
runs this project Java hello and there
you see this is the output that is there
and if at all you want to look at the
contents of the repository if you can go
here this is my
workspace of my system hang on this is
not right
okay good job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there on my GitHub repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on the main GitHub repository all right
so this was the same program that was
here and Jenkins on our behalf went over
all the way to GitHub pulled this
repository from there and then you know
it brought it down to my local system on
my Jenkins instance it compiled it and
it ran this particular application
okay now that I've integrated Jenkins
successfully with GitHub for a simple
Java application let me build a little
bit on top of it what I will do is I
have a maven-based web application that
is up there as a repository in my GitHub
so this is the repository that I'm
talking about it's called AMV and web
app it's got It's a maven-based
repository as you would know Maven is a
very very simple Java based uh build
tool that will allow you to run various
targets and it'll compile it will based
upon the goals that you specify it can
compile it can run some tests and it can
you can build a war file and even deploy
it into some other server for now what
we're going to use Maven is just for
building and creating a package out of
this particular web application it
contains a bunch of things and what is
important is just the index.jsp it just
contains an HTML file that is there as a
part of this web application so from a
perspective of requirements now since
I'm going to connect Jenkins with this
particular repository git we already
have that set we only need two other
things one is Maven because Jenkins will
use Maven so in order to use Maven
Jenkins would have to have a maven
installation that is there on the
Jenkins box and in this case the Jenkins
box is this laptop
and after I have my Maven installed I
also need a tomcat server Tomcat is a
very very simple web server that you can
freely download I'll let you know how to
quickly download and install the Tomcat
alright so download Maven first
at the various ways in which you can
kind of download this mobile there is
zip files binary zip files and archive
files so what I've done is I've just
already downloaded Maven and if you see
I've unzipped it here so this is the
folder with which I have unzipped my
maven so as you know Maven again is is a
one open source build tool so you'll
have to set in a few configurations and
set up the path so mvn hyphen iPhone
version if I specify this after I set in
my path memory should work and if at all
I Echo M2 home which is nothing but the
variable environment variable specific
to my one node it is already set here so
once you unzip my oven just set this M2
home variable to the directory where you
unzipped your Maven also just set the
path to this particular directory slash
bin because that is where your Maven
executables are all found
all right so that's with Maven and you
know since I've set the path and the
environment variable mav1 is running
perfectly fine on my system I've just
verified it okay next one is the Tomcat
server
download Apache Tomcat server 8.5 is
what I have on my system so I'm just
gonna show you where to download this
from
this way you download Tomcat server and
I already have the server downloaded
again this doesn't need any installation
I just unzip it here and it kind of has
a bin and configuration I have made some
subtle changes in the configuration
first and foremost Tomcat server also by
default runs on port 8080 since we
already have our Jenkins server running
on port 8080 we cannot let Tomcat run on
the same port there will be a port Clash
so what I've done I have configured
Tomcat to use a different port so if I
go to this configuration file here there
is a server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 80 80. I have just
modified it to 8081 so I've changed the
port on which my Tomcat server would run
all right so that's one chain second
change when Jenkins kind of tries to get
into my tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be allowed
deployment by Tomcat so for that I need
to create a user on tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my Jenkins
instance
so I would go to
tomcatusers.xml file here
I have already created our username
called deployer and the password is
deployer and I've added a role called
manager hyphen script manager hyphen
script will allow programmatic access to
the Tomcat server so this is the role
that is there so using this credentials
I will enable or I'll Empower Jenkins to
get into my Tomcat server and deploy my
application all right only these two
things that is required let me just
start my Tomcat server first so I get
into my bin folder I open a command
prompt here and there's a startup.bat
it's pretty fast it just takes a few
seconds yes there you go don't get
service up and running now this is
running on Port 8081 so let me just
check if that looks good
so localhost
okay my Tomcat server is up and running
that sounds good the user is already
configured on this that's also fine so
what I'll do as a part of my first job
my one is also installed on my system so
I'm good to use Maven as a part of my
Jenkins so I will put up a simple job
now
I will say job
NBN
web app I call this
freestyle job that's good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the URL of my git repository is
uh this guy https URL
okay
because this URL I will use the
credentials the old credential that I
set up will work well because it's the
same git user that I'm kind of
connecting into
all right so now the change happens here
where after I get this since I said this
is a simple Maven repository I will have
some Maven targets to run
so the simple Target first is let me run
Maven package this creates a war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever I
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package so this is all that is
required maybe let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see if it
connects well if there's any problem
with my War file or the war file gets
created properly
okay
wonderful so it built a war file and if
you see it all shows you
what is the location where this war file
was generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this Warfare was successfully built
now I need to grab this particular War
file and then I would need to deploy it
into Tomcat server again I would need a
small plugin to do this because I need
to connect Tomcat with my Jenkins server
let me go ahead and install the plugin
for the container deployment so I would
go to manage plugins
available
type in container
container container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that I would need I
would install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the Target folder
I would say this web application War
file that is already built so I would
need to configure this plugin to pull up
this war file and deploy it onto the
Tomcat server for deploying onto the
Tomcat server I will use the credentials
of the user that I've created okay so
let me go to configure this particular
project again
and um
okay all this is good
so the package is good I'm going to just
create a package that's all fine now
add a post build step so after the war
file is built as a part of this package
directive let me use this deployment to
container now this will show up after
you install the plugin so deploy this
one to the container now what is that
you're supposed to specify you're
supposed to specify the what is the
location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that will
allow you to
from the root folder it will pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot War that's good
for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the Tomcat server
I will just say mvn web app
that's the name of my thing now I need
to specify what kind of a container that
I'm talking about all right so the
deployment would be for
the stormcat 8.5 is what I need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that I have so this
would be the URL so the credentials yes
I need to add a credential for this
particular server so if you remember I
had created a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that
my Tomcat server yes configuration of
this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployed okay so
let me use that credential
I would say I would say add a new
credential Jenkins credential the
username is deployer and the password is
replyer
so I would use this deployer credentials
for that and what is the URL of my
Tomcat instance so this is the URL of my
Tomcat instance
so take the war file that is fine found
in this particular folder and then you
know context path is same in web app use
the deployer deployment credentials and
get into this localhost which is there
8081 this is the Tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it
okay so that is all that is required so
I would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it built successfully built the war
file it is trying to deploy it and looks
like a deployment went ahead perfectly
well
so
the context path was mvn web app so if I
type in this
all right if at all I go ahead into my
Tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder you would see the
you know the date time stamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the Explorer version of our
application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the GitHub server it was built locally
on the Jenkins instance test and then it
was pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1 now for this demo I am running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
Tomcat instance was running on some
other server with some other different
IP address all that you got to go and
change is the URL of the server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that uh you know if you
have a tomcat server which is running on
some other machine that's all fine with
a different type that's all good enough
the whole bundle or the war file that
was built as a part of this Jenkins job
gets transferred onto the other server
and gets deployed that's the beauty of
Jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using Jenkins and my
own distributed build or Master Slave
configuration in Jenkins as you would
have seen you know we just have one
instance of Jenkins server up and
running all the time and also I told you
that whenever any job that kind of you
know gets started on the Jenkins server
it is little heavy on in terms of disk
space and the CPU utilization so which
kind of you know if at all you're in an
organization wherein you are heavily
reliant on the Jenkins server you don't
want your Jenkins server to go down so
that's wherein you kind of start
Distributing the load that is there on
the Jenkins server so you primarily have
a server which is just a placeholder or
like a master who will take in all the
kind of jobs and what he'll do is based
upon trigger that has happened to the
job or whichever job needs to be built
if at all he can delegate these jobs
onto some of the machines or some other
sleeves you know that's a wonderful
thing to have okay use case one use case
two assuming that you know if you have a
Jenkins server that is running on a
Windows box or on a Linux one and if at
all you have a need where you need to
build based upon operating systems you
have multiple build configurations to
support maybe you need to build a
Windows uh you know Windows based.net
kind of a projects where you would need
a Windows machine to build this
particular project you also have a
requirement where you want to build
Linux Linux based systems you also have
a Mac you you support some sort of an
apps or something that is built on Mac
OS you would need to build you know Mac
based system as well so how are you
going to support all these needs so
that's wherein a beautiful concept of
Master Slave or you know primary and
delegations or agent and master comes
into play so typically you would have
one Jenkins server who will just you
know configure with all the proper
authorizations users configurations and
everything is set up on this Jenkins
server his job is just delegations he
will listen to some server triggers or
based upon the job that is coming in he
will if there's a way nice way of
delegating these jobs to somebody else
and you know taking back the results he
can control lot of other systems and
these systems may not have a complete or
there's no need to put in a complete
Jenkins installation all that he got to
do is have a very very simple Runner or
sleeve that's a simple jar file that is
run as a low priority thread or a
process Within These systems so with
that you can have a wonderful
distributed build server that can be set
up and in case one of the servers goes
down your master would know that what
went down and kind of delegate the task
to somebody else so this is the kind of
distributed build or the Master Slave
configuration so what I'll do in this
exercise or in this demo is I'll set up
a simple slave but since I don't have
too many machines to kind of play around
what I'll do is I will set up a slave in
in one other folder within my hard drive
so I've got the C drive and D drive my
Jenkins is on my C drive so what I do is
I would just use my e Drive and set up a
very very simple slave out there I'll
just show you how to provision a slave
and how to connect to a slave and how to
delegate a job to that slave let me go
back to my Jenkins master and configure
him to you know talk to an agent so
there are various ways in which this
client and server talk to each other
what I'm going to choose is something
called as gnlp Java Network launch
protocol so using this I would ensure
that you know the client and server talk
to each other so for that I need to
ensure that I kind of enable this jnlp
port so let me try to find out where is
that let me try this
okay yes
agents and by default this jnlp agents
thing would be disabled so if you see
here there's a small help on this
so I'm going to use this jnlp which is
nothing but Java Network launch protocol
and you know I'll configure the master
and server to talk to each other using
jnlp so for that I need to enable this
guy so I enable this guy instead of
making the default the configuration was
disabled so I make him random I make him
you know enabled and I say save this
configuration
all right so now configured always made
a setting for the master so that the
jnlp port is kind of opened up so let me
go ahead and you know create an agent
so I've got to manage nodes so if you
see here there's only one master here so
let me provision a new node here so this
is the way you know in which you bring
up a new node you have to configure it
on the server uh Jenkins would put in
some sort of security around this
particular agent and let you know how to
launch this particular engine so that he
can connect to a Jenkins master so I
would say new node I would give a name
for my node I would say windows node
because both of these are windows only
so that's fine I'll just give an
identifier saying that Windows node I
would say this is a permanent agent I
would say okay so if you see the name
let me just copy this name here with the
description
number of executors since it's a slave
node and both of these are running on my
system I'll keep the number of executors
as one
that's fine remote root directory now
this is where let me just clarify this
since I have both my
my master is running on my C drive C
drive program files 86 or hang on not
86.
C colon program files
it is indeed 86.
all right Jenkins so this is where my
master is running so I don't want the C
drive what I'll do is I'll use something
called as a drive I have another Drive
in my system but please visualize this
like you know you're running this on a
separate system altogether so I create a
folder here called Jenkins node and this
is where I'm going to place my or I'm
going to provision my slave and I'm
going to run him from here so this is
the directory in which I am going to
provision my slave node so I'm going to
copy this here and that is the remote
root directory of your particular agent
or sleep so I just copy it here the
label you know probably this is fine for
me
and usage how do you want to use this
guy
so I would don't want him to run all
kinds of jobs I will only build jobs
with label Expressions that match this
particular node and so this is the label
of this node so in order for somebody to
kind of delegate any task to them they
allowed to specify this particular label
so imagine this way if I have a bunch of
Windows system I name it as Windows star
anything that says from Windows I can
give a regular expression and say that
anything that matches Windows run this
particular task there if I have some MAC
machines I name all these Mac agents as
Mac star or something like that and I
can delegate all tasks you know saying
that start with whatever starts with Mac
in this node run the Mac jobs there
so you identify a node using the label
and then delegate the task there all
right so launch method you know we will
use Java web star because we got to
we we're going to use jnlp protocol okay
that sounds good directory I think
nothing else is required availability
yes we'll keep this agent yeah online as
much as possible that sounds good all
right let me save this
all right I'm just provisioning this
particular node now
so if I click on this node I get a bunch
of commands along with an agent.jar
so this is the agent.jar that has to be
taken down to the other machine or the
slave node and from there I need to run
this along with a small security
credential so let me copy this whole
text here in my notepad
notepad plus plus is good for me
okay I copy this whole
but there I also want to download this
alien.jar I would say yes
this agent.jar is the one that is
configured by a server so all the
details that is required for launching
this agent.jar is found in this uh sorry
for launching this agent is found this
agent.jar so typically I need to take
this jar file onto the other system
and then kind of run it from there so
I have this 800.jar I copy this or do I
cut this I come back to my folder my
Jenkins node I paste it here
okay so now with this provision
agent.jar and I need to use this whole
command Ctrl a control C and then launch
this particular agent so let me bring up
a command prompt right here and then
launched it so I'm saying in the same
folder where there is agent.jar I'm
going to launch this a particular agent
Java hyphen jar agent.jar jnlp this is
the URL of my server in case the server
and client are on different locations or
different IPS you have to specify the IP
address all this anyway would show up
and then the secret and you know the
root folder of your Jenkins or the slave
node
okay
so
something ran and then you know it says
it's connected very well it seems to
Connected very well so let me come back
to my Jenkins instance and see you know
if at all you see earlier this was not
connected alone Let me refresh this guy
okay now these two guys are connected
provision a Jenkins node and then I
copied all the credentials of the slave
dot jar along with the launch code and
then took it to the other system and
kind of ran it from there since I don't
have another system I've just got a
separate directory in another folder
another drive and I'm launching the
agent from here as long as this
particular agent is up and running or
this command prompt is up and running
the agent would be connected so once I
close this the connection goes down all
right so successfully we've launched
this particular agent now this would be
the home directory of this Jenkins node
or the Jenkins slave so any task that
I'm going to delegate to this particular
slave would all be run here it will
create a workspace right here all right
so good so let me just come back and let
me kind of put up a new task here I will
say that you know delegate job is good I
say freestyle project I'm going to
create a very very simple job here
I don't want it to connect to gate or
anything like that let me just create a
very very simple
Echo
relegate to the
slave negative two I don't like the word
slave delegated to
agent
put this way
all right so delegated to agent sounds
good now how am I going to ensure that
this particular job runs on the agent or
on the slave that I've configured
right you see this if at all you
remember how we provisioned our
particular slave we give a label right
so now I'm going to put in a job that
will only match this particular label
so I'm going to say that whatever
matches this you know Windows label run
this job on that particular node so we
have only one node that's matching this
in a Windows node so this job will be
delegated around there so I save this
and let me build this
this is again a very very simple job
there's nothing in this I just want to
demonstrate how to kind of delegate it
to an agent so if you see this it runs
successfully and uh where is the
workspace the workspace is right inside
our Jenkins node it created a new
workspace delegate a job it put in here
so my old or the my primary Master job
is in SQL program files under Jenkins
and this is the slave job that was
successfully run very very simple but
very very powerful concept of Master
Slave configuration or distributed
built-in Jenkins
okay approaching the final section where
we've done all this hard work in
bringing up our Jenkins server
configuring it putting up some jobs on
it creating users and all this stuff now
we don't want this configuration to kind
of go away we want a very nice way of
ensuring that we backup all this
configuration and in case there is any
failure Hardware crash or a machine
crash we would want to kind of restore
from the existing configuration that we
kind of backed up so one quick way to do
that would be or one dirty way to do
that would be just you know take a
complete backup of a colon program files
colon Jenkins directory because that's
where our whole Jenkins configuration is
present but we would don't want to do
that let's use some plugins for taking
up a backup so let me go to manage and
cans
and click on available
and let me search for some back there
are a bunch of backup plugins so I would
recommend one of these plugins that I
specifically use also this is the backup
plugin so let me go ahead and install
this plugin
all right so we went ahead and installed
this plugin so let me come back to my
manage plugins so this plugin is there
so hang on Backup Manager so you will
see this option once you install this
plugin so first time I can you know do a
setup I would say back up this
particular I'll give a folder uh this
folder is pertaining to the folder where
I want to check against backup some data
and I would say the format should be zip
format is good enough let me give a name
or a template or a file name for my you
know backup this is good I want it in
verbose mode I don't want to shut on my
Jenkins or should I shut it down no okay
one thing that you got to remember is
that whenever a backup happens there are
too many jobs that is running on the
server it can kind of slow down your
Jenkins instance because it's it's in
the process of copying few of those
things and the files are being changed
at that moment instead a bit problematic
for Jenkins so typically you backup your
servers only when there is very less
load or typically you try to you know
bring it to a shutdown kind of a state
and then take a backup
all right so I'm going to back up all
these things you know I don't want to
exclude anything else I want the history
I want the manual artifacts possibly
don't want this guy I would just say
save
and then I would say back him up
so this would run a bunch of you know
steps and all the files that is required
as a part of this is pretty fast but
then if at all you have too many things
up on your server for now we didn't have
too many things up on our server but in
case you had too many things to kind of
backup this may take a while so let me
just pause this recording and get back
to you once the backup is complete so
there you go the backup was successful
created a backup of all the workspace
the configurations the users and you
know all that so all this is kind of
hidden down in this particular zip file
so at any instance if at all I kind of
Crash my system for some instance or say
hard disk failure and I bring up a new
instance of Jenkins I can kind of use
the backup plugin for restoring this
particular configurations so how do I do
that I just come back to my managing
cans
come back to backup manager and
obviously restore her it's an or Jenkins
configuration welcome everyone to
another tutorial on selenium Webdriver
in which we are going to talk about what
exactly is in selenium and why exactly
we are going to use this selenium web
driver here now uh in this one there are
different topics which we are going to
talk about let's go through that one
first we're going to talk about what
exactly is selenium all about because
that's a basic topic which we need to
cover then we will be talking about what
is the purpose of uh using selenium
Webdriver in which which situations we
can actually use the selenium web driver
here and then we are going to talk about
the selenium Webdriver framework the
framework which is specifically designed
for the selenium web driver the various
drawbacks of the selenium trade driver
and ultimately at the last we will be
talking about a demonstration over here
which is all about the selenium web
driver like how exactly we can make use
of a Webdriver muscle linear web driver
in action which can help us to go for
some real-time executions of certain
some test scenarios uh opening up some
website or doing some execution so all
that stuff is what we are going to talk
about in this whole tutorial over here
now coming back to the main topic so
let's start with the what exactly is a
selenium here
now software automation uh is something
which is a kind of uh minimum
requirement every organization is having
nowadays because they were doing a lot
of stuff manually in the previous
situations and it was consuming a lot of
time but until then we were not having
the Frameworks like selenium which was
giving the users or the the automations
Engineers a whole total a different
exposure there now testing is always an
important part of a software development
here it's it's something which gives a
very a high level of value add-ons to
overall exposure or the overall sdlc
cycle here without the software testing
it's not possible for an organization to
release its source code till production
environment and it makes sense also
because the testing is very important
even nowadays if we have to procure a
new car or a vehicle we basically go for
a test drive now this is something which
we are using because of the fact that
you know we want to experience the
exposure there like how in real time we
can see the vehicle in action whether
all my requirements is getting fulfilled
or not so you have your own parameters
everyone have its own parameters so you
just want to address those parameters
and want to see that if this product is
something which can take care of all
your requirements or not so that's
something keeping in mind software
testing is very important
and whether it's a manual whether it's
an automat testing in both the cases
it's very important for the software yes
over the period of time the organization
felt that manual testing is actually uh
is not efficient as compared to the
automation testing secondly it takes a
lot of time of the end users to do that
uh different processing and you know any
kind of uh you know test scenarios if he
wants to execute he wants to go ahead
with that so that's something which
takes a lot of time but in case of the
automation test cases we have a lot of
Frameworks which can help us to drive
like how the implementation should be
done so keeping in mind selenium is one
of the tool which is available there and
the whole focus of selenium is to
provide a framework or provide an
automation which can generate a quite
efficient results for you and results
these results which we are talking about
these results are something which we are
talking about like how exactly we are
getting the high level of efficiency so
when we are talking about selenium so it
gives us a lot of benefits and a lot of
exposure so um you talking about the
websites when we talk about websites we
deal like okay
um you know if I have to validate my
website I have to do the login I have to
access the application so that's how I
will be doing the verification but with
the help of selenium kind of Frameworks
we don't have to do these things
manually anymore we have this automation
tool which can help us to drive the
things it will automatically open the
browser go to the specific website put
some inputs clicking on some buttons
generating the responses and taking up
the actions so ultimately it will help
you to drive each and everything from
the beginning to the end most of the
organizations after the deployment
actually have written the test cases
like the sanity testing and the smoke
testing in case of the selenium like a
particular selenium test cases will be
executing it will try to validate it if
the application is working fine as
expected or not just try to you know
have a kind of a brief uh overview or
you can say like introduction here like
this so and so steps you have to execute
this one so a procedure you have to
execute to follow a complete procedure
or complete automation here so keeping
in mind selenium is one of the open
source tool which is available there for
this purpose of writing the test cases
test automation there any kind of web
portal can be easily verified and tested
along with the help of selenium
it's something uh which can be uh
created like the test scripts can be
easily created across different
programming languages it's not like
since uh selenium is written in the Java
programming language so you can only uh
use this one for the Java programming
language it's not like that it's pretty
generic which means like any programming
languages if you feel you want to use
you can use a selenium for that so it's
having the compatibility with the Java C
sharp python a variety of applications
uh programming languages can be used
with the help of selenium so it doesn't
mean like uh you are only stuck with one
language so uh it helps you to gain the
benefits also because once you are
comfortable selenium then pretty much
any programming languages you can
automate and if you see like most of the
automation Engineers are actually having
the understanding of selenium only
because this gives them the comfort that
with this one single programming
language they will be able to handle
like all the different programming
languages uh related work whether it's a
C sharp whether it's a dotnet it's a
Java a node.js or any kind of
programming languages there so selenium
is having the Comfort or is having the
compatibility with that also uh in case
of selenium it's not only about one test
cases we can pretty much create test
suits like heavy test suits uh you can
create the regression test suits you can
create the u80 test Source you can
create this sanity testing or the smoke
testing kind of test suits so there are
different kind of test suits which you
can create here now these test suits
actually have a bunch of test cases
integrated like it's not only about one
test case or it's not only about two
test cases it's kind of a bunch of test
cases which we are trying to create with
the help of selenium so selenium is
something in which we basically create a
multiple uh test cases It's a
combination of multiple test cases all
together into a single one so that's
what we call it as a kind of selenium
test suit here right now the selenium
test suit is comprising of four
different tools here the very first one
is the selenium remote control second
one is the selenium grid then we got
selenium IDE and ultimately last we have
the selenium web driver so these are the
four different tools which we got over
here with the moment we talk about the
selenium suit here
now let's talk about this selenium web
driver because that's the whole focus of
this uh content over here to see like
what exactly is the selenium web driver
and how we can go ahead with that
so coming back to the selenium Webdriver
so here a selenium Webdriver is one of
the most important component of this
alignment test suit when we talk about
the selenium tools suit over here like
we talk about okay I want to create a
hole together regression test suit so
selenium Webdriver is very important
component for that and when we talk
about uh the selenium web driver it
allows the cross browser compatibility
which means like you want to test your
applications you can have a test suit
there one for the Chrome browser one for
the Firefox one for the Internet
Explorer you can then say like okay I
want to test and validate my application
across all these three browsers and in
future if Safari browser comes in all
you have to do is like you have to just
run the same script with the web driver
of the Safari so this web driver is not
only static for One browser it's a
actually approachable for across
multiple browsers there so that enhances
the compatibility there that yes this
set test suit even if you're writing the
test suits in case of selenium it's not
limited to 1 browser so it's kind of a
cross browser here so these are small
small benefits although we are talking
about the selenium web driver here but
if you closely see these all points are
actually defining why exactly the
selenium is best when we talk about the
web automations or the web testing
automation here right
and then it's actually supporting
various programming languages like a
programming languages yes it's there
it's even supporting different browsers
and then of course it's supporting
different operating systems also because
you can pretty much run these test cases
uh onto Linux Macs or Windows whatever
platform you feel like you want to use
you can pretty much use it so you don't
have to worry about like where exactly
this web driver is getting deployed and
from where you are trying to refer it so
that kind of compatibility is also
something which is available here so you
don't have to think about the uh
specific different uh versions or the
different operating systems as such over
here and then let's talk about further
on this one so it also provides the
compatibility across different
programming languages so you can see
like what are the different benefits you
got you got benefits like uh you know
it's it's supporting different
programming languages it's supporting
different browsers and ultimately it
lost it's supporting the different uh
particular uh operating systems or the
platforms here so these are small small
things like different uh benefits which
we get with the help of selenium here
and uh it's it's having the support
across different programming languages
so it doesn't matter that if you're
working with Java or if you're working
with dotnet this is going to work for
across a different different platforms
like different uh environments you can
actually deploy so these benefits are
something which can definitely help you
to see like how the overall uh benefits
can be achieved over here and uh
definitely the Chrome browsers are the
Safari the Firefox the Oprah different
uh platforms you will be able to see
like how the execution needs to be done
and how the setup used to be performed
here so that's where the complete uh
implementations uh needs to be performed
here right and uh these web driver
provides a faster execution of the test
scripts because that's uh the kind of
automation which we are looking forward
that we are not trying to see like how
the systems can be implemented so when
we are trying to talk about the
automation here so these web drivers
basically help us to go for the faster
execution also so it's not only about
that we are trying to see the setup like
we are trying to go for the
configurations here it's also like uh
the performance and the efficiency which
we're getting with this one is quite
beneficial so you can uh get an easy and
a faster execution of the test cases so
it's it's having a lot of benefits if we
talk about in these features only itself
you can see like there are a lot of
benefits which we got over here so it's
fast it's efficient and on top of that
it's not depending on any kind of
environment it's quite generic like you
know it's it's something which you can
use for Windows you can use it for Linux
you want to use it for net you want to
use it for Java it's kind of uh Chun
trick for a lot of Technologies
platforms and programming languages
right now why exactly we require the
selenium web driver like what is the
purpose of using this one so let's
explore on that part here so selenium
Webdriver provides a user-friendly
interface that could uh you know it can
be easily understood by a particular
person like when we uh when you are
using this uh selenium web driver so
this is something which you can easily
understood like uh it's pretty easy for
you to understand that and it's not that
much complex for you to understand that
okay you are going to take a lot of time
to consume you're going to take a lot of
time to uh you know understand that so
that's not a kind of interface which we
are getting when we talk of the uh
selenium web driver here right and the
web driver is something which is having
uh much more uh features as compared to
the uh selenium RC and selenium IDE
there so when we talk about the uh
selenium web driver so this is something
which is having uh much more features as
compared to the other components like
you know these the other components is
also about the selenium only but yes the
when we talk about selenium uh web
driver so it's having much more features
as compared to the selenium RC and the
selenium ID here
so you don't have to worry about the
features like all together selenium uh
pep driver is something which is quite
efficient and better as compared to the
other components so that's another
benefit which we get with the selenium
here
so selenium uh we have got some other
components like a selenium remote
control here so uh RC is something which
enables the uh the creation of uh you
know automated web applications like uh
in in case of programming languages such
as Java c-sharp uh node.js different
different programming languages are
there so we can pretty much uh use the
remote control uh the selenium remote
control over here which will enable the
uh the creation of the automated web
applications there so that's the purpose
of using the selenium remote control
here it's uh it's not something which is
being used nowadays because most of the
functionalities have nowadays moved on
to the uh selenium web driver here so
that's some migration which has happened
over there and that's the reason why we
are not going to use much of the
selenium remote control over here so
that's not being used as such as
compared to the other components but yes
the selenium Webdriver is something
which is quite popular and because of
its features and the efficiency we are
going to use uh the particular uh browse
the web driver as compared to the any
other component as such here right now
selenium IDE
needs not additional any kind of setup
is required like uh you know apart from
installation of the browser because uh
in that case everything will be
integrated in that like because we are
using we are integrating the complete uh
selenium IDE over here so all you need
to do is like you need to do the
installation of Chrome browser that's
also because you want to go for the uh
specific Chrome driver which you require
for the execution of the test cases so
for that only you are basically trying
to install the Chrome browser but other
than that there is no other component
which you actually require when we talk
about the selenium IDE am
so uh the IDE makes the life easy
because it helps us to go ahead with the
debugging mode here like a kind of a
debugging environment you will be able
to do that so even if there is any kind
of issue any any kind of problem which
comes up so it will be very easy for you
to debug those things and go ahead with
that part so uh tracking the exceptions
managing the exception so all those
things can be easily handled up with the
help of the selenium IDE here so
selenium IDE is something which is kind
of a bigger package which is uh further
comprising of different different
components like it's something which is
giving us a variety of things here right
now how exactly the uh selenium web
driver is at all different from the the
selenium rzn IDE because those are also
the solution which is available there
from this Lane now unlike the selenium
IDE selenium Webdriver can actually work
with different browsers so that's
something which we have already focused
on that it's having the compatibility
across multiple uh browsers there that's
the first benefit which we get over here
in this one now also the web drivers is
something which does not require any
user to start the server or anything
like that there so just in case of a
selenium RC you have to start some
server because you're ultimately
connecting to that server and that's how
the communication is happening but that
kind of stuff is not there in the uh
selenium web driver here
also this Lenovo Webdriver is an API and
it's not a GUI based plugin so uh it's
it's something which can easily handle
like uh it's having the uh quite
efficient uh connectivity or you can say
like the integration is also good there
because we most of the application
nowadays are working on the API format
which is pretty generic so with there is
no GUI based interface which we have to
explore or which we need to integrate
here so it's all like other apis call
which we need to do in order to use uh
make use of the selenium web driver here
now in selenium Webdriver the apis are
entirely object oriented in nature as
compared to the selenium RC and selenium
ID so which is not a kind of object
oriented in nature but selenium
Webdriver is something which is quite
object oriented here also uh web driver
the selenium web driver is actually uh
supports multiple
listeners right so uh which is available
there as compared to selenium RC and
selenium ID here so these are some
couple of features which is available
there also it also supports the testing
of the IOS and Android which is not
being supported in the RCN IDE there
because most of the applications are
nowadays also have the counterpart
Android or the iOS applications so if
you don't have the interface or
integration with those platforms then
it's a incomplete way of testing here so
not only the web applications but even
the mobile applications also now getting
integrated with the help of the selenium
Webdriver here so these kind of features
which is not exactly available in the RC
or the ID over here but definitely it's
it's going to be available there in case
of selenium web driver so what exactly
is the overall need of the web driver
like the selenium Webdriver here so uh
let's talk about that that uh how
exactly we can use it for the software
automation here so there are a couple of
benefits which is available there so
let's focus on that one by one the very
first one is the open source now it's
something which is available or which is
available as an open source over here
which means like it's something which
you can use without any license without
any cost uh just like that you can go to
the selenium.dev website and you can
start downloading the selenium related
uh details also limited components
second is multilingular support it's
having the support for different kind of
programming languages not only for the
Java based applications it's actually
supporting like different different
programming languages so you just have
to learn one single tool and then can
serve eyes or that can support multiple
programming languages here several
operating system support yes it's not
only related to the windows or Linux
platform here so it's actually supported
across uh Windows Linux Mac OS different
operating systems are actually supported
here so different operating systems is
supported by this particular selenium
here multiple Frameworks are there so
that's a multiple framework support
which is available in this one uh user
friendly it's quite user friendly there
and the developers were more comfortable
with the Java programming languages so
they get a quite a comfortable and
integrated with the selenium because
it's also using the same Java syntax
over here in this one it's cross device
testing uh definitely both mobile
desktops are different platforms
different operating systems Mac OS iOS
Android different uh platforms are
actually supported by this uh particular
selenium here so selenium Webdriver is
something which is having like cross
device testing here
Community Support is there it's kind of
Open Source yes but uh it's having a
very good Community like a lot of people
are actually there who can contribute to
this selenium you can get the
information from there and it's kind of
a huge efforts like a kind of a huge
Community efforts which you can see over
here in this case also uh compatibility
testing so it's having a very good
compatibility here so uh when you're
working with this uh selenium so it's
compatible with pretty much any
programming languages any platform any
operating system so that kind of
benefits you get with the help of this
selenium web driver here
and uh unlike uh selenium RC you don't
have to start any kind of server
component here uh which you need to
connect so it's like uh on demand like
when you're running the scripts uh kind
of a local Chrome browser will be uh
initialized
and your test cases will be executed and
uh performed and that that's how the
whole executions will be performed there
so there is no involved like you have to
go somewhere start some server start
some remote server there and then the
communication or the execution of the
test cases will be initialized so it's
not like that kind of communication here
right so let's talk about the uh web
driver architecture here now in this one
there are some different uh components
which is available there in this
architecture components the very first
one is the selenium language bindings
here now these are actually available in
different different programming
languages like Java Ruby python c-sharp
JavaScript these are the different
programming languages bindings which is
available there then with the help of
Json wire protocol these are going to be
connected to the different drivers Now
browser drivers is the one where exactly
the request will be sent out so this
selenium Webdriver is actually going to
connect or send the request to this
drivers so uh depending on the platform
also and depending on the different uh
systems you can actually go for the
browser drivers here so you want to go
for Chrome driver you want to go for
Firefox you want to go for Opera you
want to go for Safari Edge these are the
different browsers which is available
there earlier the Internet Explorer was
also there but now in the latest version
say it uh each browser or each driver is
something which is available there and
these are going to be connected through
the actual uh particular browsers like
the Chrome Firefox and also it will be
sending the request over the HTTP the
HTTP that request will be sent out to
the real drivers so the browser drivers
and then the real drivers will be there
so the web driver is going to connect to
the Chrome driver and then in fact from
there the Chrome driver is going to
initialize the Chrome browser and then
the whole request will be processed
there our websites will be open the
clicking the access everything will be
done after that on that case so these
are the different uh
steps which is involved when we are
basically going for uh from one step to
another like where the communications
will be performed over here in this case
right so uh again uh it's not dependent
on any programming languages it's not
dependent on any kind of uh browser or
any kind of components here so right
from the uh language bindings it will go
to the Json wire protocol from there it
will be sent out to the browser drivers
various browser drivers whatever the
browser drivers you want to use you can
use that and then those drivers are
actually going to connect with the real
drivers or with the real browsers over
here so that the communications or the
exact end result you should be able to
see so
for instance if you run a particular
Chrome browser a chrome driver there so
you will be able to see like a Chrome
browser getting initialized and the
website is getting accessible so all
that activity will be open or will be
performed over there so these are the
parts of the sequence these are kind of
architecture components like one to
another these will be processed or these
will be executed here right so uh these
programming language these selenium
programming languages again it's
actually a kind of a generic one so
these are the client libraries which is
available there depending on this one
for example for Java I can download some
binaries I can download some jar files
so that will be reference or utilized
into my source code for Ruby it's maybe
like different uh third-party libraries
or shared libraries which will be
available there for python it will be
available in the form of modules uh
c-sharp JavaScript so each and every
programming languages is actually having
its own uh
libraries now these libraries are
actually required so that we can get the
whole interface of the selenium it's
okay like I am writing some test cases
I'm writing the complete test suit and
I'm using it but unless and until I
import my uh selenium libraries it will
not work for me I will not be able to
work on that part because I will not be
able to get those features as such in
order to get those features I need to
download these bindings or these kind of
language bindings there corresponding to
my programming language and these are
easily available on the selenium website
so if you go to the selenium website
whatever the programming languages you
want to follow you can download these
findings these windings will be nothing
but the archives where you will be
having some kind of executables
depending on that programming language
right now from there uh we will be using
our libraries like these bindings in
order to interact in order to initialize
the selenium so then we will be going to
the Json wire protocol so it's kind of a
connector between the libraries and the
web drivers now uh programmingly uh
using these uh with the help of these uh
client libraries we're going to send the
request to the web drivers it also helps
to enable the transfer of data between a
server and client because of course uh
you have to get your end result process
right so that's where you need to go for
the execution so what you're going to do
is like you're going to see like okay I
am going to run or I'm going to execute
this uh Json wire protocol over here and
it's going to connect between my client
libraries and the web drivers here so
that's the communications and the
connectivity which we want to establish
or we want to provide here now these are
selenium browser drivers are actually uh
specific browsers now because the Json
wire is going to connect uh to the
specific
browsers uh the drivers here so that the
communication can be happen now uh these
drivers are actually used uh as in
drivers in order to interact with the
exact browser because these are not the
exact browser now if you want to
interact with the Chrome then you
definitely have to use the Chrome driver
if you want to use for the Firebox then
you have to use the Firefox driver so
depending on the programming language
you have to Define like which driver you
really need to process or you need to
really go ahead with that part so that's
where the selenium browser drivers
really comes into the picture and then
uh the exact browsers will be there now
once the executions will be done at last
you will be able to see like all these
browsers getting open if you're going to
use the Chrome browser then Chrome
browser will be initialized if you're
using the Firefox then the Firefox
browser will be initialized so whatever
the browser driver specific driver you
will utilize eyes so according to that
you will see a particular browser being
invoked over here so that's how the
communication happens and it's kind of a
sequence here like step by step here so
each and every stage is very important
because that's how the communication
will happen over here and you will get
the end result or the desired output if
you have any kind of feeling component
over here so that's where the whole
connectivity will be break down and you
will not be able to get any kind of
values X expected so this is something
which we really need to consider or we
need to go ahead with that part here if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
so what are the different drawbacks
which we got with the help of the
selenium Webdriver here so when we talk
about the selenium web driver so what
are the different drawbacks which we are
getting over here so that we can
understand like how exactly we can talk
about that part here now the drawbacks
of a selenium Webdriver is something
which we uh you know use because this is
kind of uh main component you can say
like you know using which you can
actually do the complete validation but
the problem is that it's not something
which you can use for the desktop
application so for the desktop
application this does not works so this
web driver is something which is uh
supported for the web applications only
it's not something which we can use for
the desktop applications as such so
that's a kind of a limitation which we
get with the help of the selenium web
driver here so it's only there for the
websites for the web portals
secondly the it requires the acceptance
of the teams uh you know in order to
manage these scripts because these are
the programming languages of course
there although it's a test suit but uh
it requires a programming language
efforts as such in order to go ahead
with that in order to manage these
things so it requires a kind of export
team who can actually handle these
scripts or we can work on these
requirements so uh that's a kind of
overhead because if it's not like very
easy to manage these like uh pretty much
a person who is an expert in these
things can only handle these kind of
requirements so it's kind of a
limitation where we will be only
depending on an expert to manage these
scripts as such right now um it's not
having any kind of uh reporting inbuilt
reporting capability over here so it's
not available in this one so test
reports which is getting generated here
is uh with the help of the junit and
test NG so there is no default reporting
mechanism which is available over here
in this one so we only have the
mechanism of the junit like we can
extend our test scripts in selenium by
integrating with J unit and the test NG
here so that we will be able to get a
proper reporting so for the uh reporting
purposes we actually use the components
like this junit and the test NG over
here to go ahead with that so these are
the ways in which we can actually go for
the integration where we can integrate
the selenium and the other Frameworks
like junit and the uh test NG kind of
component cm
and that's a whole basis because alone
the selenium Webdriver is something
which can execute the scripts process
the request but it's not going to handle
any kind of uh reporting mechanism so
reporting mechanism is something which
you can only get with the help of the
junit or the test uh NG here because
these are the additional packages which
you need to integrate so it's it's a
kind of a custom solution which we need
to design uh you know where we don't
have only the web driver available over
here like the core components but also
we have like other components available
over there which will be of course
having the other components like
distancing and the change unit here so
that's also something which you can
integrate all together with this one
right also uh it's very difficult to
manage there is a lot of management or
the maintenance activity which we get
over here also it's very difficult to
scale this up also depending on the load
or depending on the requirement it's
very difficult to scale it up also if
you are using for some infrastructure
some kind of a load there so having it
increased to a different level is kind
of a difficult task here also
maintenance activity is quite huge so if
you want to have a proper materials or
management you have to get a couple of
uh you know experts in that case so that
they can easily manage those things so
these are the different requirements
which is available there where we can
see like how exactly the uh we can you
know manage all these things now it also
uh you know allows the across browser uh
compatibility testing here so uh it's
something which can easily handle like
different requests across the browsers
so um image testing is not available so
uh you don't have to uh you know use the
selenium alone like selenium alone is
not compatible for testing the images
here so if you really want to test the
images so you have to integrate securely
uh in with your selenium so that you can
have a complete package so again a
selenium in some cases it's not
sufficient for like most or a variety of
things there so in some cases you have
to actually
go for another tool Integrations so that
you can have the complete details you
can have the complete component here
so that's where the real mechanism comes
in like yes uh you don't have the exact
single tool available for taking care of
all these things but yes you can have
all these things integrated uh with the
other tools other components there and
from there you will be able to get a
complete values and the complete
implementation here right so these are
the you know different uh drawbacks
which we get once we start using the a
web driver here so let's go ahead uh
with the uh particular demo over here to
understand like how exactly the selenium
web driver can be utilized can be used
so that we will be able to run some test
scripts here so we are going to run a
prepare a test suit here so that we can
get it executed with the help of
selenium so that's what we are trying to
do here so for this one we require some
couple of components to be there like
the jdk eclipse and all so let's talk
about that component so let's go ahead
with the implementation
so let's begin with the uh
configurations of this web driver here
now the very first thing which we
require is that we require to the
installation of the Java here now let's
uh go ahead with this URL so now this
one is something where we have to see
like how uh we can go for the
installation of the uh jdk here now here
we need to go for the jdk installation
that's a version which we want to
install now it variety of versions are
available there like which version you
want to install you can go with that jdk
11 8 it is the most stable version so
you can go ahead with the jdk8 here so
you can download here
different platforms it's available like
Windows platform uh whatever the
platform is there all you need to do is
like you need to just download this exe
file now once the exe file is downloaded
so what happens like you will be able to
do the installation now I have done the
installation of this jdk here so if I
have to open my command prompt here I
would be easily able to see that I'm
using a jdk version of
1.8.0 over here in this one so that's a
version which I'm using but I've gained
of course if you're using some different
version of gdkit that will also work
here the only thing is that you need to
see that you need to go for a compatible
browser a compatible uh Java and the
compatible Eclipse tool here so that's
what you require now what I'm going to
do is like I'm going to install or
download the eclipse browser also now
let's download the eclipse here now we
got an official website of eclipse here
from where we can download these at
clips
different platform you can do it like uh
this is the one which is available there
now you can click on download this one
so that will help you to download the
eclipse here so uh here the uh download
will work just like that you can do the
download here even if you want to go for
a different offerings like uh you want
to go for a different platform uh you
feel like uh you want to decide that
which package actually you need to do
because uh in the eclipse also you got
like different things
um IDE Eclipse IDE for the Java
developers for uh the C plus C plus plus
so different uh different uh operating
system and different uh packages are
also available there so it's basically
up to you like which exactly environment
you want to follow
so I want to download this uh 64-bit
over here in this one so let's download
this here now uh let's Again download
this if this is kind of a exe file which
is available here so let's download it
again now um it will be working on like
uh it's kind of a download which is
getting started over here so it's close
to 102 MB which is available there this
is the SDK table which is going to help
us to do the installation of eclipse now
this is the uh latest version uh 2020
version is what it is getting installed
over here
um and uh it's completely there I have
already got the jdk installed because of
the fact that using this jdk the eclipse
will be open if you don't have the jdk
install the Java runtime then the
eclipse will not be installed for you so
uh in order to get the eclipse uh
installed in executable perfectly fine
you need uh the jdk install to be done
here so we got like one more minute here
to complete the download and this is
just 102 MB package or installer which
is available there and once this is
installed we will be able to get ahead
with this installation of the eclipse
here so once the eclipse is installed
all you can do is like you can go ahead
with the uh particular configurations
you can create some couple of projects
in case of eclipse
um then we'll also see like how we can
download the
programming languages binding so that
also we are going to download so these
are the different components which
you're going to explore while working on
this one so uh let's wait for this uh
download of these executable to be
performed here so that we will be able
to proceed further with this one so
let's wait for that so it's hardly
taking one minute more to complete it
so selenium and Eclipse both are the
Open Source One you're getting a donate
to a close Community page there because
that's a donation which they want but
again you can use it like 100 open
source and free of cost here so you
don't have to pay any cost as such over
here in this case so there is no cost
associated with this one so just 10
seconds more and uh then we can pursue
with the installation of the eclipse
here and here we go so the installer is
almost done here so I can pretty much go
ahead and open the file so this will
help me to do the installation of the
eclipse here so the eclipse installer is
what it's getting started initialized
over here in this one
uh now the Java runtime is already
available with me we require the uh
specific uh jdk installed the Java
command line is working we can download
the eclipse here and uh then we can go
for the uh specific executions like we
can go and uh download the uh browser
drivers here now the thing is that if
you really want to go for the Chrome
browser or Firefox or any kind of those
things in case of your uh particular
system in case of your Windows machine
over here you don't have to necessarily
go for any kind of uh a kind of a driver
as such here because of the fact we got
a links over here like uh this Mozilla
for the Firefox uh this one is there for
the uh particular selenium this one is
there for the Chrome now Chrome is
something which we have already got here
like we have already got the Chrome
browser installed
but let's see like uh we can download
this driver also like uh depending on
that we can go ahead with that part and
then we can also download the Java
client uh libraries over there from the
bindings over there from the uh specific
selenium.dev website over there and uh
we can download and we can integrate it
so let's do it one by one so first of
all let's see like you know once the
installation of the eclipse is done and
then we'll be able to go ahead with the
third component or the third request
which is the a web driver or a
particular Chrome browser a driver over
here so this installer is going to give
us the same thing here so I'm going for
the uh specific Java developer here so
let's go for the uh installation here
now this is going to uh install uh the
uh Java 8 right uh this runtime over
here so uh if you feel like you want to
use the jdk 11 because that's something
which is available there now if you're
using an existing ones like uh you're
already using a an existing once over
here the jdk and also uh that's where
the installation is going on like uh
it's it's going on with that part here
but we already got some system related
uh gdks which is installed but uh you
feel like you want to go ahead with this
one
um like you're not doing these separate
installation of the jdk or JRE so there
you can actually use this once here so
let's select this one like I pretty much
want to use like any one of these uh
jvms over here like which I feel like I
can configure or I can utilize so that's
pretty much we can do here so it's like
uh we can use these variables like we
can go for these jvms or if you feel
like uh you can go for an external jvm
also there so it all depends on you like
how the uh installation you want to
perform here
right and this is the location Let's uh
go for the desktop location there
and or you can go for the default
location also over here in this one so
let's go for the installation now just
accept it and uh the installation will
be proceeded over here so uh even if you
have not done a separate JTAG
installation so this will basically have
a jdk installed I have selected the Java
11 over here but you can go for the 15
also in this case in this scenario so
the whole installation of the eclipse is
what it's happening over here
so once the eclipse is installed so then
we can pretty much go ahead with the
next component here which is like uh
dealing with the uh specific selenium
related components and Chrome browser
again it's already something which is
installed here but we'll see like how we
can download the Chrome driver how we
can configure and we can utilize that so
that's what we're going to follow here
so it's going for the installation and
uh it's something which we are trying to
do like uh it's uh this installer is
pretty much downloading some couple of
components as such uh like this J uh JRE
is something which is getting installed
or downloaded from the eclipse website
and uh that's where the uh you know all
the components is getting installed so
one by one all the components will be
downloaded from the eclipse website here
and it's a complete package which means
like you don't have to necessarily go
for a separate installation there is
another installer which is available for
Eclipse where you just have to unzip up
for a zip file and you can pretty much
use it but in this case
this is something which is having all
these things integrated all together
inside that so that's another component
which is being available here
so the installation is still going on
there so uh it depends because all these
things are getting cached uh from the
internet so it also depends on like how
much size of file is getting downloaded
here so let's uh you know let's uh wait
for the installations to be complete and
then we'll proceed further so now the
installation is done so we can launch
our Eclipse here so that's what we are
trying to launch here now apart from
eclipse what happens like we require
some other components also like we
require this linear web driver also
there so for that we have to download
the Java related client bindings so for
that uh Chrome browser first of all it's
already installed so we don't have to do
any kind of installation there uh yes I
can go ahead with the exe file like of
the Chrome browser driver that I'm going
to use it so I'm going to open the uh
specific downloads here now in this
segment what happens like selenium.dev
is the website which is available there
now here we can go for the downloads now
related to your programming language
whatever gaming language you are trying
to use so you can download the language
binding for that now language binding is
something which is utilized so using
which you will be able to see like how
you can establish the connectivity it's
just a kind of a libraries where you can
do the connectivity and you can see that
execution so what I'm going to do is
like I'm going to download this binding
save so let's download this one now it's
again available as a zip file which is
available there so uh depending on the
version you can go for the beta download
version also but I am going for the
stable version which we want to utilize
we want to refer it so it's going to
download zip file so this ZIP file will
have all the jar files and all the
required libraries there
and when I'm going to create a project
into my eclipse at that moment of time I
would be requiring all these components
like all these uh various libraries
should be added up into my uh project as
such in case of the eclipse so that's
what I need to do here so let's go to
the eclipse here so here we are going to
expand this like a package Explorer and
here we're going to go to file new and
Java project so I'm going to create a
Java project over here so
um in which we will be creating some
couple of class files in which we will
be having the selenium related test
cases like how we want to process or how
we want to execute that part so I'm
going to proceed with that part so let's
put the uh project name here so I'm
going to say like selenium
just a project name I want to put uh
then the jdk now if you want to go for a
specific jdk like another version so you
can go with that but right now I'm using
like jdk 1.8 which is pretty much
configured so I can use that uh you feel
like you want to use uh the specific JRE
of uh uh GRE which is available as part
of jdk 1.8 that also you can use or if
you want to use like a jdk so that also
something which you can utilize over
here in this one so there are different
things like you can configure the gre's
also so if you have some custom path
which uh where you have the Java
available or the jdk or Jr is available
there so that also you can easily refer
it so you can simply say that yes uh
this so and so location I want to refer
I want to see my source code so that's
where you can do the you can go for the
execution now once you're providing
these values like the install Gres which
you want to provide which you want to
process here next thing what you need to
perform is like you need to go ahead
with that execution so I'm completely
okay with the jdk whatever the
environment I want to process I can
easily do that and I'm completely okay
with that
right so let's go with that part and
then click on next
and this is the source directory which
is available there right and if you want
to add any additional libraries so uh
here exactly you can add your selenium
related libraries using which you will
be able to see your source code working
fine but I'm not going to do that
activity here so I'm going to do that
later on so that we can get a complete
things in a sequence
and then here we go like finish so you
will be able to get
the gr related libraries and the source
folder here so right now it's completely
empty project there is nothing available
as such here and what I'm going to do is
like I'm going to create a class file
over here to see to be the specific
source code of the selenium to how the
web driver is getting loaded up and
processed so that's stuff we are going
to talk about here so let's see like
what content we need to really put up
over here in this one now if we
downloaded this selenium programming
language bindings here so let me extract
it
uh you can pretty much keep it into the
eclipse folders also or if you wish you
can keep it aside in some specific
folder because it's just going to be
referred with every project so it's just
a kind of a shared release which is
available there so whatever project you
want to onboard you want to use so this
kind of uh package or this kind of uh
share Library you can easily utilize and
you can implement it so we are just
trying to extract it now once the
extraction is done so you will be able
to see like some couple of files and
folders uh now this is having a
particular uh two executable files like
client number combined this is kind of
connecting uh acting like a selenium
client and which is using to connect and
process all the requirements
we also have a sources file which is
available for this one but again it's
something which depends on the
requirement so you don't have to put
these sources uh jar file also over here
because that's not required so you can
pretty much uh use this executable jar
file because in this one you will not
have any kind of source then of course
uh your uh selenium related jar file is
further on dependent on some
dependencies like this so these jar
files are also uh something which you
should be putting up into your uh
specific
um a shared Library so that your
selenium related jar files should not
started failing so uh we'll we'll try
that scenario also so that we can get
the complete output and complete
instance here so let's see now uh we'll
go to this uh we'll import this
particular file over there and uh for
that we have to write a class file so
let's see like how we can do that so we
have already got the selenium web driver
so uh the eclipse is what we have
followed so we have created a new uh jar
project now we want to create a new
class file the build path configurations
we will be taking care of that later on
but right now we are going to see like
how we can proceed further with that so
I I'm going for this uh specific
component here right so uh whatever the
browser or whatever the driver you want
to follow you can do that so Firefox if
you want to use you want to use our
Chrome browser it all depends on you
like it all depends on the way like how
you want to configure it so uh let's see
let's uh import this uh particular
component here now if the specific a
Firefox browser is installed that's
great if it's not installed so you can
just go back here so here you will be
able to see like this browsers like
these specific components which is
available here
so this is the driver which is available
so for the windows 64-bit you can Again
download this one here
so whatever the platform you want like
if you want to use for the Chrome
browser you can go for that if you want
to go for the Firefox Edge whatever the
driver you feel like you want to go you
can do go with that part here
so let's uh open this one here and
extract this one also so that we should
be able to refer it over here into our
specific source code so this is the
driver this is the exe file which is
available there now all we need to do is
like we need to just open our Eclipse
there so uh in our Eclipse uh we should
be using or we should be referring to
this one here so this is a kind of a
path which is available similarly we
will also be giving a path over there so
that uh we can refer to that specific uh
driver that driver over here so let me
open that and uh let's see so I'm going
to create a class file here you can
create a package
called com and in that package you can
further on create a class file
like
selenium test
uh
it's also uh depends like this is just a
custom name so uh you feel like you want
to give some different name you can uh
go for uh you know any kind of class
name over here but this is something
which is uh something we are going to
see like how the execution needs to be
performed and needs to be done here so
there are different uh you know names
like uh you want to follow some
different name you can do that also now
if you see closely here let me save the
file here now in this one you are
getting some errors uh related to this
one like you're getting the uh error
codes related to the Imports here like
how the uh specific execution should be
done here right now the thing is that uh
this is something which is uh really
causing the problems uh like how the
import or the execution should be done
right also uh the thing is that uh
we require these Imports to be available
there right so uh that's definitely we
are requiring over here and uh that's
that's something which we uh require uh
we want to process as such also so right
now let's uh have an uh particular
decoration of the uh package also there
because it's something which is there in
the com package so let's have the
package com also here so it's there in
the com package uh but again those
errors are not related to that so these
are like related to the configurations
which we are trying to put and uh during
the copy pastry there might be a
conversion of the code so that I have
taken care great so uh let's see now
what I have to really do is like we have
to see like how we can proceed further
on the uh for the most executions and we
need to get this driver like we need to
get this one so I'll right click on my
project here and go to the build path
and click on configure build path
so first I'm going to uh add my binding
jar file there the Java binding a Java
file which I downloaded just now this
client combined one here so only this
jar file we are trying to add up over
here and with that most of the uh
related errors related to that uh
Imports will be resolved now I'm not
sure that how it's going to work how
it's going to uh you know function
whether it's going to success or failure
that's a different story but yes all you
have done is like I right clicked on my
project went to the build path went to
the configure build path here and went
for the add external charge so these are
the external jars which you have to do
we have to put up over here
so only the combined client combined jar
file is what I have put up over here in
this one in the referenced libraries you
will immediately be able to know that
part of the jar file here
now this is the directory where you will
be having the exe file available for
that driver for the Firefox so let's get
the path for our component also so we
got the path so let me paste it over
here
and here we go so we got the path here
this is the folder where we got our
driver available here and let's try to
resolve it let's try to run it over here
great
so now I'm going to right click here
just say run as and Java application now
in this one I got an error saying that
some com Google common collect immutable
map some class file is not available
there this is the fact that I did not
imported those uh dependent jar files
also which we got downloaded from the uh
Java binding file here so that zip file
was also having some of the jar files
there in the library folders so in this
one also you will be able to see like
some executions of the jar files is
required over here as an Imports as a
standard Imports so let's import this
one and this is the reason why we got
the error at the first place because we
are not importing those ones those jar
files which is combine jar file also so
these are the dependent jar files which
we are trying to import here so
ultimately and last you will be able to
have your referenced libraries available
here with all these jar files component
available here
right now since our driver is configured
everything is configured now the next
thing which we require is the browser
now I have the Chrome browser but
unfortunately I don't have the Firefox
browser so let's go ahead and download
the Firefox browser so for that
let's open the browser so I'm going to
download a Firefox browser over here
into my system so uh the official
website is something which is quite good
so we can go for the download Firefox
here now uh why because I require now
I'm using the Firefox here if I am using
the Chrome browser I will not be having
or facing any kind of issues as such but
since I'm using the Firefox uh driver so
I require Firefox browser so the
dependency of the browser is there when
we want to go ahead because uh pretty
much my uh code base is going to connect
or this
one is going to connect to the driver
here but driver ultimately internally or
require a browser show that it can
perform the executions it can do that
execution so these drivers are going to
just uh communicate between the your
source code and the actual browser here
so uh after the driver you also require
the browser to be installed like the
Chrome browser to be available here so
that you can pretty much use it and you
can perform the configuration so let's
see uh we are getting the browser over
here in this one and we got the browser
installed perfectly fine over here so
we'll just see the browser because in
this one we are basically trying to open
the browser and getting a website called
www.google.com here and then we are
having a particular sleep one and then
ultimately the driver is getting cured
here
so let's see so once the browser is
downloaded and installed so right click
on run as Java application
so you will be able to see the browsing
here so okay it's connecting the uh
browser the Firefox exe file is getting
executed a browser is getting executed
and it will be maximized automatically
you can see here like it's you know
getting maximized automatically here and
uh we just have to wait for a couple of
seconds more and uh here we go we got
the browser Clause automatically also
because there was a slip of a couple of
seconds over here and you got the
failure like you got the complete uh
component or it got the driver closed
there driver close means that definitely
the browser will also be closed here and
you can see here that the uh specific
output which is being performed or which
is getting executed over here it's
actually showing us like how the
executions and the uh setup needs to be
performed or needs to be done here
so this is the way that how
the pro the implementations really
performed or really gets executed over
here in this case you got the browser
execution and everything will be
perfectly fine so again I'm right
clicking over here just click on run as
Java application the same browser will
be open again uh it will be
automatically refreshed you will see
that progress like this and after a
couple of seconds uh the thread will be
on sleep but yes after that it will be
closed automatically over here so like
that you can program how to open a
website how to proceed further from
there you want to click on some buttons
you want to do some processing that's
all up to you like how you program how
you code it over here so this completely
helps you to see like how exactly you
can go ahead with the complete program
and this program will help you to
execute a good amount of testing
validations and running or executing
some couple of test cases so this is
what we have in this demo where we saw
like how we can configure the different
drivers the web driver the browser
driver an ultimately the browser and the
selenium web driver here so you're using
the selenium web driver over here which
is going to invoke the browser driver
and this browser driver is going to
invoke the browser as such over here in
this case so that's it for this demo
let's move on to main content here so
that was the demo in which we executed a
very simple program in order to execute
the selenium Webdriver which is going to
further invoke the browser driver the
Firefox driver and then it was invoking
the specific implementations there right
so this is what we did and if we
summarize this demo so in this one we
downloaded uh the selenium Webdriver we
installed it we configured it we
integrated the eclipse with the selenium
web driver
and we also executed a specific test
script in order to see like how a
particular browser will be imported and
the previous case is yes the browser was
invoking a www.google.com website there
and we were getting the response
accordingly and that was the executions
mechanism like that's a whole basis that
how the selenium test cases used to work
and used to be integrated over there so
this is the complete way that how
exactly we did this demo here meet Tim
Timber is a robot in his lab a climate
controlled and pollution-free
environment
once he's done he drops the robot off at
his project partner Mia's house Mia
takes it out to her backyard to ensure
that the robot meets the requirements
but here is where the problem arises the
change in the environment causes the
robot to malfunction Mia is now really
annoyed and she has a lot to correct and
it seems to her as though Tim didn't
really do much this wall between them
leaves a poor robot to bite the dust
well what if we broke this wall Tim and
Miana work together in a common space
Tim develops each block of functionality
of the robot which is then immediately
checked by Mia both are now working
simultaneously instead of waiting on the
other to finish their task as in when a
feature is ready for use they are put
together to build the final product they
develop a common mindset and share ideas
to further speed up the process they use
several tools which can automate every
stage this means that the robot is now
ready sooner with less iterations and
manual work from an organization
perspective Tim would be the developer
while Mia the operations their Union is
the core of the devops approach devops
has several stages and set of tools to
automate each of these stages let's have
a look at these Tim first puts down a
plan in terms of software this could
mean deciding on the module fuels and
the algorithms to use once he has the
plan he now codes the plan with tools
such as git Tim has a repository for
storing all the codes and their
different versions this is call Version
Control next the score is fetched and
made executable this is the build stage
tools such as Gradle and Maven will sort
this out now before deployment the
product is tested to catch any bugs the
most popular tool automating testing is
selenium once the products are tested
Mia must deploy it the deployed product
is then continuously configured to the
desired State ansible puppet and Docker
are some of the most common tools used
that automate these stages
now every product is continuously
monitored in its working environment
nagios is one such tool that automates
this phase and the feedback is fed back
to the planning stage and finally we
have the core of the devops life cycle
the integration stage tools such as
Jenkins is responsible for sending the
code for build and test if the code
passes the tests it's further sent for
deployment this is called continuous
integration let's now have a look at an
organization that has adopted the devops
approach which of the below sequence of
steps would they follow to develop a
software Linea answers in the comment
section keep an eye out for the right
answer on the comment section or our
YouTube Community
Giants such as Amazon Netflix Target
Etsy and Walmart have all adopted devops
and seen a considerable increase in
delivery and quality in 2014 an hour of
downtime for Netflix would cost two
hundred thousand dollars
it became absolutely crucial that
Netflix prepared themselves for any sort
of failure and so they took to the
devops approach and implemented it in
the most unique way they developed a
tool called Simeon Army this tool
created failures and automatically
deployed them in an environment that did
not affect the users the team would
troubleshoot these failures and this
gave them enough experience to deal with
any degree of collapse with everything
being automated and happening
simultaneously organizations can now
deliver at a much faster pace so
considering the benefits of devops and
its Divergence from the traditional
methods would devops be the future let
us know what you think in the comment
section below and with that we come to
an end of our video hello this is
Matthew from Simply learn and today
we're going to cover what is Docker and
why it should be of value to you as
somebody who works in devops so let's
say take a slow scenario of a developer
and a tester before you had the world of
Docker a developer would actually build
their code and then they send it to the
tester but then the code wouldn't work
on their system encoders will work on
the other system due to the differences
in computer environments so what could
be the solution to this well you could
go ahead and create a virtual machine to
be the same of the solution in both
areas what do you think Docker is an
even better solution so let's kind of
break out what the main big differences
are between Docker and virtual machines
as you can see between the left and the
right hand side both look to be very
similar what you'll see however is that
on the docker side what you'll see as a
big difference is that the guest OS for
each container has been illuminated
Docker is inherently more lightweight
but provides the same functionality as a
virtual machine so let's step through
some of the pros and cons of the Virtual
Machine versus Docker so first of all a
virtual machine occupies a lot more
memory space on the host machine in
contrast Docker occupies significantly
less memory space the boot up time
between both is very different Docker
just boots up faster the performance of
the docker environment is actually
better and more consistent than the
virtual machine Docker is also very easy
to set up and very easy to scale the
efficiencies therefore are much higher
with a Docker environment versus a
virtual machine environment and you'll
find it is easier to Port Docker across
multiple platforms than a virtual
machine finally the space allocation
between Docker and a virtual machine is
significant when you don't have to
include the guest OS your eliminating a
significant amount of space and the
docker environment is just inherently
smaller so after Docker as a developer
you can build out your solution and send
it to a tester and as long as we're all
running in the docker environment
everything will work just great so let's
step through what we're going to cover
in this presentation we're going to look
at the devops tools and where Docker
fits within that space we'll examine
what Docker actually is and how Docker
works and then finally we'll step
through the different components of the
docker environment so what is devops
devops is a collaboration between the
development team the operation team
allowing you to continuously deliver
Solutions and applications and services
that both delight and improve the
efficiency of your customers if you look
at the Venn diagram that we have here on
the left hand side we have development
on the right hand side we have operation
and then there's a crossover in the
middle and that's where the dev devops
Team sets if we look at the areas of
integration between both groups
developers are really interested in
planning code building and testing and
operations want to be able to
efficiently deploy operate a monitor
when you can have both groups
interacting with each other on these
seven key and elements then you can have
the efficiencies of an excellent devops
team so planning and code base we use
tools like jit and gearer for building
we use Gradle and Maven testing we use
selenium the integration between Dev and
Ops is through tools such as Jenkins and
then the deployment operation is done
with tools such as Docker and Chef
finally nagias is used to monitor the
entire environment so let's step deeper
into what Docker actually is so Docker
is a tool which is used to automate the
deployment of applications in a
lightweight container so the application
can work efficiently in different
environments now it's important to note
that the container is actually a
software package that consists of all
the dependencies required to run the
application so multiple containers can
run on the same Hardware the containers
are maintained in isolated environments
they're highly productive and they're
quick and easy to configure so let's
take an example of what Docker is by
using a house that may be rented for
someone using Airbnb so in the house
there are three rooms and only one
cupboard and kitchen and the problem we
have is that none of the guests are
really ready to share the cupboard and
kitchen because every individual has a
different preference when it comes to
how the cupboard should be stocked and
how the kitchen should be used this is
very similar to how we run software
applications today each of the
applications could end up using
different Frameworks so you may have a
framework such as rails perfect and
flask and you may want to have them
running for different applications for
different situations this is where
Docker will help you run the
applications with the suitable
Frameworks so let's go back to our
Airbnb example so we have three rooms
and a kitchen and cupboard how do we
resolve this issue well we put a kitchen
and cupboard in each room we can do the
same thing for computers Docker provides
the suitable Frameworks for each
different application and since every
application has a framework with a
suitable version this space can also
then be utilized for putting in software
and applications that are long and since
every application has its own framework
and suitable version the area that we
had previously stored for a framework
can be used for something else now we
can create a new application in this
instance a fourth application that uses
its own resources you know what with
these kinds of a bill abilities to be
able to free up space on the computer
it's no wonder Docker is the right
choice so let's take a closer look to
how Docker actually works so when we
look at Docker and we call something
Docker we're actually referring to the
base engine which actually is installed
on the host machine that has all the
different components that run your
Docker environment and if we look at the
image on the left hand side of the
screen you'll see that Docker has a
client server relationship there's a
client installed on the hardware there
is a client that contains the docker
product and then there is a server which
controls how that Docker client is
created the communication that goes back
and forth to be able to share the
knowledge on that Docker client
relationship it's done through a rest
API this is fantastic news because that
means that you can actually interface
and program that API so we look here in
the animation we see that the docker
client is constantly communicating back
to the server server information about
the infrastructure and it's using this
rest API as that Communication channel
the docker server then would check out
the requests and the interaction
necessary for it to be the docker Daemon
which runs on the server itself well
then check out the interaction and the
necessary operating system pieces needed
to be able to run the container okay so
that's just an overview of the docker
engine which is probably where you're
going to spend most of your time but
there are some other components that
form the infrastructure for Docker let's
dig into those a little bit deeper as
well so what we're going to do now is
break out the four main components that
comprise of the docker environment the
four components are as follows the
docker clients and server which we've
already done a deeper dive on Docker
images Docker containers and the docker
registry so if we look at the structure
that we have here on the left hand side
you see the real relationship between
the docker client and the docker server
and then we have the rest API in between
now if we start digging into that rest
API particularly the relationship with
the docker Daemon on the server we
actually have our other elements that
form the different components of the
docker ecosystem so the docker client is
accessed from your terminal window so if
you are using Windows this can be
Powershell on Mac it's going to be your
terminal window and it allows you to run
the docker Daemon and the registry
service when you have your terminal
window open so you can actually use your
terminal window to create instructions
on how to build and run your Docker
images and containers if we look at the
images part of our registry here we
actually see that the image is really
just a template with the instructions
used for creating the containers which
you use within Docker the docker image
is built using a file called the docker
file and then once you've created that
Docker file you'll store all that image
in the docker Hub or registry and that
allows other people to be able to access
the same structure of a Docker
environment that you've created the
syntax of creating the image is fairly
simple it's something that you'll be
able to get your arms around very
quickly and essentially what you're
doing is you're creating the option of a
new container you're identifying what
the image will look like what are the
commands that are needed and the
arguments for within those commands and
once you've done that you have a
definition for what your image will look
like so if we look here at what the
container itself looks like is that the
container is a standalone executable
package which includes applications and
their dependencies it's the instructions
for what your environment will look like
so you can be consistent in how that
environment is shared between multiple
developers testing units and other
people within your devops team now the
thing that's great about working with
Docker is that it's so lightweight that
you can actually run multiple Docker
containers in the same infrastructure
and share the same operating system this
is its strength it allows you to be able
to create those multiple environments
that you need for multiple projects that
you're working on interestingly though
within each container that container
creates an isolated area for the
applications to run so while you can run
multiple containers in an infrastructure
each of those containers are completely
isolated they're protected so that you
can actually control how your Solutions
work there now as a team you may start
off with one or two developers on your
team but when a project starts becoming
more important and you start adding in
more people to your team you may have 15
people that are offshore you may have 10
people that are local you may have 15
Consultants that are working on your
project you have a need for each of
those developers or each person on your
team to have access to that image and to
get access to that image we use a Docker
registry which is an Open Source
server-side service for hosting and
distributing the images that you have
defined you can also use Docker itself
as its own default registry and Docker
Hub now something that has to be bear in
mind though is that for publicly shared
images you may want to have your own
private images in which case you would
do that through your own registry so
once again public repositories can be
used to host the docker images which can
be accessed by anyone and I really
encourage you to go out to Docker and
see the other Docker images that have
been created because there may be tools
there that you can use to speed up your
own development environments now you
will also get to a point where you start
creating environments that are very
specific to the solutions that you are
building and when you get to that point
you'll likely want to create a private
repository so you're not sharing that
knowledge with the world in general now
the way in which you connect with the
docker registry is through simple pull
and push commands but you run through
terminal window to be able to get the
latest information so if you want to be
able to build your own container what
you'll start doing is using the pull
commands to actually pull the image from
the docker repository and the command
line for that is fairly simple in
terminal window you would write Docker
pull and then you put in the image name
and any tags associated with that image
and use the command pause so in your
terminal window you would actually use a
simple line of command once you've
actually connected to your Docker
environment and that command will be
Docker pull with the image name and any
Associated tags around that image what
that will then do is pull the image from
the docker repository whether that's a
public repository or a private one now
in Reverse if you want to be able to
update the docker image with new
information you do a push command where
you take the script that you've written
about the docker container that that you
define and push it to the repository and
as you can imagine the commands for that
are also fairly simple in terminal
window you would write Docker push the
image name any Associated tags and then
that would then push that image to the
docker repository again either a public
or a private repository so if we recap
the docker file creates a Docker image
that's using the build commands Docker
image then contains all the information
necessary for you to be able to execute
the project using the docker image any
user can run the code in order to create
a Docker container and once a Docker
image is built it's uploaded to a
registry or to a Docker Hub where it can
be shared across your entire team and
from the docker Hub users can get access
to the docker image and build their own
new containers welcome to all our
viewers I'm Anjali from Simply learn and
today I'll be taking you through the
installation process for Docker so
before we begin let me give you an intro
to Docker so what is docker Docker is a
tool which is used to automate the
deployment of applications in
lightweight containers so when I say
containers I mean a software package
that consists of all the dependencies
required to run the particular
application and when you deploy
containers you're basically providing
the capability for the application to
run in any kind of environment so
Dockers have multiple features some of
which are that multiple containers can
run on the same Hardware it has very
high productivity when compared to
Virtual machines it maintains isolated
applications and has a very quick and
easy configuration process so now let's
begin with the demo we'll be installing
Docker on an Ubuntu system so this is my
system I just open the terminal so the
first thing you can start with is
removing any Docker installation that
you probably already have present in
your system if you want to start from
scratch so this is the command to do so
sudo app get removed doc okay
doc engine Docker dot IO enter your
password
and Docker is removed so now we'll start
from scratch and we'll install Docker
once again before that I'll just clear
my screen
okay so before I install Docker let me
just ensure that all these softwares on
my system currently is in its latest
state
so sudo app get update
great so that's done next thing we'll
actually install our docker
so type in sudo apt
get
install
docker
now as you can see here there's an error
that's occurred so sometimes it's
possible that due to the environment of
the machine that you're working in this
particular command does not work
in which case there's always another
command that you can start with
just type Docker install
and that by itself will give you the
commands you can use to install docker
so as it says here sudo apt install
Docker dot IO is a command that we will
need to execute to install docker
and after that we'll execute the sudo
snap install Docker so sudo apt install
Docker dot IO first
and this will install your docker
after that's done we will have sudo snap
install Docker so snap install Docker
installs a newly created snap package
there are basically some other
dependencies for Docker that you'll have
to install
of course since this is the installation
process for the entire Docker i o it
will take some time
great so our Docker is installed the
next thing we do as I mentioned earlier
is that we need to install all the
dependency packages so the command for
that is
sudo snap install talk
enter your password
so with that we have completed the
installation process for Docker but
we'll perform a few more stages where we
will test if the installation has been
done right
so before we move on with the testing
for Docker let's once again just check
the version that we have installed
so for that the command is Docker
version
and as you can see Docker version
17.12.1 CE has been installed next thing
we do is we pull an image from the
docker hub
so Docker run
hello
world
now hello world is a Docker image which
is present on the docker Hub Docker Hub
is basically a repository that you can
find online so with this command the
docker image hello world has been pulled
onto your system
so let's see if it's actually present on
your system now the command to check
this
is pseudo Docker images
and as you can see here hello world
repository this is present on our system
currently so the image has been
successfully pulled onto the system and
this means that our Docker is working
now we'll try out another command
pseudo Docker PF minus a this displays
all the containers that you have pulled
so far so as you can see here there are
three hello world images displayed and
all of them are in exited state so I did
this demo previously too which is why
the two hello worlds which is created
two minutes ago is also displayed here
and the first hello world which has been
created a minute ago is the one we just
did for this demo now as you have
probably noticed that all the hello
world images over here all these
containers are in the exited state so
when you give the option for Docker PS
minus a where minus a stands for all it
displays all the containers whether they
are in exited or running state if you
want to see only those containers which
are in their running State you can
simply execute sudo Docker PS
pseudo docker
yes
and as you can see no container is
visible here because none of them are in
running State and with that we come to
an end of our Docker installation this
is Matthew from Simply learn and today
we're going to dig through what Docker
is and how you could be using it within
your own devops environment so let's get
started in this presentation we're going
to go through a number of key things
we're going to compare Docker versus
traditional virtual machines and what
are the differences and why you'd want
to choose Docker over a virtual
environment we'll go through the
advantages of working with Docker and
the structure and how you would build
out a Docker environment and during that
structure we'll dig through the
components and the advanced components
within Docker at the end of the
presentation we'll go through some basic
commands and then show you how those
basic commands can be used in a live
demo so with all that said let's get
started so this first we'll compare
Docker with a traditional virtual
machine so here we have the architecture
on the the left and right of a
traditional Virtual Machine versus a
Docker environment and there are some
things that you'll probably see
immediately that are big differences one
is that the virtual environment has
hypervisor layer whereas the docker
environment has a Docker engine layer
and then in addition to that there are
additional layers within the virtual
machine each of these really start
compounding and creating very
significant differences between a Docker
environment and a virtual machine
environment so with a virtual machine
the actual memory usage is very high
whereas with that darker environment the
memory usage is very low if we look at
performance virtual machines when you
start building out particularly more
than one virtual machine on a server the
performance starts aggregating and
starts getting poorer whereas with
Docker the performance always stays
really good this is largely due to the
lightweight architecture used to
construct the docker containers
themselves it look at portability
virtual machines just are terrible for
portability they're still dependent on
the host operating system and there's
just a lot of problems that happen when
you are using virtual machines for
portability in contrast Docker was
designed for portability so you can
actually build Solutions in a Docker
container environment and have the
guarantee that the solution will work as
you have built it no matter where it's
hosted finally boot up time the boot up
time for a virtual machine is fairly
slow in comparison to the boot up time
for a Docker environment which is almost
instantaneous so we look at these in a
little bit more detail one of the other
challenges that you have with a virtual
machine is that if you have unused
memory within the environment you cannot
reallocate that memory so if you set up
an environment that has nine gigs of
memory that's being used we have six
gigs that are free you can't do anything
with it though that whole nine gig has
been allocated to that virtual machine
in contrast with Docker if you have 9
gigs and six gigs becomes free that free
memory can then be reallocated and
reused across other containers used
within that Docker environment another
challenge is running multiple virtual
machines in a single environment I can
lead to instability and performance
issues whereas Docker is designed to run
multiple containers in the same
environment and actually gets better the
more containers you run in that hosted
single Docker engine portability issues
with a virtual machine is the software
can work on one machine but then when
you move that VM to another machine
suddenly some of the software won't work
because there are some dependencies that
haven't been inherited correctly whereas
Docker itself is designed specifically
to be able to run across multiple
environments and to be deployed very
easily across systems and again the
actual boot up time for a VM it just
takes a long time you're talking about
minutes in contrast to the milliseconds
that it takes for a Docker environment
to boot up so let's dig into what Docker
actually is and what allows for these
great performance improvements over a
traditional VM environment so Docker
itself is an OS virtualized software
platform and it allows it organizations
to really easily create deploy and run
applications as what are called Docker
containers that have all of the
dependencies within that container very
easily and the container itself is
really just a very lightweight package
that has all the instructions and
dependencies such as Frameworks
libraries bins Etc all within that
container and that container itself can
then be moved from environment to
environment very easily if we to look in
our devops life cycle the place where
Docker really shines is in deployments
big because when you're actually at the
point of deploying Your solution you
want to be able to guarantee that the
code that has been tested will actually
work in the production environment but
in addition to that what we often find
is that when you're actually building
the code and you're actually testing the
code having a container running the
solution at those stages is also a
really good plus because what happens is
that the people building the code and
testing the code are able to validate
their work in the same environment that
would be used for the production
environment so really you can use Docker
in multiple stages within your devops
cycle but it becomes really valuable in
the deployment stage so let's look at
some of the key advances you have with
Docker some things that we've already
covered is that you can do rapid
deployments and you can do it really
fast the environment itself is highly
portable and was designed for that in
mind the efficiencies that you'll see
will allow you to run multiple Docker
containers in a single environment as
compared to more traditional VM
environments the configuration itself
can be scripted through a language
called yaml which allows you to be able
to write out and describe the docker
environment that you want to create this
in turn allows you to be able to scale
your environment very very quickly but
with all of these advantages probably
the one that is most critical to the
type of work that we're doing today is
security you have to ensure that the
environment you are running is a highly
secure but highly scalable environment
and I'm very pleased to say that Docker
takes security very seriously so you'll
see it as one of the key tenants for the
agile architecture of the system that
you're implementing so let's look at how
Docker actually works within your
environment so Docker works there is a
what's called a Docker engine the docker
engine is really comprised of two key
elements that you have a server and a
client and the communication via the two
is via rest API the the server as you
can imagine has the instructions that
are communicated out to the client and
instructs the client on what to do the
connection between the client and the
server the communication is via a rest
API on older systems you can take
advantage of the docker toolbox which
allows you to go ahead and control the
docker engine the docker machine Docker
compose and kitamatic so let's now go
into what the actual root components
though of Docker are so let's have a
look at those key components there are
four components that we're going to go
through we have the docker clients and
server we have Docker images we have the
docker registry and the docker container
we're going to step through each of
these one by one so let's look at the
docker clients and server first so the
docker clients and server is a command
line instructed solution where you would
use terminal on your Mac or command line
on your PC or Linux system to be able to
issue commands from the docker Daemon
the community indication between the
docker client and the docker host and is
via a rest API so you can do similar
communication such as a Docker pool
command which would send an instruction
to the Daemon which would then form the
interaction of pulling in the correct
components such as an image or container
or registry to the docker client the
docker Daemon itself is actually a
service which actually performs all
sorts of operating and Performance
Services and as you'd imagine the docker
Daemon is constantly listing across the
rest API to see if it needs to perform
any specific requests if you want to
trigger and start the whole process you
what you want to do is use the command
dockered within your Docker Daemon and
that will start all of your performances
and then you have a Docker host which
actually runs the docker Daemon and
registry itself so now let's look into
the actual structure of a Docker image
so a Docker image itself is a template
split which contains instructions for
the docker container and that template
is written with a language called yaml
and yaml stands for yet another markup
language it's very easy to learn the
docker image itself is built within that
yaml file and then host it as a file in
the docket registry the image is really
comprised of several key layers and you
start with your base layer which will
typically have your base image in this
instance is your base operating system
such as Ubuntu and then you then have
layer of dependencies above that this
would then comprise the instructions in
a read-only file that would become your
Docker file so that's what you go
through and look at what one of those
sets of instructions would look like so
here we have four layers of instructions
we have a from pull run and then command
so what does that actually look like in
our layers so to break this down the
from creates a layer which is based on
Ubuntu and then what we're doing is
we're adding in files from the docker
repository onto that base command that
base layer and then what we want to be
able to do is then say okay what are the
wrong commands so we can actually then
build the container within the
environment and then we want to be able
to then have a command line that
actually executes something within that
container and in this instance the
command is to run python so one of the
things that we will see is that as we
set up multiple containers at each new
container is a new layer with new images
within the docker environment each
container is completely separate from
the other containers within your Docker
environment so you're able to create
your own separate read write
instructions within each layer what's
interesting is that if you delete a
layer then the layer above it will also
get deleted so what happens when you
pull in a layer but something has
changed change in the the core image
what's interesting then is that the
actual main image of itself cannot be
modified once you've copied the image
you can then modify it locally but you
can never modify the actual base image
itself so here are some callouts for the
components within a Docker image so the
base layer are in read-only format the
layers can be combined in a union file
system to create a single image the
union file system saves memory space by
avoiding duplication of files and this
allows a file system to appear as a
writable but without modifying the file
which is known as a copy on right the
actual base layers themselves are read
only so to be able to get around this
structure within a Docker container the
docker environment itself uses what's
known as a copy and write strategy
within the images and the containers
themselves and so what this allows you
to do is you can actually copy the files
for better efficiency across your entire
container environment the copy and write
straight energy does make Docker super
efficient and what you're able to do all
the time is keep reducing the amount of
disk space you're using and the amount
of performance that you're taking from
the server and that's really again a key
element for Docker it's just this
constant ability to be able to keep
improving the efficiency within the
actual system itself all right so let's
go on to item number three which is the
docker registry so the docker registry
itself is the place where you would host
and distribute the different types of
images that you have created or you want
to be used within your environment the
actual repository itself is just a
collection of Docker images and those
Docker images are built on instructions
that you would write with yaml and are
very easily stored and shared and what
you can actually do is you can actually
associate specific name tags to the
actual Docker images themselves so it's
easy for people to be able to find and
share that image within the docker
registry itself one of the things you
actually see is we go through the demos
you actually see us actually using the
the tag name and you'll see how it is an
alphanumeric identifier and how we
actually use it to actually create the
actual container itself one of the
things you can do to us start off how
you would manage a registry is you can
actually use the publicly accessible
Docker Hub registry which is available
to anybody but you can also create your
own registry for your own use internally
the actual registry that you create
internally can have both public and
private images that you create and this
may be for various reasons of how you'd
structure your environment the actual
commands you would use to actually
connect the registry are both push and
pull push is to actually push a new
container environment that you've
created from your local manager node to
the remote registry and a pool allows
you to pull a new client that has been
created and has been shared so again
pull command and it pulls and retrieves
a docket image from the docker registry
and makes it very easy for people to
share different images consistently
across teams and a push command allows
you to take a new command that you've
created a new container that you've
created and push it to the registry
whether it's Docker Hub or whether it's
your own private registry and allow it
to be shared across your teams some key
did you knows in Docker registry
deleting a repository is not reversible
action so if you delete a repository
it's gone so let's go into the final
stage here which is the actual Docker
container itself so the dock container
itself
um is an executable package of
applications and its dependencies
bundled together so it gives all the
instructions that you would have for the
solution that you're looking to run it's
actually really lightweight and again
this is because of the redundancy that's
built into how you structure the
container and the container itself is
then inherently also extremely portable
what's really good about running a
container though is that it does run
completely in isolation so you're able
to share it very easily from groups
group and you are guaranteed that even
if you are running a container it's not
going to be impacted by any host Os
peculiarities or unique setups as you
would have in a VM or a
non-containerized environment the actual
memory that you have on a Docker
environment that can be shared across
multiple containers which is really
useful typically when you have a vamp
you would have a defined amount of
memory for each VM environment the
challenge you start running into though
is that you can't share that memory
whereas with Docker you can easily share
the memory for a single environment
across multiple containers the actual
container is built using Docker images
and the commands to actually run those
images is a run command so this can
actually go through a basic structure of
how you would run a Docker image so you
go into terminal window and you would
write and Docker run redis and then it
would run a container called redis so
we're going to go in and if you don't
have the redis image locally installed
it will then pull it from the registry
then the new Docker container redis will
be then available within your
environment so you can actually start
using it so let's look at why containers
are so light lightweight they're so
lightweight because they really have
been able to get a away from some of the
additional layers that you have in
virtualization within VMS and the
biggest one is the hypervisor and the
need to run on a host operating system
those are two big big elements so you
can get rid of those then you're doing
great so let's look at some of the more
advanced concepts within the docker
environment and we're going to look at
two Advanced components one is Docker
compose and the second is Docker swarm
so let's look at Docker compose Docker
compose is really designed for running
multiple containers as a single service
and it does this by running each
container in isolation but allowing the
containers to interact with each other
as was stated earlier on you would
actually write the compose environment
using yaml as the language in the files
that you would create so where would you
use something like Docker compose so an
example would be if you are running an
Apache server with my SQL database and
you need to create a additional
containers to run additional services
without the need to start each one
separately and this is where you would
write a set of files using Docker
compose to be able to help balance out
that demand so let's now look at Docker
swarm so Docker swarm is a service that
allows you to be able to control
multiple Docker environments within a
single platform so what you actually are
looking at doing is within your Docker
swamp is we're treating each node as a
Docker Daemon and we're actually having
an API that's interacting with each of
those nodes there are two types of nodes
that you're going to be getting
comfortable working with one is the
manager node and the second is the
worker node and as you'd expect the
manager node is the one sending out the
instructions to all of the worker nodes
but there is a two-way communication
that is happening the communication
allows for the manager node to be able
to manage the instructions and then
listen to and receive updates from the
working node so if anything happens
within this environment the major node
can react and adjust the architecture of
the a worker node so it's always in sync
it was really great for a large scaled
environments so finally let's go through
what are some of the basic commands
you'd use within Docker and once we've
gone through all these basic commands
we'll actually show you a demo of how
you'd actually use them as well so if
we're going to go in probably the first
command is to install the docker and so
if you have yam installed you just do
yum install Docker and you'll install
Docker onto your computer to start the
docker Daemon is you want to do system
CTL start Docker the command to remove a
Docker image as Docker RMI and then the
image ID itself and that's not the image
name that's the actual alphanumeric ID
number that you want to grab the command
line to download a new image is Docker
pull and then the name of the image
you'd want to pull and by default you're
going to be pulling from the docker
default registry that will then connect
to your Docker Daemon and download the
images from that registry calendar the
command line to run an image is Docker
run and then the image ID and then we
have the if we wanted to pull
specifically from Docker Hub then we
would have a Docker pull and then the
image name and colon It's tag to pull
build an image from a Docker file you
would do Docker build Dash T and then
the image name and colon tag to shut
down the container you do Docker stop
container ID the access for running a
container is Docker exec it container ID
bash so we've gone through all the
different commands but let's actually
see how they would actually look and
we're going to go ahead and do a demo so
welcome to this demo where we're going
to go ahead and put together all of the
different commands that we have outlined
in the presentation for Docker first is
just to list all of the docker images
that we have so we do sudo Docker images
and we enter in our password
and this will Now list out the images
that we've created already and we have
three images there
so let's go ahead and pull a Docker
image so to do that we'll we'll go ahead
and type sudo docker
and actually we don't want to do image
we want to select pull and then the name
of the image that we want to pull which
is going to be my SQL
and by default this is actually going to
go ahead and use the latest MySQL
command MySQL image that we have so it's
now going to head and pull this image
it's going to take a few minutes
depending on your internet connection
speed it's kind of a large file that has
to be downloaded so we'll just wait for
that to download
you can see the others have completed
just waiting for this last file to
download almost there once that's done
we're going to go ahead and do is we'll
actually run the docking container and
create the new container using the image
that we just downloaded but we have to
wait for this to download First
all right so the image has been pulled
from Docker hub
and let's go ahead and create the new
Docker container so we're going to do
sudo docker
run Dash D
Ash p
0.0.0.0
colon 80
column 80.
and then put in my SQL
column latest so we have the latest
version
and we have our new token
and that shows our new Docker container
has been created
now let's go ahead and see if the
container is running
and we'll do sudo docker
PS
to list all the running containers and
what we see is that the container is not
listed there which means it's probably
not running so let's go ahead and list
out all of the images that we have
within Docker so we can see whether it's
actually listed there so we'll do PS
Dash a and yes there we are we can see
that we do have our new container we
want to see called latest and it was
created 36 seconds ago but it's in the
exited mode so what we have to do is we
have to change that status so it's
actually running
so let's change that to running state
we'll do sudo
docker
run
Dash
it
Dash Dash
name
and we can name it
SL
IDE SQL
MySQL
slash bin slash
and that's now going to be in the root
and we'll exit out of that and now if we
list out the docking containers we
should see it is now an active container
pseudo docker
start
and then we'll start the scene and then
and we should now see it
there we are it's now in the running
State excellent
and we can see that it was updated six
seconds ago
we're going to go ahead and we're going
to clear the screen
okay now what we want to do is remove
the docker container
so we're going to do is checklist of
images that we have
and so pseudo Docker images
here are the images that we have and we
have my sequels listed and what we want
to do is delete my SQL and to do that
we're going to type in sudo Docker RM
Dash F image MySQL
run that command and what we'll find is
the image now there's no such image oh
okay so what we actually have to do is
we have to go and see that the image is
now gone it's been removed excellent
exactly what we wanted to see
and we can also delete an image by its
image ID as well
however if an image is running and
active we have to kill that image first
so I'm going to go ahead and we're going
to select the image ID we'll copy that
and it's going to
replace that it won't be able to
actually run correctly because the image
is active so what we have to do now is
stop the image and then we can kill it
so it's in the running state
so we have to do
so we do pseudo Docker kill
and kill SL and then we'll kill the
container
and now we'll see that the container has
gone
and now we can delete the image
and that's going to be the image gone
with the image ID but boom easy peasy
okay let's go ahead on to the next
exercise which is to
so here we are we've listed all of the
uh containers and they're all gone so
let's go into the next exercise final
exercise which is to actually create a
batch image and we can do a batch HTTP
image so let's go ahead and write that
out so it's going to be Docker run
Dash did
dash dash name
white is that's going to be the name of
this HTTP service Dash p
ad 8080 colon 80 Dash V
open quotes
dollar sign PWD
close quotes
colon slash USR
slash local
slash
apache2 slash HT dogs
slash httpd
semicolon 2.4
let me run that
put in our password again
so what we see is the port is already
being used so let's go ahead and see
which ports let's go see if we can
change the port or to see what's ports
are running so let's do pseudo images
and see which ports are being used
because so the the port or the name
hasn't been put in correctly so pseudo
Docker images
PS
udedoka ps-a
and yep let's put 80 there
to clear the screen
so we're going to change the container
name because I think we actually have
the wrong container name here so let's
go and change that and we'll paste that
in and voila here we go
now working and we'll just double check
and make sure everything's working
correctly so to do that we'll go into
our web browser and we'll type in as
soon as Firefox opens up
type in localhost
colon 8080
which was the the port that we created
and there we are it's a list of all the
files which shows that the server is up
and running today we're going to cover
what is a Docker container why you would
want to consider using it in your devops
environment so let's have a look at what
we have in our current environment so
today when you actually have your
standard machine you have the
infrastructure you have the host
operating system and you have your
applications and then when you create a
virtual environment what you're actually
doing is you're actually creating
virtual machines but those virtual
machines actually are now sitting within
a hypervisor solution that sits still on
top of your host operating system and
infrastructure and with a Docker engine
what we're able to do is we're able to
actually reduce significantly the
different elements that you would
normally have within a virtualized
environment so we're able to get rid of
the the bins and the so we're able to
get rid of the guest OS and we're able
to eliminate the hyper supervisor
environment and this is really important
as we actually start working and
creating environments that are
consistent because we want to be able to
make it so it's really easy and stable
for the environment that you have within
your Dev and opt environment now
critical is getting rid of that
hypervisor element it's just a lot of
overhead so let's have a look at a
container as an example so here we
actually have a couple of examples on
the right hand side we have different
containers we have one container that's
running Apache Tomcat in it with Java a
second container is running SQL server
and microsoft.net environment the third
container is running python with mySQL
these are all running just fine within
the docker engine and sitting on top of
a host OS which could be Linux it really
could be any host OS within a consistent
infrastructure and you're able to have a
solution that can be shared easily
amongst your teams so let's have a look
at an example that you'd have today if a
company is doing a traditional Java
application so you have your developers
working in JBoss on his system and he's
coding away and he has to get that code
over to a tester now what will happen is
that tester will then typically in your
traditional environment then have to
install JBoss on their machine and get
everything running and cool and
hopefully set up identically to the
developer chances are they probably
won't have it exactly the same but
they're trying to get it as close as
possible and then at some point you want
to be able to test this within your
production environment so you send it
over to a system administrator who would
then also have to install JBoss on their
environment as well yeah this just seems
to be a whole lot of duplication so why
go through the problem of installing
JBoss three times and this is where
things get really interesting because
the challenge you have today is that
it's very difficult to almost impossible
to have identical environments if you're
just installing software locally on
devices the developer has probably got a
whole bunch of development software they
could be conflicting with the JBoss
environment the tester has similar
testing software but probably doesn't
have all the development software and
certainly the system administrator won't
have all the tools of the developer and
tester have their own tools and so what
you want to be able to do is kind of get
away from The Challenge you have of
having to do local installations on
three different computers and in
addition what you see is that this uses
up a lot of effort because when you're
having to install software over and over
again you just keep repeating doing
really basic foundational challenges so
this is where Docker comes in and Docker
is the tool that allows you to be able
to share environments from one group to
another group without having to install
software locally on device you install
all of the code into your Docker
container and simply share the container
so in this presentation we're going to
go through a few things we're going to
cover what Docker actually is and then
we're going to dig into the actual
architecture of Docker and kind of go
through what Docker container is and how
to create a Docker container and then
we'll go out through the benefits of
using Docker containers and then the
commands and finalize everything out
with a brief demo so what is darker so
darker is as you'd expect because all
the software that we cover in this
series is an open source solution and it
is a container solution that allows you
to be able to containerize all of the
necessary files and applications needed
to run the solution you're building so
you can share it from different people
in your team whether it's a developer a
tester or system administrator and this
allows you to have a consistent
environment from one group to the next
so let's kind of dig into the
architecture so you understand why
Docker runs effectively so the docker
architecture itself is built up of two
key elements there is the docker client
and then there is a rest API connection
to a Docker demon which actually hosts
the entire environment within the docker
host and the docker demon you have your
different containers and each one has a
link to a Docker registry the docker
client itself is a rest service so as
you'd expect a rest API and that sends
command line to the docker Daemon
through a terminal window or command
line interface window and we'll go
through some of these demos later on so
you can actually see how you can
actually interact with Docker the docker
Dem then checks the request against
um the docking components and then
performs the service that you're
requesting now the docker image itself
all it really is a collection of
instructions used to create container
and again this is consistent with all
the devops tools that we have the devops
tools that we're looking to use
throughout this series of videos are all
environments that can be scripted and
this is really important because it
allows you to be able to duplicate and
scale the environments that you want to
be able to build very quickly and
effectively the agile container itself
has all of the applications and the
dependencies of those applications in
one package you kind of think of it as a
really effective and efficient zip file
it's a little bit more than that but
it's one file that actually has
everything you need to be able to run
all of your Solutions the actual Docker
registry itself is an environment for
being able to host and distribute
different Docker images among your team
so say for instance you had a team of
developers that were working on multiple
different solutions so say you have a
team of developers and you have 50
developers and they're working on five
different applications you can actually
have the applications themselves the
containers shared in the docker registry
so each of those teams at any time check
out and have the latest container of
that latest image of the code that
you're working on so let's dig into what
actually is in the container so the
important part of a docking container is
that it has everything you need to be
able to run the application it's like a
virtualized environment it has all your
Frameworks and your libraries and it
allows the teams to be able to build out
and run exactly the right environment
that the developer intended what's
interesting though is the actual
applications then will run in isolation
so they're not impacting other
applications that using dependencies on
other libraries or files outside of the
container because of the architecture it
really uses a lot less space and because
it's using less space it's a much more
lightweight architecture so the files
and the actual folder itself is much
smaller it's very secure highly portable
and the boot up time is incredibly fast
so let's actually get into how you
actually create a Docker container so
the docket container itself is actually
built through command line and it's
built out of a file and Docker image so
the actual Docker file is a text file
that contains all the instructions that
you would need to be able to create that
Docker image and then we'll actually
then create all of the project code with
inside of that image then the image
becomes the item that you would share
through the docker registry you would
then use the command line and we'll do
this later on select Docker run and then
the name of the image to be able to
easily and effectively run that image
locally and again once you've created
the document you can store that in the
docker registry making it available to
anybody within your network so something
to bear in mind is that Docker itself
has its own registry called Docker Hub
and that is a public restroom so you can
actually go out and see other doc images
that have been created and access those
images as your own company you may want
to have your own private repository so
you want to be able to go ahead and
either do that locally through your own
repository or you can actually get a
licensed version of Docker Hub where you
can actually then share those files now
something that's also very interesting
to know is that you can have multiple
versions of a Docker image so if you
have a different version control
different release versions and you want
to be able to test and write code for
those different release versions because
you may have different setups you can
certainly do that within your Docker
registry environment okay so let's go
ahead and we're going to create a Docker
image using some of our basic Docker
commands and so there are essentially
really you know kind of just two
commands that you're going to be looking
for one is the build command another one
is to actually put it into your registry
which is a push command so if you want
to get a image from a Docker registry
then you want to use the pull command
and a pull command simply pulls the
image from the registry and in this
example using ngi next as our registry
and we can actually then pull the image
down to our test environment on our
local machine so we're actually running
the container within our Docker
application on a local machine we're
able to then have the image run exactly
as it would in production and then you
can actually use the Run command to
actually use the docker image on your
local machine so just say you know a few
interesting tidbits about the docking
container once the container is created
a new layer is formed on top of the
docker image layer is called the
container layer each container has a
separate read write container layer and
any changes made in that docking
container is then reflected upon that
particular container layout and if you
want to delete the container layer the
container layer also gets deleted as
well so you know why with using Docker
and containers be of benefit to you well
you know some of the things that are
useful is that containers have no
external dependencies for the
applications they run once you actually
have the container running locally it
has everything it needs to be able to
run the application so there's no having
to install additional pieces of software
such as the example we gave with JBoss
at the beginning of the presentation now
the containers are really lightweight so
it makes it very easy to share the
containers amongst your teams whether
it's a developer whether it's a tester
whether it's somebody on your operations
environment it's really easy to share
those containers amongst your entire
team different data volumes can be
easily reused and shared among multiple
containers and again this is another big
benefit and this is a reflection of the
lightweight nature of your containers
the container itself also runs in
isolation and which means that it is not
impacted by any dependencies you may
have on your own local environment so
it's a completely sandboxed environment
so some of the questions you might ask
us you know can you run multiple
containers together without the need to
start each one individually and you know
what yes you can with Docker compose
docking compose allows you to run
multiple containers in a single service
and again this is a reflection on the
lightweight nature of containers within
the docker environment so we're going to
end our presentation by looking at some
of the basic commands that you'd have
within Docker so we have here on the
left hand side we have a Docker
container and then the command for each
item we're actually going to go ahead
and use some of these commands and the
demo that we're going to do after this
presentation you'll see that in a moment
but just you know some of the basic
commands we have are committing the
docket image into the Container kill is
a you know standard kill command to you
know terminate one or more of the
running containers so they stop working
then restart those containers but
suddenly you can look at all the image
all of the commands here and try them
out for yourself so we're going to go
ahead and start a demo of how to use the
basic commands to run Docker so to do
this we're going to open up terminal
window or command line now depending
whether you're running Linux PC or Mac
and we're going to go ahead and the
first thing we want to do is see what
our Docker image lists are so we can go
sudo Docker images and this will give us
well first we'll enter in our passwords
let's go enter that in and this will now
give us a list of our Docker images and
here are the dock images I have already
been created in the system and we can
actually go ahead and actually see the
processes that are actually running so
I'm going to go ahead and open up this
window a little bit more but this will
show you the actual processes and the
containers that we actually have and so
on the far left hand side you'll see
under names we have learned simply learn
be unscore cool these are all just
different ones that we've been working
on so let's go ahead and create a Docker
image so I'm going to do sudo
docker
run
Dash D Dash p
0.0.0.0 go on a t colon 80
Ubuntu and this will allow us to go
ahead and run an Ubuntu image and this
will run the latest image and what we
have here is a hash number and this hash
number is a unique name that defines the
container that we've just created and we
can go ahead and we can check to make
sure that the container actually is
present so we're going to do
pseudo.go.ps and this actually show us
down there so it's not in a running
state right now but that doesn't mean
that we don't have it so let's list out
all the containers that are both running
and in the exits see so let's do sucker
PS Dash a and this lists all the
containers that I have running on my
machine
and this shows all the ones that have
been in the running State and in the
exit stage and here we see one that we
just created about a minute ago and it's
called learn
and these are all running Ubuntu and
this is the one that we had created just
a few seconds ago
let's open it up and
there we go so let's change that to that
new dock container to a running state so
scroll down and we're going to type sudo
docker
run
Dash it Dash Dash
name my
um so this is going to be the new
container name it's going to be my
Docker so this is how we name our Docker
environment
and we'll put in the image name which is
Ubuntu
and dash bin Dash Bash
and it's now in our route and we'll exit
out of that
so now we're going to go ahead and start
the new my Docker container so sudo
docker
start
my
and we'll get the container image which
will be my docker
my docker
return and that started that Docker
image and let's go ahead and check
against the other running Docker images
to make sure it's running correctly so
sudo docker
PS
and there we are underneath name on the
right hand side here you see my Docker
along with the other Docker images that
we created and it's been running for 13
seconds
quite fast so we want to rename the
container let's use the command sudo
docker
rename we can take another Docker image
this to scrub this one and we'll put it
in rename
and we'll rename I'm putting the old
container name which is image and then
we'll put in the new container name and
let's call it
purple
so now the container image that had
previously been called image is now
called Purple
so do sudo Docker PS
to list all of our Docker images
and if we scroll up and there there we
go purple
how easy is that to rename an image
and we can go ahead and use this command
if we want to stop container so we're
going to write sudo docker
stop
and then we have to put in the container
name
and we'll put in my Docker the container
that we originally created
and that image has now stopped
and let's go ahead and prove that we're
going to list out all the docker images
and what you see is that it's not listed
in the active images it's uh not on the
list on the far right hand side
but if we go ahead and we can list out
all of the docker images so you actually
see it's still there as an image it's
just not in an active stages what's
known as an exit state
so here we go
and there's my Docker it's in an exited
state so that happened 27 seconds ago
so if you want to to remove a container
we can use the following command
so sudo docker
RM
we'll remove
my docker
and that will remove it from the exit
state
and we're going to go ahead and we're
going to double check that
and yep
yep it's not not listed there under exit
State anymore
it's gone
and there we go
there that's where it used to be all
right let's go back
so if we want to exit a container in the
running state so we do sudo kill and
then the name of the container
I think one of them is called yellow
let's just check and see if that's going
to kill it
oops no I guess we don't have one called
yellow so let's find out name of a
container that we actually have
so pseudo docker kill oh we're going to
list out of the ones that are running oh
okay there we go now yellow isn't in
that list so let's take I know let's
take simply learn and so we can actually
go ahead and let's write sudo Docker
kill simply learn
and that will actually kill an active
Docker container
boom there we go
and we list out all the active
containers you can actually see now
that's they simply learn container is
not active anymore
and these are all the basic commands for
Docker container today we're going to
dig into Docker swarm so what we're
going to do in this session is we're
going to go through what Docker and
Docker container is and why you'd want
to use it we'll then break out what are
the characteristics and structure of a
Docker swarm environment and then
finally we'll go through and do a demo
using actual code in the command line
interface to actually run and build out
the main functions and commands that you
would use for a Docker swarm environment
so with that said let's get started so
Docker is a tool that we actually use to
help automate applications in our
environment so that we have a consistent
way that we're actually building and
testing and validating codes that's been
created think of it as a virtualization
but much more sophisticated and
efficient way of doing virtualization
the thing that you have that's a huge
Advantage when you're working with
Docker is that it's a very lightweight
software package it allows you to have
all of the tools needed for actually
running the code code without having to
have the significant overhead that you
would normally have with virtualization
so one of the characteristics you have
with Docker is that you can actually run
multiple Docker environments in the same
host environment and for you to be able
to do this we had to figure out how this
would actually run and so to actually do
this we actually do what's called a
Docker swarm and a Docker swarm is an
environment where you can actually have
multiple Docker images running on the
same host operating system so you can
have running in each of those Docker
containers different solutions so let's
dig into what a Docker swarm is so a
Docker swarm is essentially a tool that
allows you to very easily create and
schedule multiple Docker nodes so really
two or more Docker nodes and you can
have quite a large number of Docker
nodes in a single swarm each node itself
is actually a Docker demon and that
demon is able to interact with Docker
API and have all the benefits of being a
full Docker environment one of the other
advantages you have is that the each
dock container within the Swarm can then
be deployed and managed but as a node in
that entire clustered environment so
what we have here is a breakdown of the
five key elements within a Docker
environment you have the docker
container you have the Daemon the docker
images and the docker client and Docker
registry so the docker Daemon itself is
what does all the work interacting with
the actual host operating system to be
able to manage the docker containers so
if we look here here we have set up an
environment where we have three docket
container being run with Docker and what
we want to be able to do is be able to
interact with the environment because
what would happen if we actually have
something change in our environment so
we have the environment set up there's a
Docker swarm and one of our containers
fails what we're able to do is use the
Swarm to be able to correct that failure
so the docker swarm manager is able to
come in and reschedule containers and as
you would imagine the actual swarm note
has full backups and full redundancy for
any kind of failures that would happen
and we would do all of this work through
command line interface so let's go
through some of the features that you
have within the actual Docker swarm
itself so a key feature for Docker swarm
is that it is fully decentralized which
means that it makes it very easy for
teams to be able to access and manage
the environment as you would expect as
well is that the communication that
happens between the manager and client
nodes within the swamp is highly secure
and of course this is really just a
fundamental that you should have for any
kind of solution but it is good to know
that Docker swarm has that built in
there is also Auto load balancing within
your environment and you can actually
script that into how you write out and
structure your swarm environment and
that load balancing then also allows you
to then convert that swarm environment
into a highly scalable infrastructure
and then rollback task allows you to be
able to roll back environments to
previous safe environments so say
something does get pushed out and
something breaks you're able to
immediately roll back into a safe
environment so each of the containers
are pushed out and and are controlled
using services and they actually happen
to be breast Services which make it very
easy for you to be able to integrate
within your environment and each of the
different Services contains a group of
containers of the same image Now by
having this structure it allows you to
be able to scale your application
appropriate to the demands on your
server so if you have a service that
needs to have a significantly larger a
number of services for it to run you can
actually scale that appropriately and
they can be either Geo or demand based
one of the requirements for setting up a
double swarm is you must have at least
one node deployed so the way that the
architecture is set up is that you have
a major node and a client node and there
must be one of each for the entire
environment to be able to work
effectively so you know here we are just
jumping ahead of sales a little bit we
have two types of nodes in a Docker
swamp we have the major node and we have
the worker node which is the client that
does the actual execution of the tasks
the manager node very similar to other
systems that we've talked about on
simply learn allows you to actually
control and manage the actual tasks that
are being executed by the worker nodes
and the worker nodes as you can imagine
and then actually execute the
instructions that the manager are
sending out to it so here we have a
situation where we can illustrate what
would happen with a manager node sending
out commands to different workers nodes
the manager is fully aware of the status
of the entire swarm environment at all
times this is because of the two-way
secure communication that's going from
the manager to the worker environment
the workers as you'd expect are
accepting tasks that are being sent from
the manager so the manager sends out a
task saying that you need to be running
as a MySQL environment then the working
node will then convert to a MySQL
environment and all of these
environments are scripted and controlled
by you as the manager the actual worker
nodes themselves actually have a client
agent and that client will then
communicate all different states of the
infrastructure back to the manager so
that anytime the manager node is in full
control of the entire swarm the magic is
the controller of this environment and
so you always want to be able to ensure
that the manager has full access to all
the work that's happening within the
Swan and this allows you as the manager
to be able to control your swarm and
very quickly be able to react to any
changes without having to rely on manual
installations of software and hardware
and as we covered earlier on there is a
rest API that uses the communication
over HTTP from the manager to the worker
node it's interesting to note that it is
a rest API because if you wanted to you
could actually integrate that API into
custom applications and even then create
automated Docker images to be created on
demand from third-party solutions that
you may want to create so one of the
things that's a really a big Advantage
with having a swarm is that once you've
actually created the form any of the
services that you create can be accessed
by any node of the same cluster one of
the things you do have to do though is
you have to specify what container image
that you're going to use when you're
creating a new servers and you can do
that either through a centralized Docker
hub environment or through your own
private Docker Hub environment one of
the things that's interesting is that
you can set up commands and services to
be either Global or replicated a global
Service will allow you to run a service
consistently on every node within the
Swarm whereas a replicated service will
only push out functionality and tasks to
specific worker nodes within a swarm so
you may be asking yourself hey is it a
service and task the same thing no
they're kind of not in the docker world
and the difference is is a service is a
description of a task for the state
whereas the actual task is the work that
needs to get done and that's the
differentiator here so what you can do
as a Docker user is you actually create
services and then you can then Define
when you want them to start as tasks now
what's interesting is that when you do
assign a task to a node that same task
cannot be assigned to another node also
what's in interesting is that you can
actually have multiple managers within a
Docker swarm environment if you do
however go down this path you have to
elect one manager to be the primary
manager and the other managers to be
secondary managers in many ways those
secondary managers are really similar in
concept to worker nodes in which they
have the capability of a manager but
they are dependent on that single
primary manager to be able to provide
the right instructions and for services
and tasks to the entire swarm
environment so if we kind of recap some
of these we have a command line
interface which allows us to create and
connect via apis and that those apis
that we connect to in our store
environment allows us to do
orchestration via tasks and services the
task allocation allows us to allocate
work to tasks via their IP address which
allows them to execute them on the work
and then the worker nodes themselves
have to connect to the manager you know
to be able to check for when tasks come
in so that they are keeping a consistent
communication back and forth across the
entire swarm and then the final stage is
to actually execute the tasks that have
been assigned from the manager node to
the work node so that you have a
successful execution of the solution
you're looking to build all right so
with that said let's go ahead and we're
going to do a demo so we're going to go
ahead and do a demo and showing how you
can run Docker Swan for this you'll need
to have both a virtual environment
running your manager and you're working
in firing mode so here we have our
worker and here we have our manager so
we're just going to open up terminal
window and we're going to go into the
manager for terminal window so the
following command here is used to
initialize Docker swarm which is going
to type this in so sudo Docker swarm in
it
and we purchased the IP address for the
network we're connecting to
open in our password
and here we have now connected
and this is our manager node and what we
want to be able to highlight is the
specific token which identifies the
docker swarm environment and this is our
token right here so we're going to copy
that
because we'll need to use that for our
worker environment so here we are in the
worker environment and we'll use the
token that we just copied
um as a way to be able to connect to the
manager and connect to the docker swarm
environment
and so sudo
I'll paste in the darker swarm and we'll
join that I will now here we shows that
we have joined the Swarm environment as
a worker
and now we're in the manager we can
actually show that we actually have
that worker in the environment so
there's Docker node LS to list out all
of the
items in that environment
sorry we actually did that in the wrong
area so we want to write pseudo Docker
node allows to list out all the nodes in
the Swarm and there you are you see
we've actually connected the worker to
the manager node and both are active and
the manager is the leader and the worker
virtualbox is in the Swarm
okay we're going to go ahead and create
a new service so Docker Swan create and
we're going to just change the name to
hello world for the new service and
we're going to use the Alpine image from
docker.com
takes just a moment for it to run
there we go
and there we go Services converged
so what we have now is a new service
that has been created
let's go ahead and we'll list out the
services
and here we have our new Hello World
Service
and we go ahead and check the docking
containers and we're going to do Docker
PS and here's our Alpine it's running
the latest image
and that's the docker container ID
and we can see that it was just updated
and so we're going to do is use the same
command in the worker node
and make sure everything is working over
there
so go over to our worker paste that in
so what we see here is there is no image
or container created because it's not in
the worker node it would be in the
manager node
so we can go ahead and create the new
service
and we will make the Mode Global and
that way the service is available across
all of the Swarm
so we're just going to execute that work
takes a moment
and
there we are
done work has been completed and we have
the two different IDs which shows that
two different Services running and if we
go back to the working mode and we run
sudo.go PS again and there we are now we
see that we have the hello world
new virtual environment has been added
with the image of Alpine and we also
have the new token ID for that
if we want to kill a node from the Swarm
we can use the following command which
is pseudo Docker swamp leave dash dash
force and that will force the node to
leave the Swarm today we're going to
cover Docker compose so in this session
what we're going to do is we're going to
go through what Docker is and then by
extension what Docker compose is and how
it improves the performance of Docker
what the benefits of working with Docker
compose is we are going to cover as well
what the difference between Docker
compose and Docker sworn is because the
two products are similar but they have
two different types of jar and at the
end of this presentation we'll take you
through some basic commands that allow
you to get up and running working with
Docker and Docker compose finally after
this presentation we'll do a brief demo
that allows you to get up and running
using some of these commands to do your
own Docker compose environment so let's
get started with Docker compose so first
of all we have to kind of cover what
Docker is so Docker has come as an
evolution of Technology energies that
started with virtual machines VM machine
and a VM machine allowed you to run at a
complete operating system and complete
operating system and its environment on
your own computer in your own operating
system without interfering that the
problem was is that it was very heavy
and complex and in contrast Docker is a
much more lightweight and more flexible
environment that you can automate with
scripts so we have to remember that the
container itself is just software and it
has dependencies that run within that
application that are managed by a Docker
so we have a look at the way Dockers
broke now first of all we have the
docker image and we have the docker
image created by a Docker file and the
docker file is a text-based script and
that text file within dockerfile
actually has all the commands that allow
you to run the appropriate Technologies
within the docker image so the docker
image allows you to be able to have a
wide group of people and consistently
run on the same environments and if you
want to be able to share that Docker
image effectively you would do so by
uploading to Docker Hub and Docker Hub
can be available either publicly through
the the public Docker Hub website or you
can actually set up your own private
Enterprise Docker Hub to share your own
images across your own network and then
from Docker Hub people can then pull
their own Docker image and build new
containers that are consistent on the
original Docker container that you've
created so it's a great way of being
able to have your entire team scale up
easily and effectively so one of the
questions that will come up though is
what if you want to use two containers
in a single service and an example of
this might be like a web server that is
using a database but the database may be
in one container and the web server may
be in another container which is very
typical for your own web and database
infrastructure so very similar I'm
scenario but how would you do this with
Doc okay so by using just darker itself
it's actually very difficult to do this
you can do it but it's just very time
consuming and just not a very good use
of your productivity but with Docker
compose you can actually do the whole
process quite quickly and easily and
hence the reason why we have Docker
compose to allow you to have two or more
Docker containers running in the same
environment being able to communicate as
if they were running in a production
environment so let's dig into what
Docker compose is so let's consider a
scenario that you'd have today so Mitra
is a fashion website similar to Amazon
and you go to Mantra with your web
browser and on that website you would go
through a number of activities such as
logging into your account browsing a
catalog you'd have your checkout
application server and you go through
the table process of building out an
application behind each of these
services are different different
products such as you have an account
database you'd have a product database
different checkout processes and these
would all be run behind the scenes and
each of these can be considered a micro
service so the more microservices you
build into your environment the more
complexity you're adding and the more of
value it would be to have each of these
services in their own container but as a
developer you want to be able to jump
from one container to another container
so your login account can then be passed
on to your product catalog and then be
able to move through the whole process
so the environment that you would see
today would be small like what we're
showing right now where you'd have your
server and your database and you may
have a server running on an Apache
Tomcat or a SQL Server you'd have
different databases and you'd want to be
able to have each of those in their own
containerized environment so the way
that duck compose runs is that it works
as a single service so you have the
docker was running multiple containers
but the perception is of a single
service run the thing that's great
though is that each of those containers
will run in their in isolation and but
they can interact with each other so
unlike a normal Docker environment where
you have multiple Docker images running
completely in isolation of each other
these are images that will run in
isolation but can interact with each
other the docker compose files are very
easy to write they're all written with a
scripting language called yaml and yaml
is an XML based language it actually
stands for yet another markup language
but it's an XML based language and it's
very easy to use the great thing about
learning yaml is that a lot of Open
Source tools in the devops environment
use yaml as the scripting lane and then
finally in Docker compose as a user you
can actually go and and Trigger all your
services within the containers to start
with a single camera on as you can
imagine this dramatically reduces the
the amount of work that you as a
developer have to do so let's take an
example of if you're running a container
one with a nijex server and one with a
redis database uh you can create a yaml
Docker compose file that actually has
the instructions on the containers
needed to build out both environments
and then you can run each of those
environments separately but have them
connected as a single service so the
benefits of dock and compose is that you
have a single host deployment
environment you can run this all on one
piece of Hardware you can have a quick
and easy configuration using yaml
scripts the productivity that you get
has developers significantly increases
because you're not having to have time
wasted trying to configure just
traditional Docker containers by
themselves you now have a way of being
able to interact with those containers
and then finally security is at the
center of all of these containers so
each of those contain trainers are
completely isolated from each other and
they are controlled with the same level
of security that you'd have with a
traditional Docker image but there is a
question here around Docker compose
isn't it similar in concept to Docker
Swan because at a high level it kind of
seems like both do the same thing and
the answer is well you actually know
they're different there are similarities
but there are also differences and
particularly for a developer these
differences will really start coming out
in scale as you start working on your
Solutions so let's look at Docker
compose right so Docker compose will
allow you to create multiple containers
on a single host and that's the
important part of having a single host
which is maybe your development PC with
Docker swarm it also allows you to
create multiple containers however you
have to manage those multiple containers
on multiple hosts which makes a lot of
sense if you're running an operations
environment but not so much if you're
doing a development environment and
Docker compose is scripted with yaml
which is very easy for you to be able to
control your scripts Docker swarm
doesn't have a scripting technology like
yaml so it's a little bit harder to work
with so what we have here is just some
basic commands that allow you to get up
and started working with Docker compose
in our next demo we're actually going to
take you through how to use all of those
commands so we're going to go ahead and
do a demo on how to use Docker compose
and the first thing you want to do is
check that you have Docker installed so
what we're going to do is we're going to
open up the command window and we're
going to type in Docker you'll be able
to see now that we have Docker installed
if you don't have dog installed go ahead
and install Docker you can go to Google
Search to install Docker and it'll give
you the instructions for that we also
have videos that we've already done if
once you have dock installed then you
want to do a Google search on Docker
compose or go to the docker.com website
and search for the compose close section
and look for the install Docker compose
instructions so we already have another
tab which has the instructions already
installed you'll see on the left hand
side there are a number of Docker tools
you want to expand the docker compose
section select install compose and then
on the right hand side you'll have
different install options for Mac
windows and Linux if you're installing
on those platforms make sure you're
copying the correct command line so
there's a couple command ones you want
to copy copy the first one over and we
paste that in and it's going to go ahead
and download all of the files for
compose it takes a while but we have to
get another file so while it's
downloading we'll go get the other
command line just go back and grab it
real quick it's a little faster but
we'll copy that over there was a second
command instruction and post that
command yep there's the command right
there and that will apply the
appropriate binary sorry and once you've
done that you can actually go ahead and
validate that you have the correct
version of Docker compose installed and
for that you want to write the command
Docker Dash compose space dash dash
version and that will then give you a
version build once you know that you
have a version build that means that you
have everything installed correctly on
your machine so you can see here that we
have a version number which means we
have everything installed you might see
a different version number depending on
how old the video is when you're
watching it but they're using very
content at the moment and just go ahead
and clear the screen and now what we're
going to do is create a folder where
we're actually going to install the yaml
file that will have the instructions for
our docking compose environment so we're
moving the cursor to the desktop and on
the desktop we're going to create a new
folder and using the MK derive command
and we'll call this one Docker compose f
for file and then we'll move the cursor
into that new folder by using CT command
and now we are in the folder called
Docker compose F and you can go look at
your desktop and you'll see it's there
and now you want to select and pound
touch Docker Dash compose Dot yml and
they'll actually create the new yaml
file for you and you can use the ls list
command LS Docker Dash compose.yaml and
they'll allow you actually now to step
in and edit that file so let's go ahead
and hit return and they'll allow us to
go in and edit the file so now I'm in
the editor and I'm going to write some
instructions
um so I'm I'm going to put a couple of
mistakes in these instructions so we can
see how Docker pose catches those
mistakes and so but most this is going
to be fairly correct so you can just
type this out so we're going to start
with Services colon then we'll do a web
colon and then we create image colon and
we'll do ninjix and then we'll do a
database colon and and we call the image
redis and so what you can see because we
have two reference images we're actually
calling two different images two
different containers that will be
created by Docker Hub uh so what we're
going to do is uh where we can actually
show you um how that's pulling in you
can go to Docker Hub and you can
actually see the references to the
images that we've just created so go to
Docker help which is Hub hub.docker.com
and you'll see that uh ninjix redis
those are the default names for the
images so you could do other images like
HTTP for Apache web server if you wanted
to there are a lot of images in Docker
Hub so certainly have a lot of fun
building uh tools from that environment
so we're going to save those files in
the doc image and we're just going to do
colon WQ to exit this screen I save the
text and let's go and run our yaml file
and you'll see the two different
different error messages that will come
up so we're going to do cat Docker Dash
compose Dot yml and here we have a
display of the text that we just wrote
and now let's go check the validity of
the file that we just created so we'll
do Docker Dash compose config and we
should get an error message and there we
are error message and the reason why we
have an error message is because the
spacing is not correct in the yaml file
itself so let's go to the actual yaml
file that we created let's go through
and we're going to use uh just the file
finder and you'll actually open up the
yaml file in your text editor your
favorite text editor and here we have
the code that created it and let's use
the correct spacing so that everything
is spaced out appropriately in the image
and so this is the spacing that you'd
expect to see a space a line between
surfaces and the first image and the
first image is a tab in and then it
refers what the image is and let's go
ahead and clear the screen and we'll see
whether or not we've got that all
correct this clear screen and we're
going to check that everything is
running correctly and we're seeing we're
still getting an error message and the
reason why we're getting another error
is that there's still a config error in
this the actual yaml file so one of the
things you have to do when you're
creating a yaml file for Docker
composers you actually have to have the
appropriate version number in there so
what we have to do is we have to go and
find which is the appropriate version
and there are three major versions one
two and three depending on the age of
Docker that you have installed on your
computer so if you have the very latest
version of Docker 18 and newer you would
put 3.7 as the version number and what
we're going to do is we're going to just
check on the version that we have
installed and so just clear the screen
and then we'll just do Docker version
and what we have is our version of
Dockers 7
18.12 now this is the version of Docker
not Docker compose it's your main Docker
environment and so if we go back to our
web browser we'll actually see that
version 17 should align with version
number 3.5 yep there we are version 3.5
so what we want to do is go back into
our yaml file in the very first line
that we want to put in above the
surfaces is the version number and that
version number we're going to put in is
3.5 so we type in version version and
we'll put colon and then version number
is in in quotes and you save that and
now what we can actually do is we can
actually go ahead and use the single
line instruction to run both of these uh
two images that we've created because
everything is configured correctly or
just one note you'll see that the
version number is actually at the bottom
of the list and that's just the way
Docker compose works it pulls out the
services and the images that you'd
create and then push the image the
version number at the bottom of the list
so in the presentation we talked about
how you can use one line to trigger two
or more images and so to do that we're
going to do sudo Docker Dash compose R
Dash D and it's going to create the two
environments we have the web environment
and the database environment and let's
use pseudo Docker PS to actually list
out that all the processes that are
running right now and there we are we
actually see all of the images are
running we have the names the commands
the images and everything's up and
running and if we want to close both of
those images we can actually use a
single line of command as well and that
command will be pseudo Docker Dash
compose down and that closes both of the
images and we can see that all the
databases and the web server his images
have been closed and pseudo Docker PS
will actually lists that there is
nothing running and that's how to use
Docker compose and with that we come to
the end
if understanding of what exactly full
stack development is and I hope you
enjoyed learning these different tools
so thank you so much for being here and
watch out for more videos from us until
then keep learning and stay tuned to
Simply learn